welcome to this rust programming course
for beginners this comprehensive course
will guide you step by step through the
fundamentals of rust enabling you to
build robust and efficient applications
from understanding basic syntax and data
types to exploring more advanced topics
like lifetimes and closures arfan zubi
will provide clear explanations and
Hands-On exercises to ensure you grasp
every concept effectively get ready to
unlock the power of rust and elevate
your programming skills to new heights
hi my name is Irfan and I will be your
guide in this comprehensive for us
course for beginners so if you're
interested in learning rust then
congratulations you have found the right
course
so I've designed this course to ensure
that you will learn rust the proper way
using slides and visuals to illustrate
Concepts and providing exercises we will
solve together this means you will have
an appropriate mix of theory and
practice that will help you step by step
mastering this new awesome programming
language
and I strongly advise you to code along
because you will learn so much more when
actively participating rather than just
watching the video
so let's Dive In
so what are the goals of this course
first and foremost getting familiar with
Core Concepts and syntax of the language
we will take a look at data types and
data structures as well as ownership and
borrowing we will see how data is
allocated in memory and how we access
the data and we'll take a look at
standard Library generics trades
lifetimes and much much more basically
everything you need to become a great
rust developer
so why would you want to learn rust now
there would be I guess a thousand
reasons but I have here put together
some of the main ones now rust is a
really fast language in terms of
execution time it provides a rich type
system it doesn't have a garbage
collector which is part of the reason
why it's so fast
it provides useful compiler outputs and
you will see that in the exercises we
are solving it guarantees memory safety
and it's the most beloved programming
language since 2016 according to stack
overflow meaning now seven years in a
row and we are experiencing fast
adoption in various branches
foreign
now over here you can see a table which
shows various programming languages and
their score in terms of Energy
Efficiency and execution time and as you
can see rust is one of the languages on
the top of the list
now over here are some resources that
you can learn with now I guess the main
resource would be the RAS programming
language
really fantastic book and I recommend
you to read it then there is rustlings
these are small exercises basically
programs which you have to debug
then there is Ross by example so if your
style is more focusing code and less on
text then this would be suitable for you
and there is a website called rust by
practice and that is what we will cover
together
and if you want to go more advanced
there is a book called Russ forestations
and it's also very much recommended to
eat it
so before we dive into the first topic I
want to show you the website of lost by
practice and you can access it by going
to the URL practice dot RS
and this is the website
and over here as you can see these are
all the topics we will cover together
right now this will be the first one
variables
and as you can see over here we have
small exercises that we will solve
together
now before we start I want to show you
something else and of course we'll keep
up with the tradition and write a hello
world program
so you can go to the
rustlang.org website this is the
official website of the rust foundation
and you can click over here playground
and as you can see over here you can
write rascode and then execute it
and it's really cool because you even
have the Vim key bindings over here and
you can even choose themes
like that
and let's write our first program so
every program in Rust starts in the main
function this is the starting point of
execution of every rust program
and we declare functions with the FN
keyword
so to print out to standard output we
can use the print line macro
as you can see we write print Ln
exclamation mark and then we can provide
here the string we want to Output
like that
and then you can hit run
and as you can see we have executed our
first program so congratulations I hope
you coded along and now we start with
the actual course
so variables variables are assigned
using the LED keyword so if you're
coming from a JavaScript background this
might seem familiar
you can print to standard output by the
print or print Ln macros
so print and print Ln are basically very
much the same but print Ln adds a new
line at the end of the output
and scope of a variable is defined by
the block of code in which it is
declared
now a function is a named block of code
that is reusable
and shadowing allows a variable to be
redeclared in the same scope with the
same name
so let's solve some exercises
binding and mutability a variable can be
used only if it has been initialized
fix the arrow below with least amount of
modification to the code
so again we are starting always in the
main function
now over here we have two variables
and again we declare variables with the
let keyword then the name and over here
we have a type annotation now don't
worry too much for now we'll cover that
in the next topic to come but for now
think of i32 as an integer type
right
and then we have here the assert EQ
macro which stands for assert equality
so this macro takes two arguments and
just basically asserts that these two
are equal
in case they are not equal the program
will Panic meaning immediate exiting and
returning an error message
if there are in fact equal then the
program will just continue executing
so as you can see we want here that X is
equal to a value of 5 so we can
initialize X over here with with a value
of 5 like that
and to run this program you can either
click here or you can press Ctrl enter
and let's read that over here
uninitialized but used error
so when you use a variable it has to be
initialized with a value which makes
sense right you can't use something
which isn't initialized yet
now y over here is uninitialized but
also unused this will only output a
warning now over here you can see the
warning actually
but if I take this code and put it over
here
as you can see it gives us a warning
unused variable y
okay to fix that we can prepend it with
an underscore
like that
all right
use mute to Mark a variable as mutable
so in Rust a variable in its nature is
immutable and you have to explicitly
state that you want a variable to be
mutable
so fill the blanks in the code to make
it compile as you can see we are here
using a variable X so we want over here
to declare X and initialize it with a
value of 1.
now over here we are mutating X which
means this variable X over here should
be mutable and we do that using the mute
keyword like that
now this over here
is shorthand Syntax for this
all right so we take the value of one
we add 2 to it and then we assign it
back to X meaning X will then hold 3.
right now
just a quick note I will always try to
annotate the type in this course most of
the time it's not necessary so when you
see me annotating types it's actually
not because this is necessary but just
because I want to make stuff as clear as
possible so in this case this would hold
an integer type and again we will cover
that in the next topic
let's see
as you can see this is compiling X is
equal to 3.
scope a scope is the range within the
program for which the item is valid
fix the error below with least amount of
modification
so over here we are initializing the
variable x with a value of 10.
an integer type all right
now
now here we have another scope we also
can call it the inner scope and this
would be the outer scope right so in
this scope over here we are declaring
another variable y now
we over here try to print out X and Y
and we can do that by placing inside the
print Ln macro these placeholders over
here
and then providing as additional
arguments over here the variables we
want to put the values inside here
so for example if we provide X over here
then this will get replaced by 10
because X is holding a value of 10.
and as you can see in the outer scope we
are doing exactly the same
now this program won't compile
and the reason is because a variable is
only valid inside the scope in which it
was declared so for example the variable
Y is declared inside the scope meaning
T variable Y is only valid until this
point
all right that means we can't use y here
so what would be the solution
solution would be very simple we just
initialize the variable y in the main
scope in the outer scope over here
meaning X and Y both of them are valid
until this point over here
right because this over here is the main
scope
let's see
as you can see this is compiling
fix the error with the use of Define X
now we can have other functions besides
main so over here we have the function
define X
and as you can see we are initializing a
variable X which holds a string
now this would be
T-Type annotation for a string
right don't worry too much about the
annotations now because we will cover
that but just to let you know now the
problem here is that in main we are
trying to access X now in this scope
over here there is no variable with the
name of X which means that this program
won't compile because the compiler will
tell you I can't find over here a
variable with the name of X so what we
can do over here is actually taking this
line and putting it inside the function
over here because as you can see in this
scope of the function a variable X has
been declared and initialized
but if I run this program now
nothing will happen
and that's because as I've said the
starting point of every Ras program is
in the main function now
when we run the code nothing will get
executed
and that's because we have to actually
call this function for it to do
something so in this case
we can call a function like that
just providing the name of the function
and these parentheses
and as you can see the output will be
hello world right because over here we
are
providing x to the print line macro and
we are appending to it comma world
like that
shadowing you can declare a new variable
with the same name as a previous
variable here we can say the first one
is shadowed by the second one
only modify a sort EQ to make print Line
work print 42 in terminal as you can see
over here we are initializing the
variable X which holds an i32 type
an integer type
now in this scope over here we are
initializing another variable with the
same name X but over here we are
initializing it with a value of 12
instead of 5.
and that means when we assert the value
of x over here it should actually be 12
right
now what would be the value of x in this
outer scope
if you set 5 then you're right
because
this variable over here has been
declared in the main scope in this scope
over here that means X is holding a
value of 5. now in this scope over here
x holds a value of 12.
and these are basically two different
worlds right so the variable X declared
in the main scope doesn't actually care
about the variable X declared in this
scope over here
they are separate
now over here we are shadowing X in the
main scope meaning we re-declare and
re-initialize the variable X again with
an integer type
now when we output X it should actually
print out 42.
as you can see this will be the output
number six remove a line in the code to
make it compile now over here we have a
mutable variable X which holds one
an integer type then we are assigning 7
to X now X holds
seven right
then we are shadowing and rebinding so
we are re-declaring X and
re-initializing it and we initialize it
with
a value of x meaning with 7 right
and then over here we are mutating X
and that means we are here incrementing
x by 3.
again using this front end notation
which would equate to that
and
this would actually fail and I want you
to look at it and think about it what
over here might cause an error
so over here as you can see we are
re-declaring X
and over here we are mutating X now as
I've said every variable in Rust is in
its nature immutable meaning if we
redeclare X like that X will be
immutable even if it was mutable over
here when we Shadow it then it will be
immutable again so what we can do over
here is just using
the mute keyword again so X stays
mutable
now
you might ask okay why even shadowing we
can just assign a new value to X why is
this even a thing
and you can see that here very good so y
over here holds an integer type right
integer 4. now when shadowing we can
assign to the variable a a value of
another type in this case for example a
string right so y will then hold a
string type
right let's run that
and as you can see this compiles now
this line over here is completely
useless I hope you notice that because
we are taking X and assign it again to X
which basically is the exact same thing
as we had over here so completely
useless of course they are doing that to
learn the concept
but in real life you don't need this
line all right you can just do it like
that
and as you can see this also compiles
unused variables fix the warning below
with only one solution two distinct
Solutions so as you can see of course we
want two stores so we will do with two
solutions
now the problem here is that this
program won't actually output warnings
right so I will again copy that
and I will put it
and I will put it inside the rust
playground
like that so if we run this program now
as you can see we get a warning unused
variable X now I have showed you that
before the easiest method would be to
prevent the variable name with an
underscore
as you can see we don't get the warning
over here the second way would be to do
it like that
this is
telling the compiler that it should
allow
unused variables
so if you run it again
as you can see no warning
so we have solved that
destructuring we can use pattern with
lead to destructure a tuple to separate
variables
now tuples we will cover that in a later
topic
but for now just think of tuples as a
data structure that can hold
um various values even of different
types
so fix the arrow below with least amount
of modification
so as you can see over here we have a
tuple right holding two integers one and
two and this over here is called
destructuring so we are using the let
keyword and we use this syntax over here
to this structure these values into
variables X and Y so X will then hold a
value of 1 and y will hold a value of 2.
now over here we are mutating X
now again
this variable here would be immutable
because in Rust every variable in its
nature is immutable and we have to
explicitly state that we want to have it
mutable
so what we can do over here like we did
before we use the mute keyword
like that and then this should actually
compile so X holds one here and then we
increment X by two so extrude in the
nthole 3 and Y should stay the same as
it was
and as you can see this is compiling the
structuring assignments introduced in
Rust 1.59 you can now use Tuple slice
and struct patterns as the left hand
side of an assignment
so this is very useful actually
so we can declare two variables at once
so here we declare X and Y and this
would be the same like writing let X and
let y
right so you're writing one line of code
instead of two lines here
now again we declare here the variables
and we can then
destructure these data structures over
here so we have here a tuple and we are
destructuring it and notice over here we
don't need to use the let keyword again
because we have already declared these
variables over here
right
so we assign 3 to X and this value over
here we don't care about so we can use
these double dots over here
now this over here is an array and again
we will cover that don't worry and this
array holds two values now we don't care
about the first one but we want to
destructure the second one into a
variable called y
now fill the blank to make the code work
in this case we have here an array right
remember assert EQ takes two arguments
and both of them have to be the same
equate to the same output right so what
would be the value of x
it would be 3. because we have this
structured here 3 into the variable X
and the same goes for here we have this
structured 2 into a variable Y which
means y will then hold two
all right and we are done with the first
topic easy start and see you next time
now let's look at numbers in Rust and
we'll start with integer types
now an integer is basically a whole
number meaning it doesn't have a
fractional part
and integers can come in two different
forms they can either be signed or
unsigned now a signed integer can
represent both positive and negative
numbers
and I remember that because signed might
stand for the minus sign that could be
prepended to it
and unsigned integers are always
positive integers meaning they don't
have a minus sign hence unsigned
now integers can come in different
lengths so there can be 8-bit integers
16-bit 32 up until
128 bits and each length over here has
two distinct types one for signed and
one for unsigned so for example if we
have a variable which holds an unsigned
8-bit integer we would type annotate
that with the type u8
or for example we have a signed 64-bit
integral we would annotate it as i64.
now the last element in the table over
here is Arc and Arc stands for
architecture now that means that the
size of these two types eye size and U
size are dependent on the computer's
architecture now I guess most of you
guys today run computers with 64-bit
architecture meaning Isis new size have
a size of 64 bits or 8 bytes
All Right Now the default types in Rust
are for integers i32 and for floats f64
so if we don't annotate anything the
compiler will infer it to these types
now my head is in the way
now to make sense of all of this you
will have to understand the binary
number system
now if you're familiar with binary just
skip ahead because you don't learn
anything new here but I just want to
ensure that we are all on the same page
so if we consider this decimal number
over here 42
and let's look at each distinct digit so
we would have 4 and we would have two
right
now 2 would be in the ones place and
four would be in the tenths place
and if we would have more digits here
here would be the hundreds place
thousands place and so on
now
as you can see we are here using a base
of 10. why is that because in the
decimal system we have 10 distinct
digits to represent numbers right 0 to
9. and as you can see we are here doing
an exponentiation with an exponent of
zero because this is actually a
mathematical rule which states that
anything with an exponent of 0 will
always evaluate to one so it doesn't
matter which base you use if you have an
exponent of 0 the result will always be
one right 10 to the power of 0 would be
1 4 to the power of 0 would be one and
so on
and over here we have 10 to the power of
1 which would be 10 right and then what
we do is just we are multiplying the
digits of our number with these
exponentiations right so we would for
example here 4 times 10 to the power of
1 plus 2 times 10 to the power of 0.
now again 10 to the power of 1 would be
10 and 10 to the power of 0 would be one
and then we would multiply these numbers
together and then add this and we would
have 42 right something which is very
natural to you and you don't even think
about it right because decimal numbers
are everywhere now in computers things
actually look a little bit different
let's for example again consider the
decimal number 42 now this would be the
binary representation of this number
zero zero one zero one zero one zero
and as you can see we have here eight
digits now a digit is called bit right
and a bit is the smallest possible unit
of information a computer can hold okay
now we have eight bits over here and
eight bits make up one byte
and we over here have actually the same
logic as we did over here but with a
base of two because again we can only
represent two digits in a computer and
that's because a transistor can only be
in one of two states either it's
conducting electric current or it's
non-conducting zero or one
right so
the logic stays the same here we have 2
to the power of 0 which would be one
because of the rule we have talked about
2 to the power of 1 would be two two to
the power of 2 would be four two to the
power of 3 would be eight and so on and
as you notice the number here doubles
one two four eight sixteen and so on
now
this over here is actually the
fascinating part about computers to me
personally because it's just crazy if
you think that everything
represented this video over here and
graphical models and 3D games and
everything is stored and represented
with only two digits
mind-blowing right
so
we actually here do the same thing we
are just multiplying
the bits over here with the
exponentiations
now we won't consider the zero bits
because anything multiplied by zero will
always be zero right so we are just
caring about the one bits over here so
we are multiplying one times two to the
power of one which would be 2 right
because 1 times 2 would be two then one
times two to the power of 3 which would
equate to 8 and 1 times 2 to the power
of 5 which would be 32 as you can see
over here and then we are basically just
adding these numbers together and we
have 42 and this is the way your
computer stores all of your data
all right
now you might ask okay how far can we go
with this what would be the largest
possible number we can represent
and let's for that see the range of
8-bit integers
so the smallest possible unsigned 8-bit
integer would be zero right I hope this
makes sense because if we have a zero in
every position over here the result will
just be zero right now the largest
possible unsigned 8-bit integer would be
255.
and that's the case when every single
position over here holds A1 right and
again we are then just multiplying D1 by
the exponentiations over here and add it
together
and you might now think okay 255 isn't a
lot what if I want to represent bigger
numbers and there is a simple solution
to that
you're just adding more bits over here
right because the more bits we have the
larger number we can represent
so let's see for example a 16 bit
integer again the smallest possible
16-bit integer unsigned would be zero
and this is if every position over here
holds zero
now the largest possible 16-bit integer
unsigned would be 65
535 okay and again this would just be if
we had in every single position a one
right again just adding the results of
the exponentiations over here all
together and we would have this result
now as you can see the more bits we have
the more we can represent
now what about signed integers again
sine integers can represent negative
numbers
so signed integers use a concept called
tools complement
where the processor will take a number
over here
for example 42 and this would be the
binary representation of this number
then it will invert this binary number
meaning a 0 becomes a 1 and 1 becomes
zero right just inverting
and then after inverting the number we
add one single bit okay so we add one
here this would then equate to zero and
we have a carry of one
and then we add here one and we would
have one and the rest says the same now
this would then be the binary
representation of minus 42.
or negative 42. now the most significant
bit over here is actually the sine bit
if it is zero then it means the number
is positive if it is 1 then the number
is negative all right
and that's why there are distinct types
for
signed and unsigned
and the ranges for signed and unsigned
integers vary right
and over here we have an illustration
just to see the ranges for example for
I8 a signed integral of 8 Bits
the range would be from
-128 to 127.
so the smallest possible number we can
represent with a signed 8-bit integer
would be
-128 and the largest one would be 127.
and as you can see again the more bits
we have
the larger and smaller the integer can
go
right
and again unsigned integers never go
below zero
right then we have view size and eye
size so these are as I've said
architecture dependent so on a 32-bit
architecture computer
the size of these view size and eye size
type would be 32 bits
on a 64-bit architecture it would be 64
bits
and this is also called pointer sized
integer type because it matches the size
of a word in a given platform
so what is a word you have to understand
that the processor does not read one
byte at a time from memory it reads one
word at a time
so in a 32-bit processor it can access
four bytes or 32 bits at a time and in a
64-bit processor it can access 8 bytes
or 64 bits at a time
now if we look at this very simplified
representation of computer memory where
we have over here addresses and over
here the data
and
each location over here holds data of
one byte all right
now in a 32-bit architecture the size of
a word is four bytes right 32 bits which
means that the processor can access 4
bytes at a time so the processor will
read
this section over here as one word right
it's basically unit of data and what you
have to take from this is this statement
over here
you size gives you the guarantee to be
always big enough to hold any pointer or
any offset in a data structure
so the U size type
can hold memory addresses which can
point to any location in computer memory
that's very important
so let's see floating point there are
two types F32 which is of size 32 bits
and f64 which is of type 64 bits now the
representation of these floats are
according to the IEEE 754 specification
so let's look at some exercises
tips if we don't explicitly assign a
type to a variable then the compiler
will infer one for us
now remove something to make it work
as you can see over here we have a
variable X which holds an i32
integer right
now over here we have immutable variable
Y which holds an unsigned 32-bit integer
right so over here we are trying to
assign X to Y now this would actually
fail because we can't assign a variable
of a type to a variable of another type
it's not possible
so what we can do over here to fix that
is actually just omitting the type and
this will then implicitly hold an i32
type right because this is the default
integer type in Rust
now over here we are initializing in
another variable set and what would be
the type of Z
right it would be I 32.
all right
thank you
fill the blank so over here as you can
see we have a value 38 which is of type
u8 so we can also annotate a type
directly on a value
meaning this value over here 38 is of
type u8 now the problem here is that the
variable over here V expects a type of
u16
so we can't initialize a variable which
expects a certain type with another type
but what we can do over here is using
the as keyword which basically can
convert an integer type to another
integer type so we can use here s and
u16
this will then compile
tips if we don't explicitly assign a
type to a variable then the compiler
will infer one for us now we know that
already
modify a sort EQ to make it work so over
here we are initializing the variable x
with a value of 5. what would be the
type annotation
it would be i32 right it's the default
integer typing rust now in this assert
EQ macro we have here a string u32 we
don't worry yet about this method I will
explain that in a later episode
and on the other side of the assert EQ
macro we have a function call so we call
type of with an argument of x
actually a reference to X but again
don't worry we'll cover that
so
when we call this function over here it
basically just gives us back the name of
the type
so if we pass X over here we would get
back
i32 right
because this variable over here holds a
value of type i32 now this boot then
actually fail right because we want here
that
type of X returns u32 so what we can do
is just changing this type annotation
over here
all right fill the blanks to make it
work now over here we have a data type
for example I8 and the constant Max now
Max just Returns the largest possible
number that can be represented with the
mentioned data type so for example I8
Max would be
127. right this would be an assigned
8-bit integer and we have seen the
ranges
now the max for an unsigned 8-bit
integral would be 255.
all right
fix arrows and panics to make it work
now over here we have a value 251 which
is of type u8 and we add 8 to it now in
this case the compiler will infer the
types so this would be 8
and the variable itself will hold them
u8
now can you spot the problem over here
the problem is we have seen that u8 can
only represent up to
255 right so over here we would have
259 so this is not possible
so what we can do over here is just
changing that to the next
bigger data type for example u16
now then we have here a data type I8
assigned 8-bit integer and we call the
checked add method now this is actually
the same as doing it like that but in a
safer way because we have to handle the
error
and unwrap over here we will cover that
so
this
is actually a little bit safer but it
still will panic because again the I8
cannot represent
259 it would be an overflow so again we
can over here just say we want an i16
because an i16 can without problems
represent 259.
so V1 will then hold u16
and V2 will hold i16
. again I'm just doing this for clarity
you don't have to annotate the types
alright modify assert to make it work
now as you can see over here we have
numbers
in different representations or
basically in different number systems so
this is decimal this is hexadecimal this
is octal and this is binary okay
now
the decimal over here has an underscore
and this is just a delimiter so this is
just for readability it doesn't affect
the actual value
now let me convert that over here we
would have 2024
this is already in decimal system then
over here we would have 255
then over here we would have 63 and then
over here I hope you remember this would
be
255. now if we calculate this
as you can see the result would be this
value over here
like that and this basically proves that
in Rusty you can
perform mathematical operations on
different
number systems right
now floating Point fill the blank to
make it work as you can see over here we
have a floating point value so what
would be the type
I will annotate it directly so it would
be f64 this is the default floating
Point type right
now over here we have an F 32
and over here we have an F 64.
right
like that again type annotations are not
necessary now if we pass x to the type
of function over here what would be the
return value
it would be f64 right
make it work in two distinct ways so if
we execute this program over here
as you can see this would panic
now the problem here is a floating Point
precision
the result won't be exactly 0.3 it would
be something like
that maybe right or something like that
I don't know exactly but
t
floating point value is too precise
because the default floating Point type
is f64 so this is really precise and
that's why you have these tiny fractions
over here now we can solve this using
an F 32 Which is less precise right
like that
and this succeeds now two distinct ways
we can also use the as keyword
like that
so let me first move my head over here
again
so range two goals first modify Sr to
make it work second make print line
output 97 to 122.
now over here as you can see we have
immutable variable sum
what would be the type annotation it
would be i32 okay now
over here we have a for Loop meaning we
are iterating over some range and then
we are executing an instruction inside
this code block over here
multiple times basically the times we
are iterating over this range over here
now in each iteration the variable I
will hold
a different value right so in the first
iteration it would be -3 in the second
iteration it would be -2 in the third
minus 1 and so on until we reach 1.
y1 because 2 over here is excluded and
that's always the case when using this
syntax the end point of the range is
always excluded so we are iterating from
-3 to 1 okay
now let's actually do these iterations
manually so
we start with zero right now in the
first iteration I would be -3 so
0 plus minus 3 will be
minus 3 right
so sum will then hold
-3 now in the second iteration I will be
minus two so minus three plus minus 2
will be minus five
third iteration minus one minus five
plus minus one will be minus six
then
in the next iteration I will be zero so
it doesn't have any impact and in the
last iteration I will be one so minus
six plus one will be minus five
so the value of sum after this for Loop
will be minus five
now over here we again have a for Loop
and this time we are iterating over a
range of characters namely from A to Z
now this time Z over here is included
because we are using the equal sign over
here which means we want a range from A
to Z where the end point set is included
and C over here will then hold in each
iteration a character so in the first
one it would be a then it would be B
then C and so on and we just print out
the characters
let's see how that looks like as you can
see just printing out each character
from a to z
now we want to have an output of 97 to
122.
so let's look at the ASCII table
as you can see in memory a character
would be stored as a numerical value now
of course in memory everything is stored
as binary numbers but it would be stored
as the binary representation of these
decimal numbers right here
so we want to go from 97 a to
122 Z right
so it's actually pretty simple instead
of
outputting DC as character
we want to Output it as an u8 for
example
right
and then as you can see we have the
ASCII code for the characters from A to
Z lowercase
right
then over here exercise 10 fill the
blanks so we are here importing from the
standard Library the Ops module range
and range inclusive
now we have seen the shorthand syntax
and this would actually be the more
verbose way to write that but I think no
one actually does it this way
over here we have a range which starts
at one and ends at five now again five
would be excluded right
like that now range inclusive means
we range from 1 to 5 where 5 is included
and we would write that short and syntax
like this
one two five and five is included
right let's see the last exercise in
this topic computations fill the blanks
and fix the errors
so as you can see over here we have
integer additions so one plus two will
be three
and the compiler over here will infer
these types so because we have over here
an u32 an unsigned 32-bit integer it
will infer these values over here to be
of the same type
all right
now over here the same thing we have 1
minus 2 would be -1
and the compiler infers these types
then over here we have 1 minus 2 which
is equal minus one
the problem over here is that we are
dealing with an unsigned 8-bit integer
now remember unsigned integers can never
be negative
so what we can do to fix that is just
converting it to an I8 assigned 8-bit
integer and signed integers can
represent both positive and negative
numbers
now over here we would have 150
and if there are no type annotations
here the default integer type will be
inferred which will be i32
now over here again we have the problem
of floating Point Precision so we can
cast that to an F 32.
like that
over here we have the modulus operator
and the modules operator basically gives
back the remainder of a division so if
we divide 24 by 5 we would have a
remainder of 4.
now as you can see here we have Boolean
logic and bitwise operations and I want
to show you some slides so we get the
concept
let's start with Boolean logic Boolean
logic deals with values that are either
true or false
and there are three basic operations and
or and not
and over here you can see the truth
tables of these operations
so let's see the and operator now the
end operator takes two inputs and
produces one output
now the only time it outputs true is
when both of the inputs are true
otherwise it will always return false
in an or operation
if either one of the inputs is true or
both of the inputs are true then it will
output true if both of the inputs are
false then it will output faults
and the not operator will just basically
invert the Boolean value so over here we
have not false and this would evaluate
to true and not true will evaluate to
false
now let's see bitwise operations
bitwise operations are operations that
manipulate individual bits that make up
a binary number treating each bit of a
binary number as a separate unit and
perform logical operations on them
so it's very important that you get that
in bitwise operations we are treating
each bit as a separate unit and we are
doing some manipulation on each
individual bit and not the binary number
as a whole
and we'll cover here and or X or
operations and bitwise shifting now
there are a lot more but I will just
cover the ones in the exercise
let's start with the end operator this
Ampersand symbol over here and returns
one only when both of its inputs are one
so similar to Boolean logic as you can
see the end operator takes two inputs
and produces one output
now
as you can see in the truth table if
both of the inputs are one then the
output will be 1. in any other case the
output will be zero
let's see the or operator this symbol
over here
all returns one if at least one of its
inputs is one if both inputs are zero
the output will also be zero
so same thing as in Boolean logic if
either one of the inputs or both of the
inputs are one then it will output one
so the only case it outputs 0 is when
both of the inputs are zero
and let's see xor xor or exclusive or
returns one if the inputs are different
and zero if the inputs are the same
so it's basically similar to the or
operator with the difference that if
both of the inputs are one then it will
output 0. so the inputs must be
different so it will output one all
right if they are the same it will
output 0.
and this is basically a building block
of your computer so your computer is
made up of logic gates and these logic
gates perform these operations all the
time
millions of times in a second
then let's see bitwise left shift so we
have over here the decimal number one
this would be the binary representation
now we want to left shift
by five positions
so we take this bit over here and move
it five positions to the left
so the so this bit over here will be at
this position after the DP twice left
shift operation all right and that means
we then have a value of 32 because this
is the binary representation of decimal
32.
and bitwise right shift is basically the
same
now over here we have a hexadecimal
value and we want to right shift it to
positions
now this value over here would be 128 in
decimal
and this would be the binary
representation of 128.
now we want to right shift it to
positions meaning we take this bit over
here and shift it two positions to the
right meaning the bit will then be in
this place and again we would have 32
because this over here is the binary
representation of that number all right
let's see
so true
and false
would be
false
right because in an and operation both
of the inputs must be true in order for
it to Output true now true or false
would be true
because in an or operation only one of
the inputs have to be true
and not true would be equal to
that's right false
fight
like that now let me run the program so
we can see the result of these
bitwise operations
so as you can see over here zero zero
one one and zero one zero one is zero
zero zero one why is that because again
we are here considering each individual
bit as a unit and Performing
manipulation on each
a distinct bit now over here as you can
see we are taking the rightmost bit over
here and we are performing The End
operation with the rightmost bit over
here meaning one and one
would be one right because and if both
of the inputs are 1 then it will output
one in any other case as you can see one
and zero would be zero
0 and 1 would be zero zero and zero of
course would be zero
now let's see this or operation we have
one or one this will output one
we have one or zero which will output
one again right because in or operation
if either one of its input or both of
them are one then it will output one
zero or one is one and zero or zero of
course is zero
and then we have xor one X or one put B
zero because remember X or the inputs
must be different in order for it to
Output one
like over here for example 1 X or zero
would be one right the inputs over here
are different one and zero
same over here 0 x or one would be one
and zero X or zero of course will be
zero and as you can see over here these
are the bitwise shifting so I've covered
that in the slides
all right see you in the next topic so
we will cover in our Char pool and unit
let's start with characters
so over here make it work now size of
Val will just return this size in bytes
of a specific value so over here we are
initializing the variable C1 with a
character so C1 holds a type of char
then we pass to the size of valve
function the variable C1 and this will
return the size of this character in
memory in bytes right and same thing
over here we have C2 also holding HR
and we call the size of L function with
this variable
so
let me first print out the actual result
of this function call
so if I come over here
and I will do a print line
statement
and just basically
outputting the result of this function
column so let's see
as you can see the output would be 4
meaning this character over here will
take up four bytes in memory so the size
of C1 is 4 bytes
now in Rust the chart type is big enough
to hold every single Unicode symbol
meaning it is of size 4 bytes so it's
able to hold any Unicode scalar value
all right
and the same thing over here the output
would be four
meaning if we call this function we will
get back four
all right
make it work again initializing a
variable with a Char then we are calling
the printshar function with an argument
of this variable
as you can see this function over here
this is the function signature this
function takes as argument C which is of
type Char and then we will and then we
just print out C
now the problem over here is that this
isn't actually a Char this would be
considered a string because in Rust
there is a difference between double
quotes and single quotes So double
quotes are four strings and these single
quotes are for characters
foreign
out the character
let's see booleans make print Line work
as you can see this variable underscore
F holds a Boolean value of false
and over here T also holds a Boolean
value of true
now in an if block this conditional over
here will be checked if the result
evaluates to true then this instruction
inside the curly braces will be printed
out if it evaluates to false then the
program will just ignore this
instruction over here
now in this case we want to print that
out
but over here the result would evaluate
to false because we are saying not
true right because T holds a Boolean
value of true
so not true would be false that means
this will never get printed out what we
can do over here is just removing this
not operator and then it will work
make it work again we have some
variables that hold Boolean types now
again this variable over here T will
also hold a Boolean type because this
over here is an and operation and
remember an end operation takes two
inputs and produces one output so the
output type will be of type pool now
true and false would evaluate to false
and then we are comparing T and F now F
holds true and T holds false
which is not what we want
so what we can do over here is just
making this false over here
and then both of them hold a Boolean
value of false
unit type make it work don't modify
implicitly red unit
so the unit type is a type which doesn't
hold any value
its size is zero bytes and it's usually
if a function doesn't return
any value then a unit type will be
returned and this happens implicitly so
you don't have to annotate that
let's see an example
over here the underscore V variable
holds a unit type
as you can see a unit type is basically
represented as an empty Tuple
and this would be the type annotation
right
so over here we are holding a tuple with
two i-32 values
then as you can see we have here an
assert EQ macro we are comparing V with
the output of this function call let's
see this function over here implicitly
red unit so all this function does is it
will print out something and then goes
back to the color now this function over
here doesn't return anything
and if a function doesn't return
anything the compiler will implicitly
return a unit type right but you don't
have to annotate that
all right so the return value of this
would be unit type now V over here holds
a tuple meaning this would fail we have
here to provide underscore V which holds
a unit type so this holds a unit type
and this function call over here will
return a unit type
all right what's the size of the unit
type modify 4 in assert to make it work
as you can see we are again having this
size of L function and we are providing
it this variable which holds a unit type
now the output would be zero because
unit types are of size 0.
so to quickly recap HR is a single
character of size 4 bytes
a Boolean value of true or false is of
size 1 byte and the unit is an empty
Tuple of size 0 bytes used to return
nothing in expressions or functions
so this time I will first show you the
slide
and then we will solve exercises so a
statement is an instruction that
performs some action but does not
produce a value
function definitions for example are
statements as well as code that ends
with a semicolon usually
and an expression will evaluate to a
resultant value so let's see
all right let's see this example over
here we have X which holds an u32 all
right now
over here we are initializing the
variable y with the resultant value of
this whole expression so as you can see
we can inside these curly brackets
we can declare variables over here and
then we do some operations and return
the value as you notice I omit over here
the semicolon that means that
this result of this operation will get
returned which means when this evaluates
it will then be assigned to Y so y will
then hold the result of this operation
now all of the code inside these curly
braces are considered as an expression
because it produces a resultant value
right it would be this value over here
now this variable assignment over here
would be considered a statement because
first of all it ends in a semicolon and
second it doesn't produce a new value
right it just assigns a value to a
variable
now y in the end would hold an u32 right
because we are here performing an
operation with values of u32 types
the semicolon suppresses this expression
and unit type is assigned to Z
so Z over here would hold a unit type
why is that because we over here have a
semicolon so this
code over here doesn't return a value
if we omit the semicolon then this would
be the return value that then gets
assigned to this variable meaning it
will then hold a u32
all right let's do exercise one make it
work with two ways so
as you can see over here we are
initializing this variable over here
with this expression inside the curly
braces now we are here initializing the
mutable variable x with a value of one
so X will hold I 32.
then we are mutating X incrementing it
by two so X should then hold
3 right
now over here this would actually hold
a unit type
because over here we have an assignment
so we are adding 2 to the value of x and
then we assign it to X now the problem
is that
variable assignments are actually
statements so this should end in a
semicolon because this would be the same
as if I would write it like that
right
so we can't return over here a variable
assignment but what we can do is
we just return X because X over here
will then hold 3 and then we return X
meaning the value of x is then assigned
to the variable V
so variable V will then hold a type of I
32.
let's see
this compiling as you can see make it
work in two ways now the second way to
solve it is just in this assert EQ macro
we compare V to a unit type
because
um no value will get assigned to V and
that means the variable we will then
hold a unit type like that
over here as you can see we are
initializing V with a variable
assignment so this would not be allowed
it's invalid syntax but what we can do
is we use curly braces like that and
then we
initialize here a variable X and we
return X
this would be allowed
so V then holds an i32
let's see over here we have a function
call with two values one and two so
let's see the function over here it
takes two arguments X and Y of type i32
and it returns an i32 value now over
here as you can see this function just
adds X Plus y now the actual return type
over here would be unit type
because as you can see we are ending
this operation with a semicolon meaning
nothing will get returned so if we omit
the semicolon over here then we would
have a return type of I 32.
meaning after the function call over
here
s will then hold the result of this
operation 1 plus 2 would be 3 so s would
hold three
that would be a type of i32
so let's now look at functions a
function is a block of reusable code
that performs specific tasks it can take
arguments processes those inputs and
then returns a result
and a diverging function is a function
that never returns to the caller
and this would happen for example if the
diversion function is panicking looping
forever or quitting the program
so let's see don't modify the following
two lines as you can see we have here a
tuple and we are destructuring it we
have already seen how that works
now over here we have a function called
now this would be the color and this
function would be the collie okay when
we call the function the flow control
will go to this function and the program
will continue executing the instructions
provided in this function now
it's very important that you know that
functions always have to annotate types
for their arguments
so over here
we would Define that X should be of type
i32 right because Y is I 32 and we are
performing here a mathematical operation
meaning they both have to be of the same
type
and
as you can see like in the last exercise
this function wouldn't return a value
because over here we have a semicolon so
if we omit that then this result of this
operation will get returned which means
the return type would be i32
then when this Returns the flow control
will go back over here and assign The
Returned value from this function to
variable s meaning the variable s will
then hold
a type of i32 and the value would be 3
right because we are calling the
function with arguments one and two or X
and Y
over here which hold one and two and
then this function will just sum it up
together and that means s will hold 3.
over here we are calling the print
function so we go to the function over
here and as you can see
the function just prints out something
to standard output but it doesn't return
a value now implicitly the compiler will
return a unit type like that but we
don't have to write it
it's implicit
solve it in two ways don't let print Ln
work
all right so we are here calling a
function never return
and this function should never return
because as you can see the return type
over here is defined as exclamation mark
and that means this is a diverging
function a function that should never
return back to the caller
now we can do this in various different
ways but I will just use the most simple
one which is panic
and the Panic macro just
causes the program to panic meaning the
program will immediately exit and return
an error
as you can see unreachable statement so
this line over here is never reached
as you can see and that's what we want
because over here don't let print Ln
work so we never actually reach this
point the program will exit before
going back to the caller
diverging functions diverging functions
never return to the caller so they may
be used in places where a value of any
type is expected
so in the main function we just print
out something and over here we have a
function get option
it takes as argument a value of type u8
and returns option i32 now we will cover
options in a later episode
now over here we are matching TP
and matching if you're coming from
another programming language is like is
which
block okay we are matching TP and then
if for example TP would be one then this
code block over here would get executed
if it is anything else then this code
block will be executed and we will cover
match statements but match is just a
much more powerful way of pattern
matching than for example if else
conditionals
so after this match we are calling this
never return FN and this should never
return so there are some macros we can
use here I've showed you one the Panic
macro
[Applause]
like that
or we can also use unimplemented
and you use the unimplemented macro if
you have a function that is not
implemented yet
and we can also use it to do macro
like that
and to do is basically very similar to
and implemented and all of them will
cause this function to not return to the
caller in this case this would be the
color over here
fill in the blank so as you can see we
have here a variable B which then gets
matched over here so if B holds a value
of true then 1 will be assigned to
variable V
if B holds a value of false then it will
print out success and the program will
then panic
now
we can here assign false because I guess
we wanted to print out success right
and
yeah let's see
as you can see this would be the
compiler message if a program panics
trade main panicked at we have no value
for false but we can panic
that would be this output over here
so we will now cover ownership and
ownership is a concept which is unique
to rust meaning even experienced
programmers can find it difficult to
understand this concept
but it's very logical and it all makes
sense and I will use visuals and
illustrations
to make it easier to understand the
concept so ownership is basically a set
of rules that govern memory management
these rules are enforced at compiled
time
if any of the rules are violated then
the program won't compile
now let's see the three rules of
ownership in Rust first each value in
Rust has an owner second there can only
be one owner at a time
third when the owner goes out of scope
the value will be dropped
now the owner of a value is the variable
or data structure that holds it and is
responsible for allocating and freeing
the memory used to store that data
foreign let's look at scope
a scope is arranged within a program for
which an item is valid we have two types
of scope one is global scope and that
means a variable that is declared in
global scope is accessible throughout
the entire program
and local scope if a variable is
declared locally it means it is
accessible only within that particular
function or code block
which in turn means it's not accessible
outside of that function or code block
let's see an example of scope
as you can see we are here initializing
the variable s with a string that means
s over here is the owner of this data of
this string value okay
now s is valid from this point forward
so after initializing s it will be valid
throughout this scope over here which is
defined by these curly braces
so inside of this scope we can do stuff
with s
when this scope is over s is no longer
valid so as over here the owner of this
data will deallocate the data that is
stored in computer memory and that means
in turn we can't use as after this point
it gets dropped or removed
from memory
so when s comes into scope it is valid
it remains valid until it goes out of
scope and a general rule is the scope
ends where the block of code ends so to
understand ownership you have to
understand computer memory now memory is
a component in a computer to store data
and instructions for the processor to
execute
there is a type of memory called random
access memory or RAM and it is volatile
meaning when you're turning off your
computer all data stored inside Ram is
lost
and there are two types of regions in
Ram which is used by your rust program
it is stack memory and Heap memory
so now let's look at stack memory and I
want you to imagine a stack of plates
now if you want to eat something you
take from the top of this stack a plate
put food on it eat and then you will
clean up the plate right when you're
done cleaning you put the plate back on
the top of the stack
and that's exactly what is happening in
stack memory so this concept is called
last in first out meaning the last thing
that is pushed
on top of the stack will be the first
thing that will get popped from this
deck meaning the first thing that will
get executed
now all data stored on this deck must
have a known fixed size like integers
floats Charles bulls and so on basically
all the types we have seen so far are
all of fixed known size at compile time
now pushing to the stack is faster than
allocating on the Heap because the
location for new data is always at the
top of the stack
meaning the program can access
a data and stack memory at constant time
if you are familiar with time complexity
and types of unknown size will get
allocated to the Heap and a pointer to
the value is pushed to this stack
because a pointer is fixed size
don't worry I will show you
illustrations which will make you
understand this concept better
let's see for example
this simple rust program so as you can
see we are starting in main because main
is the starting point of execution in
every rust program
so over here we declare some variables X
Y and Z meaning these variables are
local to the main scope to this code
block over here
and
because they are local they can't be
accessed outside of this scope
now over here we have a function call
and we pass it the value of x and of Y
right so as you can see the add numbers
function takes two arguments of type i32
then over here we declare a new variable
and assign and we assign the result of
the operation a plus b meaning
the past value is X Plus Y
and we assign it to the variable C and
then we just return C right so then
Z over here will hold the returned value
now
when we start execution main alongside
with all the local variables will get
pushed to the stack
then because we have over here a
function call inside Main
the add numbers function alongside with
all the local variables to this function
will get pushed to this stack if we
would have other function calls over
here or inside here then this will also
get pushed on the stack and so on
and then the program will just execute
everything that is on the stack from top
to bottom
now let's look at Heap memory date of no
known fixed size belongs on the Heap
allocating data on the Heap will return
a pointer an address to a location where
the data has been allocated
allocating on the Heap is slower than
pushing to this stack and accessing data
on the Heap is also slower as it has to
be accessed using a pointer which points
to an address
so if we look at this abstract
illustration of Heap memory as you can
see we are allocating to Heap memory if
the size of of the type we are
allocating is not known at compile time
and the types can then also be
dynamically grown or shrinked right the
size is not fixed
and we will see examples of these types
where this cat where this could be
useful
so when we allocate to Heap memory let's
see for example the this packet over
here we will get back a memory address
and we need this address so we know
where this specific data over here has
been allocated so we then can access it
in our program
and an example of a heap allocator type
would be the string type now as I've
said all types we have covered so far
were fixed size meaning their size was
known at compiled time and they can't
grow and Shrink
so the difference is a string is mutable
meaning its size can change at run time
and a string is stored on the stack with
a pointer to the Heap so when we
initialize a string type then we will
get back a pointer which then points to
the actual data in the Heap
and and the actual data of the string is
stored on the Heap
so let's see an example to understand
this better as you can see we have here
the variable S1 which we initialize with
a string type over here
and we initialize a string like this
string
double colon from and then these the
actual string
now
you need to understand that the variable
S1 doesn't hold the actual string in
this case
it holds a pointer which points to the
data that was allocated on the Heap so
if we look at S1 we can see that S1
doesn't hold the actual data but it
holds a pointer and a pointer is
basically a variable that holds a memory
address that's what we call pointer
and we have here Len and this is the
length of the string we have initialized
and the capacity holds the information
of how much space was reserved in Heap
memory for this specific type in this
case we have initialized a string with a
length of 5 so the capacity will be 5 so
5 locations have been allocated in Heap
memory so this place is reserved
for this string type and we will go into
a much greater detail about capacity
but for now when we initialize a string
with a length of 5 the capacity will be
five it will be the same
so the size of this S1 variable will be
24 bytes because each field over here is
of Type U size
right so the pointer is of Type U size
the Lan anti-capacity all of them are U
size and u-size assuming we are on a
64-bit computer will be 8 bytes so 3
times 8 bytes will be 24 bytes meaning
the size of the variable S1 is known at
compile time because again
the variable S1 will get pushed to this
stack memory and everything that lives
on the stack memory has to be of known
fixed size at compile time in this case
all of these fields over here are known
fixed size but we are pointing over here
to the actual data in Heap memory which
can be dynamically sized right it can
grow and shrink and we will see examples
of that
so that is actually the point
important the S1 variable doesn't hold
the actual data but it holds a pointer
to the data in Heap memory
okay basically a pointer to the location
of the first element
and by the way in Heap memory this data
over here is allocated as a contiguous
block meaning in Heap memory these are
all in a contiguous sequence of memory
addresses right that's why we only need
the
memory address of the first location and
a length and then the compiler will know
where to look at and how long the
sequence of data is
so copy versus move scalar values with
fixed size all types we've covered at
the beginning will automatically get
copied in this stack copying here is
cheap
dynamically sized data won't get copied
but moved copying would be too expensive
let's see an example
over here as you can see we have
initialized a variable x with a value of
5. then we assign X to y
now the type of this value would be i32
right because it's the default integer
type
now because i32 is fixed size it means
that it lives in this stack memory
and everything that lives in stack
memory will automatically get copied
meaning we are here assigning a copy of
x to y or basically a copy of the value
5. so we are not assigning the actual
value but a copy of that meaning Y and X
would point to different memory
locations the value is the same but the
location at which the value is stored is
different because again when we assign a
fixed size integer that lives in stack
memory rust will automatically copy the
value
because copying on the stack memory is
cheap now over here as you can see we
initialize a string
and then we assign S1 holding this
string 2s2
now as we've seen S1 doesn't actually
hold the data over here but it holds a
pointer which is returned when we are
allocating this data over here this
string on the Heap memory so the
allocator that allocates this data on
the Heap memory will return a pointer
and that means if we assign S1 over here
to S2 then S2 will only get a copy of
the pointer and not the actual
data
so that is how that might look like as
you can see we have S1 which is
initialized to hold a string
now S1 will then be assigned to S2
and
as you can see this is how this might
then look like we have here the variable
S1 and S2 now
the actual data over here didn't get
copied the one thing that got copied was
the pointer alongside with the metadata
meaning
these two variables now point to the
same location in memory
right now this would violate the second
rule which states that there can only be
one owner at a time
so we can't over here have two owners to
the same
data in Heap memory
so what rust will do is it will drop S1
it will delete S1 and that means
S2 will then be the owner of the data so
the first variable S1 will be dropped
and cannot be used after assigning it to
S2 to avoid dangling pointers
so after assigning S1 to S2 we can't use
S1 again
and that's different like we saw over
here with for example integers which are
fixed size
we can use after assigning X to Y we can
use both of these variables X and Y
without any problem because again here
the value got copied
so the compiler will drop the variable
S1 meaning S2 will become the owner of
this string and that means we can't use
S1 after this point
now what if you want to actually have a
deep copy meaning you actually want to
copy the data that is allocated in Heap
memory we can do that but we have to
explicitly state that we want to do that
because as I've said this might be
expensive if you have large data that is
allocated on the Heap
and if rust would implicitly copy
all the data all the time you're
assigning variables then this would be
really expensive and that's why we have
to explicitly call over here the Clone
method so when we take S1 which holds a
string and we call upon it the Clone
method
and assign this to S2 then that is what
this might look like
as you can see S1 again doesn't hold the
actual data but a pointer to the data
that is that has been allocated in Heap
memory
and when we now look at S2 S2 also holds
a pointer to data that has been
allocated in Heap memory the difference
is that the actual data in Heap memory
that S1 is pointing to has been copied
in Heap memory
so S1 and S2 point to different
locations even if the data is the same
right and that's different from what we
saw here as you can see S1 and S2 point
to the same location in Heap memory
I hope you get the concept so let's now
see how ownership Works in functions as
you can see we have here a variable s
which we initialized with a string type
so over here s comes into scope
and in this case s will be the owner of
this data
then over here we are calling the takes
ownership function providing it an
argument of s
so s value moves into the function and
so is no longer valid here meaning the
function takes ownership is now the
owner of s
so as you can see this function over
here takes an argument of string type
and it just prints out the provided
string
so as you can see some string comes into
scope and some string over here is the
string we have provided as an argument
then we print it out and over here
some string goes out of scope and drop
is called the backing memory is freed
meaning
when we reach the end of the scope
some string will get deallocated in Heap
memory
so after this point over here s
can't be used in this main function over
here because again the ownership has
been moved from variable s into the
takes ownership function
now over here we have another
initialized variable x with a value of
five now five would be of type I 32 the
default integer type meaning 5 is a type
that lives on this stack it's pushed to
the stack and not allocated on the Heap
and that means when we call this
function makes copy and provided X over
here
then we provide this function a copy of
the value and not the actual value
itself
so we provide here a copy of the value 5
right and then over here we just print
out this number then here are some
integrals out of scope nothing special
happens
so the argument we are providing here
goes out of scope but X over here is
still valid because again we have just
provided a copy because this is a type
that is living on the stack memory
so let's see this example over here we
are calling the gifs ownership function
now when we look at this function over
here we are inside the function code
block
initializing a variable with a string
value over here
and then we are just returning this
string
and that means that S1 will then hold
the returned string
namely this yours string over here so S1
will be the owner of The Returned string
type
over here we are initializing S2 with a
string over here that means S2 is the
owner of the string
then we are calling here the function
takes and gives back with an argument of
S2 meaning takes and gives back will
become the owner of this data
and that also means that after calling
this function we can't use the variable
as 2 because it has been dropped
now when we look at the function takes
and gives back it takes an argument of
type string which we are providing here
and then it just again Returns the
string right so S3 will then hold the
return string basically S3 then became
the owner of this data right so we have
transferred ownership from S2 to this
function takes and gives back and then
from this function to S3
and then at the end of the main scope S3
goes out of scope and is dropped S2 was
moved we've seen that we have moved it
inside the function so nothing happens
S1 goes out of scope and is dropped
so
the variable S1 also gets dropped
because it is the owner of of this
string type returned from this function
so you are now asking why do I even care
about all this stuff in other languages
I don't have to worry about all of this
and this seems rather complicating
a simple issue right now the main point
of all of this is that ownership
prevents memory safety issues
so by this concept of ownership you are
preventing dangling pointers pointers
that point to Nowhere or some garbage
values
double three which is trying to free
memory that has already been freed or
memory leaks not free memory that should
have been freed and if you're coming
from C or C plus plus you're you know
exactly what I'm talking about here
so before stepping into borrowing we
will do some exercises concerning
ownership
so let's see number one use as many
approaches as you can to make it work
so
as you can see the variable X over here
has been initialized with a string
then we are assigning X to Y so y also
should hold a string
the problem over here is that we try to
access X over here after it has been
assigned to y
now we have seen in the example that X
will get dropped after we assigning
after we are assigning it to another
variable
right so we can't access X but what we
can do is
telling the compiler that we want a deep
copy of the data that X is holding and
we are using for that the Clone method
and then we X and then we can access
both of these variables because the data
has been cloned and X still lives on
number two don't modify code in main
again S1 has been initialized with a
string
and then we are calling here take
ownership and providing it an argument
as two
as you can see the function take
ownership expects an argument of type
string and it just prints out the
provided argument
now
we are then assigning the return value
of this function to this variable the
problem here is that this function
actually doesn't return anything so this
would hold a unit
type right
now if we want to return the argument
over here after Printing and using it
we can just return it like that and if
you return something from a function you
have to annotate the return type and
that would be string right
because we are taking here in the string
and then we are returning it back that
means S2 will then hold the returned
string
and then we can print out S2
and notice S1 can't be used after we
have called this function with an
argument of S1 because the ownership has
been transferred to this function
so meaning
S1 is holding the data over here which
means it's the owner then we call this
function and provide it as one meaning
this function over here becomes the
owner and then we are assigning the
return value to S2 so that means S2 over
here will be the owner of the data
in the end
number three we are here calling the
function GIF ownership
and as you can see inside the function
we are initializing a variable s which
holds a string
and we call here the into bytes method
on S
now let me show you that in the
documentation
so this is the in two bytes method
now as you can see converts a string
into a byte Vector so if we have a
string over here and we call the into
bytes method
then we will get the string over here
but represented as a vector of bytes
okay
and the important thing here is that
this consumes the string meaning s over
here will get consumed and that means s
can't be used after this point
now what we can do as an alternative we
can use S bytes and S bytes just takes
references and references will be our
next topic so don't worry too much about
it right now but when we call the S
bytes method over here then the owner
will remain
the same right it doesn't consume the
data
so what we can do over here is calling
the S bytes method and that means s
Remains the owner of this data and we
can return it then and that means s over
here will be then the owner of The
Returned value
and then we just print out s
fix the arrow without removing code line
again we are initializing s with a
string
then we are calling the print store
function with an argument s
and all we do is we then print out the
string
but over here again we try to access S
and that would be a compiler error
because we are over here
providing S as an argument to this
function over here meaning this function
will become the owner of the data s is
holding and that means s is not
accessible anymore
what we can do over here is we can call
the Clone method
meaning we are providing this function
over here a copy of this data so this
data will get copied in Heap memory
and that means s will still be valid
don't use clone use copy instead
so over here we have a tuple now this
Tuple holds two integers a unit type and
a string
now let me annotate that
we annotate tuples like that
and we have to
find each type of array value distribute
so we have 2i32 integers
One units type and one string
now over here we are calling the Clone
method and assign it to Y so y should
actually hold the same
uh values all right
and because we have called the Clone
method we can use both variables without
the problem now it says don't use clones
so we can't use clone over here
now my solution to this would be if you
take a look
at the types this Tuple is holding then
we see that most of the types over here
are actually on the stack memory meaning
they are of known fixed size right so
inters and i32 would be of size 32 bits
right a unit type would be of zero bits
the only problem arises here because we
have a string now a string is a heap
allocated type meaning its size is not
known at compile time now what we can do
over here is we can use a string literal
now
we will cover the difference between
strings and string literals but for now
a string literal is a string that is
hard coded into the binary
itself into the program
so it is immutable which means that this
size is known at compile time so all T
types the Tuple holes are known
are of known fixed size at compile time
so over here we can do the same
and what's the reason we have been doing
this because we know that a type that
lives in stack memory meaning it's fixed
size will get copied implicitly
now this Tuple only holds fixed sized
types meaning the Tuple itself is fixed
size and that means X over here will get
copied implicitly by the compiler all
right
mutability can be changed when ownership
is transferred
as you can see we are here initializing
s with a string
then modify this line only
we are here assigning s to S1
now over here as you can see we are
modifying the string that S1 is holding
and remember when we assign s to S1 S1
will become the owner of this data
meaning s will get dropped
so we are then trying to mutate S1
and we are pushing to it D string world
now remember that a variable is
immutable in its nature so we have to
use the mute keyword over here to denote
that S1 should be mutable
and that means that
if
the ownership has been transferred to
another variable we can change its
mutability right even if s was immutable
we can make S1 mutable without problem
because S1 is now the owner of the data
now over here as you can see we are
initializing a variable x with a boxed
integer type now box allows you to
allocate directly on the Heap as you
know this is an i32 and i32 is normally
live in stack memory when we use this
over here Box new and we box this i32 it
means it gets allocated on the Heap
and that means
X will then hold a pointer
to the data that was allocated in Heap
memory so the type annotation here would
be box and
this box holds an i32
and X then basically holds a pointer
now over here implement this line don't
change other lines
now as you can see we have over here to
declare y
now y gets the referenced and that means
we have
over here to get back a pointer so we
can do basically the same thing like we
did before we can use Box new and let's
do one for example
so the variable one will hold a box
with a type of i32
and as I've said we allocate
this integer
on Heap memory meaning we get back a
pointer and the pointer is a memory
address to the location where this data
has been allocated
now because y holds a memory address
we can't
assign a value and integer value
directly to Y because Y is just holding
an address
and not an i32 type because remember we
can just assign a value to a variable if
both of them are of same type
now as you can see y holds the type of
box i32 which is not the same type that
means we have to de-reference and we are
dereferencing using this star operator
and and this star operator means
we go to the location
of Y because Y is holding a memory
address and we want to access the value
right so we want to access this interval
that has been allocated on the Heap and
that means we can assign a new value
2y but we have to use this store
operator
and again over here you can see it even
better
this would be equal right because X is
pointing
to a location in memory which holds an
integral value of 5.
now if we would omit the star operator
this would not match because X would
hold something like that
right in memory address now this memory
address and the integer 5 would not be
equal but this star operator basically
says go to this address and give me back
the value that is stored at that address
which would be 5.
and of course we have to make this
variable over here mutable
right because we are here mutating y
partial move within the destructuring of
a single variable both by move and by
reference pattern binding can be used at
the same time doing this will result
doing this will result in a partial move
of the variable which means that parts
of the variable will be moved while
other parts stay in such a case the
parent variable cannot be used
afterwards as a whole however the parts
that are only referenced and not moved
can still be used
so over here we have a lot of stuff we
didn't cover yet and I will try my best
to explain it but if you don't get it
100 it's no problem okay we will go into
greater detail on each of these
structures and types
so as you can see over here we have a
struct person now a struct is basically
a custom type we can create our own
types in Rust
and
a struct basically is a template we are
saying here as you can see this truck
holds two members
one name which is of type string and one
H which is of type boxed u8
okay a heap allocated unsigned 8-bit
integer
then we have to instantiate
and
this person struct meaning we are using
this template and create basically a
concrete value of that so we are
providing here for the name member a
string like it's defined here and for
the age we provide a boxed value of 20.
now this person variable will then hold
a type of person right this is now our
own
custom defined type
now
name is moved out of person but age is
referenced
so over here we are destructuring the
person instance over here
and we do that very similar to tuples we
have seen we used to let keyword the
name of destruct and then we the
structure the fields so the person
so the person instance over here will
get the structure meaning person name
will get put into the name variable and
the H member here will get put inside
this H variable now notice something we
are here using the ref keyword meaning
th variable will only take a reference
of this data and not the actual data
itself
but name will get moved inside this
variable so the name variable here will
be the owner of this string
right
and that means that person is not the
owner of this string anymore it has been
when instantiating the struct but it is
not anymore
then as you can see we are printing out
these variables
but we then can't use the person
instance right because the person
instance is not the full owner of all
team members inside it
and also we can't access person.name
this is how you would access normally a
member in a struct person Dot and then
they member in this case name but we can
access
person.h because the person instance
over here is still the owner of age
because again we have destructured it
and the variable H only took a reference
again
if you don't understand a hundred
percent it's fine okay we haven't
covered a lot of this stuff going on
here and I even think this is not a good
example right now
but yeah so exercise eight as you can
see we have here a tuple holding two
string types
[Applause]
now we are assigning the first element
of the Tuple and by the way Cupids are
also zero index like arrays and we can
access the indexes like this
the name of the variable and then Dot
and the index we want to access in this
case the first one
that means that underscore s will hold a
type of string right namely this over
here
and that means the ownership of this
string data here got transferred to this
variable so underscore s is now the
owner of this data
meaning we can't access T again because
T is not the owner anymore of all the
values it contains in the Tuple right so
we can't use it again but we could still
use T at index 1 because this over here
is still owned by T because only the
first element has been moved out
and over here again a tuple with two
strings
[Applause]
so fill the blanks
as you can see what we want here is
destructuring the Tuple and we want to
initialize these two variables S1
and S2
and remember when we destructure it we
have a syntax like that
now over here as you can see when we are
destructuring this Tuple
both of the values
it is holding will get transferred to
these variables so S1 will be the owner
of this stream and S2 will be the owner
of this string meaning T doesn't own any
values after this point
but what we can do because we want to
access T again over here we can call the
Clone method as you've seen
meaning S1 and S2 only hold copies of
these strings and not the actual values
and that means that t will still be
accessible and T is still the owner of
all the values inside the tuber
alright see you in the next topic so
let's look at borrowing borrowing is a
way of temporarily access data without
taking ownership of it
when borrowing you're taking a reference
a pointer to the data and not the data
itself
its goal is to prevent Dengue pointers
and data races
data can be borrowed immutably and
mutably and there are certain rules when
borrowing which we have to comply with
otherwise the program won't compile
let's look at these rules the first rule
states that at any given time you can
have either one mutable reference or any
number of immutable references
but you cannot have both you either have
one mutable reference or any number of
immutable references
and the second is references must always
be valid
so let's see an example of a reference
over here we are initializing S1 with a
string then we call the calculate length
function and as you can see we are here
passing a reference to S1 and this is
indicated by this Ampersand symbol over
here so then let's see the calculate
length function as you can see the
argument should be of type reference to
a string which we did provide right it's
a reference this Ampersand to S1 which
is of type string
and then all this function does it will
call the Len method which will return
the length of the string
and it returns it now notice that the
return type will be of Type U size
and then this Len variable over here
will hold the length of this string
and the type annotation would be use
size right the return value of this
function
and then we just print out S1 and length
and notice something over here we can
use S1 because S1 over here stays the
owner of the data we have just provided
here a reference to S1 and not S1 itself
so let's see how that looks
as you can see we have S1 now again it's
very important that you understand that
the variable S1 over here doesn't hold
the actual data but a pointer to the
data which will get allocated to the
Heap memory so when we allocate to the
Heap we will get back a pointer which S1
is holding alongside with other metadata
now because over here we are providing
S1 as a reference that means the
variable s from this function
will then
be another pointer which points to the
S1 variable so s points to S1 and S1
points to the Heap allocated data
and that means that S1 over here Remains
the owner of
the string
let's see Mutual references as you can
see we initialize a string and assign it
to S now then we call the change
function with a mutable reference and
notice that you have to annotate that
you want the reference to be mutable
this is important and it has to be
explicitly stated so that the rules are
set in place because remember you can
only have one single mutable reference
at a time
and then this change function over here
as you can see in the function signature
it takes an argument of type mutable
reference to string which we are
providing right we are providing a
multiple reference to S which holds a
string and then we can manipulate the
string
now again very important s Remains the
owner of this data even though we are
manipulating it in this function over
here s Remains the owner because we are
here dealing with references
so let's look at some examples just to
strengthen the knowledge of this concept
as you can see we here initialize s with
a string and then we have here two
mutable references to S and we assign it
to R1 and R2
now this would fail this program doesn't
compile now this would violate the first
rule of borrowing which says that we can
only have one mutable reference to the
same data at a time
but what we can actually do
let's see this program as you can see
again we have a variable s which holds a
string
and notice over here we have an inner
scope
so in this scope R1 will hold a mutable
reference to s
now because at the end of the scope R1
we go out of scope meaning it will be
dropped we can then again pass a mutable
reference to R2
so this program will compile
so over here again initializing s with a
string here we have two immutable
references to S now up to this point no
problem because the first rule states
that we can have any number of immutable
references
the problem is over here because we are
then assigning immutable reference to S
to R3 this is a problem because this
would violate the first rule of
borrowing which says that we can either
have any number of immutable references
or one single mutable reference but we
can't have both of them immutable and
mutable references at the same time
now over here as you can see we have the
exactly same program but as you can see
we are here having two immutable
references assigned to R1 and R2 and
then we just print it out now after this
point over here
the variables R1 and R2 won't be used in
the entire program and that means that
we can assign then a mutable reference
to R3
it's important to notice here that again
we don't use R1 and R2 after this point
so it's allowed to have a mutable
reference over here
while over here as you can see we are
trying to access all of them at once
this would cause a problem
now I've showed you some of the reasons
why the compiler is so strict and one of
them was dangling references so let's
see what a dangling reference is
as you can see over here we are calling
a function dangle now in tangle we are
initializing a variable with a string
type and then we are returning over here
a reference to this string
as you can see in the return type it is
a reference to a string now the problem
here is that when the function returns
this variable over here will hold a
reference to this string right
and
s over here will get out of scope at the
end of this function scope here
and that means
this variable over here will point to
something that has already been dropped
or deleted so it points to a garbage
value right
and rust won't allow you to compile a
program like that because this will
violate the second rule which states
that references must always be valid
very important
and to avoid that we can change this
tangle function over here and just
returning
this string itself right so reference to
nothing would then be the owner of the
string
but returning a reference to something
that has been declared inside the
function scope is a bad idea all right
let's do some exercises
as you can see we have here a variable
holding an i32 value
then over here fill the blank and we
have to complete this
P assignment over here now let me see
over here the memory address of X is
and we are providing P so we want to
print out here the memory address and by
the way this is denotation if we pass
here a pointer that it actually outputs
the address
of the memory location that P is holding
so over here what we want to do is we
want a reference to X now as I've told
you
P will then be of type reference to an
i32 right because X is holding an i32
type
now a reference to an i32 is basically a
pointer to a location in memory that
points to this
data over here
so P here holds a memory address we'll
see that when we execute this program
as you can see the memory address of X
is
this
so
this memory address is where
the value 5 is stored in in memory
and we are accessing that using a
pointer over here
again a pointer is just a normal
variable which holds a memory address in
this case the memory address of x
right
so this is a reference to X
over here again we have variable X
holding i32 type and a reference to X
which is a reference to an i32 value
modify this line again we compare here y
with five now y doesn't actually hold
the value 5 it holds a memory address
now to access the data
at which this y pointer here will point
to we have to dereference and we do that
with the reference operator
like that that means go to the location
of Y and give me the value right so when
we go to the location where X is stored
for example at this memory address we
want to get the value that is stored at
that address
we are using
here the star operator
just to access the value
so over here we initialize a variable
holding a string type
then we are calling the function borrow
object
and as you can see the borrow object
function expects an argument of type
reference to a string but what we are
here providing is a string right we are
providing s which is of type string now
we want here to pass a reference to s
meaning a reference to string in this
case we are complying with the function
signature
over here again variable s holding a
string then we call puster function over
here now again we have to always take
care of the function signature what is
expected so as you can see the argument
should be of type mutable reference to a
string so we have to pass here a mutual
reference to s
where s is holding a string right
number five again here having a string
and
as you can see over here we are mutating
p
so that means we want to have immutable
reference
to s
as you can see p will then hold
P will then hold immutable reference to
a string type right
and then we can mutate the string that P
is holding and again because we are here
having a reference S will remain the
owner of the data meaning we still can
use S even after this assignment over
here
ref can be used to take references to a
value similar to ampersand
as you can see we have here a variable
holding HR
and this over here would be a variable
which holds a reference to a chart right
a reference to C
now fill the blank don't change order
code now instead of here
using the Ampersand symbol we can use
the ref keyword and it's exactly the
same actually they are very similar
there are some minor differences in
pattern matching
um but we will come to that
so when we dereference R1 and R2
then this should hold the same
data right
and over here check the quality of the
two address strings
so we have here a function get address
which gets called with R1
and R2
now all this function over here does is
it takes a reference to HR as an
argument and it will
then put it inside this format macro now
this format macro over here is the same
as the print line macro with the
difference that the print line will
print to the standard output while
format will return a string right so we
take this argument
and then we will
return here the memory address of this
reference
now in this case R1 and R2 should hold
actually the same memory address right
because they are pointing to the same
data this case C so R1 is pointing to C
and R2 is pointing to C
all right so let's see
and this is compiling
borrowing rules remove something to make
it work don't remove a whole line again
here having immutable variable s which
holds a string then we have two mutable
references to s
and this actually would
failed to compile because again we can
only have one mutable reference at a
time so to solve this as you can see
over here we are just printing out R1
and R2 so this reference over here don't
need to be mutable right
because it's sufficient that we have a
read-only reference to S and again the
rule states that we can have as many
immutable references as we want
so this is compiling and also just to
show you
when dealing with references over here
as you can see s is still valid
right
error borrow an immutable object as
mutable
fix the error by modifying this line as
you can see we have here a string
and we call here borrow object with a
mutual reference to S so the problem
over here is that we can't pass a mutual
reference to something which is
immutable so we have to make this
variable over here mutable and then we
can
uh
then we can provide here a mutable
reference to this variable
but the other way around it's no problem
okay borrow a mutual object as immutable
so this code has no errors as you can
see we have here a string
and we are passing to the borrow object
and immutable reference right
now
this would actually compile because as
you can see the function signature
States it should be an immutable
reference even though s itself is
mutable we can still pass it as an
immutable reference this would compile
without problems
and then over here you can see we are
even mutating s because it's mutable
comment one line to make it work we have
here a string
and we have a mutable reference to S
right
so this would be the type annotation
mutable reference to a string type
now we are then mutating R1
and over here we again have a mutable
reference to s
and then we are modifying R2 the problem
here is that you know the rule that we
can only have one mutable reference at a
time
but as you can see R1 over here gets
used again so this should remain valid
but we can't have two valid mutable
references at the same time so if I
comment this out
then this program should compile because
we are not using R1 after this point
meaning we can have another mutable
reference
and even if I print out here R2
this should also compile
because over here the only valid mutable
reference to S would be R2 because we
are not using R1 after this point
so over here again we have a string
and we have two mutable references to S
now if we would run that
it would actually
compile
as you can see the program compiles
even though we have two mutable
references to S but we are not using any
one of these in the program
but over here it says add one line below
to make a compiler error cannot borrow S
as mutable more than once at a time
you can't use R1 and R2 at the same time
so let's use both of them over here
to force this compiler error
and as you can see this would be the
compiler error we are expecting Canon to
borrow S as mutable more than once at a
time
and over here you can see really the Rus
compiler is one of the best compilers
I've ever seen because it provides you
with really useful compiler messages
alright see you in the next topic so we
have now reached the topic of compound
types now a compound type is a type
which is made up of other types for
example a string is made up of
characters so it's considered a compound
type
now we have in Rust two types of strings
we have string with a capital S string
like that and we have string slices now
if I say string I will always refer to
this type otherwise I will say string
slice
so a string is a heap allocated string
type that owns its contents and is
mutable we have seen that a string is
allocated in Heap memory
a string slice is an immutable sequence
of utf-8 bytes in memory it does not own
the underlying data and is immutable
so think of string slice as a view on a
sequence of characters stored as utf-8
bytes in memory it's basically just read
only
so use string slice if you just want to
view a string
and string slice is more lightweight and
efficient than string and U string if
you need to own the data and be able to
mutate it
then we have string literals a string
literal is a sequence of characters
enclosed in double quotes
its fixed size compile time known
sequence of utf-8 bytes the type is
reference to static string which
indicates the data is stored in static
storage meaning it is valid throughout
the entire lifetime of the program
the data is hard-coded into the
executable and stored in read-only
memory meaning they are immutable
so let's now see an example of a string
slice and I'm seeing my head is in the
way here
let's do it like that
so let's see
over here we are initializing s with a
string now again I repeat myself I know
but this is very important s doesn't
hold the actual data it holds a pointer
which points to the data that is that is
allocated in Heap memory so s will have
a pointer alongside other metadata that
will point to the first
character of the string
and let's now consider this world
variable here so we are taking a
reference to s
meaning s will remain the owner of the
Heap allocated string
so we are taking a reference to S and
providing here an offset
from 6 to 11. now I hope you remember in
a Range this would be excluded so it
would be from 6 to 10.
so when we look at the world variable we
see that it has a pointer and a length
now this length over here is actually
false I'm sorry for that this should be
the length of the string slice in this
case one two three four five so this
pointer points to the offset of the
string we have provided so it points to
index six
and it goes to 10 because again 11 is
excluded so this world here will hold a
string slice of
this word
right
so the string slice World points to a
sequence of characters stored on the
Heap this is basically just a view into
a heap allocated string and that's why
it's immutable
all right
the type of string literal hello world
is Ampersand stir for example let s
string slice equals hello world now this
would be a string literal right because
we are
hard coding it into the executable
and a string literal is also considered
a string slice because it's also
immutable and it's basically just a
reference to the static memory this
string gets stored in
so store and string slice we can't use
Stir type in normal ways but we can use
reference to stir
fix error without adding new line as you
can see this would over here be a string
literal we are hard coding this string
into the executable into the program
itself
so again we can't use Stir as a type but
we can use a reference to a stir right
we can only use Stir by boxing it
Ampersand can be used to convert Boxster
to string slice now fix the arrow with
at least two solutions as you can see
over here we have a string literal a
string hard coded into the program
itself
then we call the into method we will
cover that later but basically into will
convert a type into the type we are
annotating here so this string literal
will be put into
a box meaning it will be Heap allocated
then we are calling this greetings
function with an argument s
and as you can see as this argument over
here is has to be of string slice so
what we can do over here to convert this
box into a string slice is passing a
reference to this box
as you can see this is compiling but we
even can just omit all of this
right this photo would be string slice
and we then just pass s notice that we
don't have to pass a reference to S
because s is already the type we need
string type is defined in standard
library and stored as a vector of bytes
back but guaranteed to always be a valid
utf-8 sequence string is Heap allocated
growable and not null terminated
so let's see we want to initialize here
s with a string right
then we are mutating
this string over here and mutate it
again now over here we are pushing to it
a string literal and over here we are
pushing to it a single chart now if you
push a single chart you just use the
push method not
not the push stir method
and in the end as should hold hello
world now we can initialize here an
empty string like that
this is now an empty string type
now why are we using this type over here
and not string slice
like so for example
why aren't we use why aren't we doing it
like that
because remember a string slice and
string literals are immutable
they are just references to some string
data in the memory so we have to use
string here
so we are here initiating an empty
string and then we are mutating it and
push to its held over and this
exclamation mark
this compiles let's output the string
as you can see
the string over here has been mutated
and that's the whole point of using this
string type over here it can be mutated
they can grow and shrink and so on
so let's see exercise four fix all
arrows without adding new line as you
can see over here we have initialized a
variable with a string
then we are mutating this string over
here which means we have to make this
variable s here mutable
so we are pushing A Single Character
this comma and then we are pushing
another string like that and we can even
push to the string by using this
notation here even though I don't like
it but it's also possible
but over here
we have two
pass it a string literal because this is
defined in this standard Library
all right
let's see
and of course over here sorry we have to
use the push stir
method
as you can see this is compiling so
again we are pushing A Single Character
then we are using here the push stir
method pushing a string literal and we
can also mutate strings like that
we place can be used to replace
substring
again we have here a string
and we then can replace
some elements inside the string
so we provide as first argument
the element we want to replace in this
case dogs
and it should be replaced with cats
so S1 should then hold I like cats now
again replace will mutate the string
meaning the S should be mutable
foreign
methods can be found under string module
so number six you can only concat a
stream with a string slice and strings
ownership can be moved to another
variable
so we have here S1 holding a string
and S2 also holding a string
now as you can see we want to
concatenate these two strings and we can
use the plus operator for that
now in the rust documentation it says
that the first argument should be of
type string while all other arguments
must be string slices
so we have to convert S2 over here to a
string slice now there are two
possibilities the first one is using the
s store method like that so this over
here will then be considered as a string
slice
so we have converted a string to a
string slice
right
but the output
but the result of this concatenation
will be of type string it's important to
remember that
and S3 should then hold this
concatenated strings
now because S1 over here has been moved
inside S3 we can't use S1 anymore
because S3 has become the owner of this
data
so let's instead print out S3
and as you can see this is compiling now
there is an easier approach to that we
can convert a string to a string slice
by just
providing a reference to a string so a
reference to a string can be
inferred to a string slice like that
string slice and string opposite to the
seldom using of stir string slice and
string are used everywhere
swing slice can be converted to string
in two ways so we have covered that
fixed arrow with at least two solutions
so over here we have a string slice
right
now
we call the greetings function over here
with an argument of s now s should
actually be of type string
so we can convert that by calling this
two string method like that
so we have converted here
a string slice to a string
all right
the second way would be
doing it like that string from and then
providing s
as you as you can see this is compiling
and
there are other ways for example two
ohms even though
I think this is not used that much
because it's more General but it's also
possible
right we can use string form or two
string to convert a string slice to a
string use two approaches to fix the
arrow and without adding a new line
as you can see we have here a string
literal that has been put into a string
so this variable over here will hold a
type of string
now to convert this s over here into a
string slice because this is the type
annotation of this variable we can as I
did before we can pass as as a reference
and again
a reference to a string will be inferred
to a string slice
again we can use as stir for example
would be the same
string escapes you can use escapes to
ride bytes by their hexadecimal values
fill the blank below to show I'm writing
rust
so as you can see we can escape
certain values and they will then be
convert to ASCII characters for example
this would be the hexadecimal
representation
of the ASCII value of s
right so if we want to write rust here
then the next
character to S would be T so we would
write
X 74.
like that
and you can check this out over here
there are a lot of examples
where we can just Escape using the
backslash Now using two backslashes here
will print out this literal
and these literal characters so the
output will be backslash x3f okay
because we are basically escaping this
backslash
all right and over here we have raw
string and a raw string is a string in
which there are no escapes so everything
is printed literally as it is written so
the output of this let me run that
so the output of this would be
backslash x3f it won't be converted to
an ASCII character
so let's see string index you can't use
index to access HR in a string but you
can use slice
reference to a S1 for example and the
offset
so let's see we have here a string
and now we want to access the first
character
now in most programming languages this
would be possible but in Rust you have
to use string slices meaning you take a
reference to S1 and then provide the
offset if we want to only access the
first character we would provide an
offset in form of a range from 0 to 1.
now again in a Range this would be
excluded meaning we only access this
first element
so the return type will then be a string
slice notice something here when we
assert age we would have a string of H
and not a character even though we are
here only accessing a character we are
accessing it using these string slice
this string slice notation over here
so remember a string slice is just a
view into a heap allocated string right
so we are just looking what is at this
location
in this case we just want to access the
first location over here
right
modify this line to fix the error tips
this would take three bytes in utf-8
format and that's right we have said
that a character in Rust is of size 4
bytes now a character in a string is a
little bit different so if it is an
ASCII a character then it will usually
take one byte and DC Unicode characters
can take three bytes or I guess some of
them even four bytes
all right so we want to have in H1 only
this character
so again we are taking a reference to S1
and providing an offset oh
8 would be at index 0 I would be at
index 1 this comma index 2 and then this
will be index 3. now this takes up three
bytes so we have to provide here an
offset from three to six remember six is
excluded so it goes from three to five
three four five three bytes
let me output that
as you can see this would be the output
and again this is just a view into a
heap allocated string right
operate on utf-8 string fill the blank
to print each character in this string
so over here there is a method called
chores
now chores will put this sequence of
characters into an iterator meaning we
can then iterate over it using a for
Loop for example
and that means
c will then be in each iteration one of
these characters and we will then just
find out C
as you can see in each iteration we are
printing out a single character alright
that's it see you in the next topic so
we'll Now cover arrays now an array is a
fixed size collection of elements of the
same data types stored as contiguous
Block in stack memory now it's stored in
stack memory because its size is known
at compiled time
the signature of an array is like that
you can see over here
which indicates that the length is fixed
at compile time arrays can neither grow
nor shrink they must retain their size
so let's see
the type of array is like this as you
can see erase length is part of their
type signature so their length must be
known at compiled time for example you
can't initialize an array like below
this would not be possible as you can
see we have an init R function which
takes an argument of type i32 and then
we try over here to initialize an array
with
the length that is provided as an
argument
this would be and compiler error because
as we've seen the size of an array must
be known at compiled time if we do it
like that the size of the array would
only be known at runtime this will cause
an error because the compiler has no
idea of the exact size of the array at
compile time let's see fill the blank
with proper array type
as you can see we have here an array
with five elements now what would be the
type of these elements it would be the
default integer type which is i32
so we annotate arrays like that in
square brackets then we would have to
type of the elements
and the amount of elements inside of the
array which is five
modify the code below to make it work so
we can call the Len method on an array
and it will then provide the length of
the array
so in this case this would be 5 right
because there are five elements inside
number two we can ignore parts of the
array type or even the whole type let
the compiler infer it for us
so we actually don't have to annotate
the type or we can annotate the type but
leave
for example the type annotation here for
the compiler to infer
fill the blank arrays or stack allocated
size of well returns to bytes which in
Array occupies HR takes four bytes in
Rust Unicode Char so we have seen that
before the size of well we'll just take
an argument and it will output the size
in bytes
the provided argument occupies in memory
so if we provide the r over here then we
should actually get back
3 times 4 bytes because because a
character in Rust takes four bytes
meaning
this array over here would occupy 12
bytes in memory
all elements in an array can be
initialized to the same value at once
so as you can see we have here an array
which should hold 100 elements
and each element should hold the number
one okay we are here accessing the first
element
and this is the notation for accessing
elements in an array in this case we
access the first element at index 0.
until length would be 100 so instead
of typing out 100 times 1 we have a
short 10 Syntax for that
so we can here first of all provide the
element it should hold in this case one
and we want it to hold 100 elements of
this value over here
number four all elements in an array
must be of the same type
so as you can see because when we
annotate an array we actually have to
define the type here
in this case we want integer types and
we have three of them now as you can see
this is a torrent this is not possible
all elements inside an array must be of
the same type
indexing starts at zero so over here we
have an array of characters let's
annotate that
and there are three elements inside it
and now we want to access the first
element right
we want this variable over here to hold
the first element now again arrays our
zero indexed meaning we access it using
this notation here and provided a value
of 0.
out of bounds indexing causes panic so
over here we have an array
which holds two strings
and we want to
access the first element right
now we can use this notation over here
like we did before or we could use the
get method the difference is that get
will return an option type we'll cover
that in a later episode but it's
generally safer than using this notation
and this is especially true if you're
accessing elements at runtime okay
so
we can use this notation or we could use
this notation now over here this would
panic because this array has only two
elements meaning indexes 0 and 1. so
let's access here index one
and this compiles
so let's see slices a slice is a
reference to a contiguous sequence of
elements in a collection it provides a
way to borrow part of a collection
without taking ownership of the entire
collection it can be created from arrays
vectors strings and other collections
implementing DT ref trade
so let's see this example of a slice we
have here an array and then we are over
here taking a reference to a and
providing an offset
essentially the same thing we did with
string slices right a slice is just a
view into a collection
and over here we try to access the
elements at index 1 to index two right
because 3 would be excluded
so the variable slice will then hold a
slice with the elements 2 and 3 in it
all right let's see slices are similar
to arrays but their length is not known
at compiled time so you can't use slice
directly
here both this slice over here and store
or slice types but directly using it
will cause errors you have to use the
reference of this slice instead so
because these two slices over here
their sizes are not known at compile
time we have to use a pointer to that
right
and we have seen that in the example of
string slices
so we use this syntax over here
fix the arrows don't add new lines
as you can see we are holding here an
array let's annotate the type
like that
this is an array of three i32 integers
now we want here to get a slice with
this offset meaning from 0 to 1 0 1.
so again like we did with a string slice
we want a reference to an array
with this specific offset so we are
trying to access 0 to 1 because 2 is X
because 2 is excluded meaning we are
accessing here index 0 and 1. the
elements one and two so this slice over
here
will then hold one and two right
now the type annotation here would be
like that because we are holding a
reference to this array right and this
would be the type annotation of a slice
now over here we have a string later on
now
string literals as we've seen always are
annotated like that
string literal is hard coded into the
program's binary and that's why we can
access it using a reference
to this string literal over here which
is in the binary itself
all right
a slice reference is a two word object
for Simplicity Reasons from now on we
will use slice instead of slice
reference the first word is a pointer to
the data and the second word is the
length of this slice the word size is
the same as U size determined by the
processor architecture for example 64
bits on an
x8664 slices can be used to borrow a
section of an array and have the type
signature
like this
where T over here stands for the type
as you can see we have here an array
with three characters
now we want to have a slice of this
array with
the first two elements these two
elements
and this is shorthand notation instead
of writing it like that we can just omit
the zero
all right so we are accessing 0 1 and 2
is excluded
so the slice variable should hold a
slice with these elements
the type annotation over here would be
reference
to char
okay
modify 8 to make it work tips slice
reference is not an array if it is an
array then assert will be packed each of
the two characters this and this
occupies four bytes 2 times 4 8.
now because this slice variable over
here doesn't actually hold an array but
a slice
we are here actually holding a pointer
right because this is a reference to
this array
and that means we have seen over here A
Slice reference is a two word object
meaning the pointer and the length field
will both occupy sizes of Type U size
and your size
if you're on a 64-bit computer it means
you size will be of size 8 bytes or 64
bits
and that's why a slice holds
16 bytes
right
if we would pass the array here we would
have
if this slice would have been an array
then 8 would actually pass because we
would have two characters each character
is four bytes meaning eight bytes but
because we have a slice which holds a
pointer and a length both of Type U size
we have 16.
so over here we have an array of five
integers of type i32
fill the blanks to make the code work as
you can see we want the slice variable
to hold a slice of these elements
so
let's first
annotate the type actually so this slice
variable over here should hold a slice
of I 32 elements right so we are taking
a reference to the array and provided an
offset we want to go from this to this
meaning index 0 1 we are starting at 1
and we go up to 0 1 2 3 4.
and I choose 4 here because 4 is
excluded so we will go from 0 1 2 3 to
index 3.
string slices
and we've covered that already but let's
do some exercises for repetition now
over here we have a string and we take
over here a string slice
meaning we take only
the first two characters
like that
or let me write
like like that right we take the first
two characters
fill the blank to make the code work
don't use 0 to 2 again
so over here we have a second variable
which should hold a string slice and
they should actually hold the same
elements as you can see over here we are
we are here asserting that slice one and
slice two are the same
so instead of using this syntax over
here as we've seen before we can use
like that we can omit t0
over here we have a string literal
again a string literal is hardcoded in
2D binary and this would be the type
annotation
modify this line to make the code work
as you can see we want slice over here
to hold
a string slice with only this character
so let's annotate the type this would be
a string slice and because this Unicode
character over here takes three bytes we
have to provide an offset here of three
meaning
zero one two right three bytes
alright last one number six a reference
to a string can be implicitly converted
into a string slice
now over here we initialize a variable s
which holds a string
here reference to S is reference to
string type but first word needs aced
but first word needs a string slice as
you can see over here
it works because reference to string can
be implicitly converted to string slice
so as you can see over here we are
calling the first word function which
takes us an argument a type of string
slice
and
this would actually work because we are
here providing a reference to S which
means this over here is
a reference to a string right
and
a reference to a string can be converted
to a string slice implicitly by the
compiler
so then this function over here will
take a reference
of s
and provides an offset from 0 to 1 where
1 is excluded so we just so we just take
the first element
and it returns this as a string slice
that means that the return value of this
function will be assigned to the word
variable
then over here we are calling the clear
method on S which means this string will
then be empty clear will just remove
every content in the string the string
itself will still remain in memory with
the same capacity and S also is valid so
it's different from drop but it will
empty the string essentially
so we will then have over here an empty
string
the problem over here is that clear
takes immutable reference to self
and
that's a problem because over here we
have a reference which is immutable to S
and we have over here immutable
reference to us
now
the problem arises because we are here
using the immutable reference so if we
would delete that and put it over here
then
after this point the word variable over
here which holds an immutable reference
is not used anymore and so we can use
this clear method
and this is compiling and as you can see
we just get the first element
alright see you in the next topic
now we will cover tuples we have seen
some tuples before and some exercises
but now we will go into greater detail
so a tuple is a way to store related
pieces of information in a single
variable and it's essentially a
collection of values of different types
grouped together as a single compound
value again a compound value is a type
composed of other types
it's stored as a fixed size contiguous
block of memory on this stack and the
signature is parentheses and the types
the Tuple is holding
let's see
elements in a couple can have different
types pupils type signature is like that
where T1 T2 are the types of tuples
members
so as you can see we can hold different
types we have here an u8 and an i16
together in a tuple
tuples can be tuples members so we can
even Nest tuples so this Tuple over here
as you can see
holds an u8 over here
and another Tuple inside it which holds
an i16 and a u32 integer
all right
fill the blanks to make the code work
so over here we have to annotate the
type now again the first element over
here would be u8 the second one is u16
the third one is an I64
the fourth one would be a string literal
and the last one is a string
members can be extracted from the Tuple
using indexing
so as you can see we have here a tuple
let's annotate the type
this is how we would annotate a tuple
and it holds
three string literals
then we are accessing here the second
element tuples remember are zero indexed
but in this case it would be M but we
want it to equal sulfates so we have to
access
d
index 2 right 0 1 2.
long tuples cannot be printed so
if a tuple exceeds a certain amount of
elements it is too long to be printed
as you can see this would be too long
if I delete that over here
so this would work so we can have up to
12 elements in a tuple to make it
printable
if it exceeds 12 elements you can still
use it but it's not printable
the structuring Tuple with pattern
so let's first annotate the type of this
Tuple here
we have an i32
the default integer type then we have a
float
which means f64 the default floating
Point type and we have a string literal
fill the blank to make the code work
so over here we want to destructure this
Tuple where X holds one y holds hello
and that holds 6.4
so let's see
re-distructure tuples like this using
the let keyword and the parentheses
then
the first element should be X right
now the second element 6.4 should be put
into Z
and the last element should be
destructured into variable y
the structural assignments over here we
are declaring some variables and then
over here we destructure this Tuple and
we want to put it inside these variables
so we can so because we have already
declared these variables we don't need
to declare it once more so we can omit
the LED keyword
and then
all we do is we destructure it so one
should be put inside variable y
2 should be put inside variable Z
and 3 should be put inside variable X
tuples can be used as function arguments
and return values
fill the blank need a few computations
here
so
so as you can see we are calling this
function some multiply and this function
over here expects an argument of type
Tuple and the Tuple should hold two
integer values what we do over here is
we perform some operations and return it
in a tuple right so
so the first operation will be this one
adding the first element of the provided
Tuple with the second element of the
provided Tuple
and then we are multiplying the first
element of the provided Tuple with this
second element of the provided Tuple and
we return that in a tuple again so the
result of this operation over here will
be the first element
and the result of this operation will be
the second element and as you can see we
and as you can see we can return that in
a tuple
now after returning this Tuple we
destructure it so the first element will
be put in X and the second element will
be the structured to the variable Y
where X will hold 5 and Y will hold 6.
so we have now to provide here two
numbers when we add them together they
will equal they will evaluate to five if
we multiply the two numbers they will
evaluate two six so this is a little
riddle for you and try to solve it
and the answer would be
2 3 right and don't forget to add here
parentheses because we are passing it
here a tuple right we are not passing
two arguments we are passing one
argument which is a tuple that holds two
elements very important
so if we add 2 and 3 we will get 5 and
if we multiply two times three we will
get six and this will be the return type
of this Tuple over here
all right see you in the next topic
up until now we have been using types
that are defined in this standard
library but we can in fact create our
own types
and we can do that by using a struct now
a struct is a compound type allowing to
group together values of different types
into a named data structure
it's similar to tuples but each value
has a name so the values can then be
accessed through this name
and a struct has to be instantiated with
data think of it like destruct itself is
the template for the instances you
create from it
now let's see how that works
as you can see over here we have our
template in this case a struct named
user and the user struct holds various
fields and we can define a field by
giving it a name and a type that this
field should hold so in this case the
active field holds a type of Boolean
username holds a type of string email
string and sign in count u64 and then we
can instantiate this struct and we do
that by calling the name of destruct
user in this case and providing for each
field a concrete type
and of course the types have to match
the template
then we are assigning this instance we
have created over here to a variable so
this variable will then hold an instance
of the user struct
and we can access and even mutate the
fields of an instance so over here as
you can see we have created an instance
and assigned it to the user1 variable
and then we can use this syntax over
here to access a field
so in this case we are even mutating the
email field from the instance user 1. as
you can see we do that exactly like we
would mutate a variable
just assigning it a new value
now to mutate you have to make it
explicitly mutable meaning you use the
mute keyword here like you did with
variables
and functions can also create instances
and return it so in this case we have
the build user function which creates an
instance of the user struct and as you
can see again it's just providing
concrete values for each of its fields
and over here as you can see this
function takes two arguments email of
type string and username of type string
and then it provides it 2D username
field and to the email field
now in this case we are repeating
ourselves as you can see and we can
avoid this by just using this shorthand
syntax
so if the name of a field and the name
of a variable or argument matches then
we can write it like that and this just
makes it less verbose
and there is also a concept called
struct update syntax so over here we
have an instance of the user struct now
we want to create another instance but
taking some of the values from the
fields from user 1. as you can see for
example in this instance we want the
active field to hold
the value of user 1's active field
so we are accessing user 1 and the
active field
and as you can see we are taking
everything from this user one instance
except the email
and
as I've said there is a better way to
write this and this would be
instantiating a struct like we did
before but just providing the fields
that are different from the instance we
we want to take from it
so for example over here we say that the
email field should hold this value
and the remaining values should be taken
from this user 1 instance so this will
then create a user instance
with all the same values from user 1
except the email field
then we also have Tuple structs and
Tuple structs are like normal structs
but using tuple-like Syntax for defining
their fields it's basically a named
Tuple and it's instantiated by
parentheses instead of curly braces and
its values are accessed using Point
notation
and then we have unit-like structs and
these are structs without any Fields
meaning they don't hold any values
and it's mainly used when working with
trades and this will be covered soon
and that means they don't store any data
let's solve some exercises the types of
structs
exercise one we must specify concrete
values for each of the fields in
destruct
as you can see we have here a person
struct holding various fields
and then over here we have a variable H
which holds a value of 30. now then we
are instantiating this person's struct
and assign it to the variable P meaning
P will then be an instance of the
person's struct
now as you can see we have here the
fields and the concrete values
and this would be the shorthand Syntax
for this because we have over here a
variable matching the name of the field
so we can write it like that
but as you've noticed we didn't provide
the hobby field a concrete value so when
you are instantiating a struct you have
to provide to each field a concrete
value so let's do that
and the variable P will then hold a type
of person
now h of course has to match with the
templates so this would be an u8
[Applause]
and of course
we use commas here and not say me colons
all right
unit struct doesn't have any field it
can be useful when you need to implement
a trade on some type but don't have any
data that you want to store in the type
itself
so as you can see this example is using
trades and we have and we have not yet
covered that so I will skip that because
this might just be confusing and we will
cover that soon
number three Tuple truck looks similar
to tuples it has added meaning this
track name provides but has no named
fields
it's useful when you want to give the
whole Tuple a name but don't care about
the fields names
so as you can see over here we have two
Tuple structs one color and one point
and they are exactly like tuples but
they are named okay so over here we have
three integer values in the color Tuple
struct and in the points rack the same
thing now we want to instantiate the
point struct over here
and the variable V will then hold an
instance
of our custom type point
then we are calling the check color
function and provide an argument of B
now as you can see
the check color function
takes an argument of type color but this
is not what we want right because we are
here passing a variable of type point so
let's change that
and over here we are then destructuring
the instance
that was passed so in this case as you
can see X should hold zero so let's
provide this value over here
then the P1 field and as you can see we
are accessing
the fields in the Tuple struct like we
would access elements in a normal Tuple
using this syntax so over here we are
accessing the second element and this
should hold 127.
so that means the last element should
hold 255.
and
as you can see over here we are
destructuring
so the first element over here gets this
structured into a variable X
now the second one over here we don't
need to destructure right because we are
accessing it directly using the PE
instance
and the last one let's call this Z okay
and by the way when destructuring and
you don't need a value like for example
this one you just provided an underscore
let's see
and of course when the structuring we
have to provide the name of this truck
in this case point
and this is compiling
operating on structs you can make a
whole struct mutable when instantiating
it but rust doesn't allow us to Mark
only certain Fields as mutable
fill the blank and fix the arrow without
adding removing new line
again we have the person struct we have
here the age variable
let's annotate that and we have the P
instance
so as you can see we want to mutate the
age field of the P instance
and this is right but the problem is the
P instance is not mutable so let's make
that mutable
and then we can also mutate the name
field like that
using field initial shortened syntax to
reduce repetitions
so again we have the person struct and
in main we are just printing out
something and over here we have the
build person function so as you can see
this function takes two arguments name
of type string and H of type u8
and these arguments exactly match the
types defined in the template
so then we can over here instantiate a
person struct
meaning we can hear for the name field
provide this argument
[Applause]
and we have seen we can use field image
for 10 syntax meaning if the field name
matches the name of a variable or an
argument we can skip it like that
let's see exercise 6 you can create an
instance from another instance with
struct update syntax so as you can see
we have here the user struct and we have
seen an example of that in these slides
then over here we are creating an
instance from the user struct
that means the variable U1 will then
hold an instance
that means that the variable U1 will
then be an instance of the user type and
again we are just providing each field
over here with a concrete value
then over here
we call the set email function with an
argument of the U1 instance
so let's see over here as you can see in
the function signature the argument must
be of type user
and then we want to create over here a
new instance
and what we want to achieve here is that
we take everything
we take every field from the U1 instance
except for the email field we want to
we want that to be different
so what we can do is providing a
concrete value for the email field and
then just saying the rest we want to
take from the argument provided
and then we are just returning it
so that means U2 will then hold a newly
created instance
Point distracts we can use derive debug
to make a struct printable click fill
the blanks to make the code work so you
actually can't print out a struct using
the normal print line syntax
we have to
so to be able to print a struct we have
to derive a trade again we will cover
trades but we have to derive that
using an attribute all right that means
that destruct rectangle here
implements this debug trade and that
means we can then use debug notation to
print it out
so over here as you can see we have a
variable scale
and then we are creating here a
rectangle instance
so we are providing a concrete value for
the
field with
and this would be 30 times the scale
and we provide a concrete value for
height now as you can see print debug
info to standard error and assign the
value of 30 times scale to width
now this debug macro over here will just
print out debug information to the
standard error output
and
that means over here rect one will then
hold an instance of the type rectangle
and the type annotation for the scale
variable over here would be u32
right because we are passing this scale
variable over here meaning it should be
of Type U 32.
and then again we are here
using the debug macro and printing out
racked one and instead of doing that we
can also use a normal print line
statement
like you're used to except that in the
placeholder over here we have to use
this notation and this is called debug
notation
meaning any type that implements the
debug trade can then be printed
and the difference between debug macro
and printland macro as you can see print
line will point to the standard output
while debug will print to the standard
error and that's why you don't see it
over here you just see the print line
output
now to see that
[Applause]
I will go to the rust playground
and we can just run this code
and as you can see over here this would
be
the debug output
so this debug macro over here prints out
the exact thing we are passing to the
width field in this case 60. and this
debug macro over here points out
the instance right we then have an
rectangle with a width of 60 and a
height of 50. basically the same thing
that we print out with the print line
statement here
foreign
move within the destructuring of a
single variable both by move and by
reference pattern bindings can be used
at the same time doing this will result
in a partial move of the variable which
means that parts of the variable will be
moved while other parts stay in such a
case the parent variable cannot be used
afterwards as a whole however the parts
that are only referenced and not moved
can still be used
and I guess we have seen that before but
let's do another exercise
so as you can see
right we have seen that
alright so let's move to the exercises
directly because I've already covered
that
and I think the exercises are better for
understanding so as you can see fix the
arrows to make it work over here we have
a file struct holding two fields of type
string
then in main we are creating an instance
of the filed struct providing it
concrete values for each field meaning F
will then hold an instance of the file
struct
and over here we are then assigning the
name field of the F instance to the
underscore name variable
so what would be the type annotation
here
it would be string right because F name
holds a string
and that means the name variable here
will become the owner of this string
data
and that is the reason that we then
cannot use f as a whole and also not F
dot name because a partial move happened
so if a field gets moved out to another
owner then you can't access this field
and also not the data structure that is
holding this field
so this would fail over here and this
would fail now to fix that we can
actually access
just the name variable here right
because this is now the owner of this
string
but what we can't do is accessing the
whole instance over here this is not
possible
as you can see this is working
now
if you actually want to keep f as the
owner of all the fields
and to print it out like that
and by the way notice again when we are
outputting
a single field we used in normal
notation if we output the whole instance
then we have to use debug notation
because these fields over here hold
types that are defined in the standard
Library while this is a custom type we
have created
so to make that work we can also use
here the Clone method
and as you can see this is working and
we are here printing out the instance
all right see you in the next topic
we can also create custom types using
enums now an enum is a way of defining a
type with only one of a possible set of
values we can only access one variant of
an enum at a time
and it can hold additional information
using tuples
and it's especially useful when using in
match statements
let's see an example of an enum so we
have here the enum IP address
and this enum holds two variance so in
enums we call it variance and not Fields
like instructs
and each variant over here holds a type
using tuple-like syntax all right so an
IP address by the way can be in either
one of two formats either it's V4 or B6
and now we will see the difference
between enums and structs so this is how
we would instantiate this enum IP
address
we are accessing the name of the enum
double colon and then the name of the
variant in this case V4 then providing
it a concrete value
I hope you noticed the difference
in a struct we would have
provided concrete values for each field
in an enum we instantiate the enum only
with one single variant all right
so this home variable will then hold an
instance of the IP address enum
and this loopback variable over here
will also hold an instance of IP address
but using the variant V6
and by the way this is the old format of
IP addresses ntcc new one
so let's do some exercises enums can be
created with an explicit discriminator
so enums are enumerated right that's why
they are called enum now if you don't
provide here a value it will be
implicitly starting from zero
this would be one and this would be two
and we can also enumerate them with an
explicit discriminator okay so this will
then hold zero this variant will be one
and this will be two
and over here you can see C like enum
now you can't use as a discriminator a
floating point value this is not allowed
but like in C if you for example would
do it like that
we are here providing the discriminator
5. then
1 and 2 implicitly will be six
and seven
right or we could say
this should be 9 for example
right
so you can manipulate the enumeration of
an enum
so let's see actually let me change that
back
and let me change that to integers
an inner variant can be converted to an
integer by the as keyword
so when we take
this enum over here and we create an
instance
as we've said as we've seen calling the
name of the enum and the variant
and then we can convert it to an u8 for
example right
and we can do the same thing here
and over here should be the same thing
and as you can see this is compiling
let me print out
[Applause]
as you can see when we access from the
number in on the variant one then A1
will get outputted now let's see if I
provided a value of 10 over here
but for that I have to
comment that out
as you can see
this foot would then be
the discriminator for the one variant
all right each enum variant can hold its
own data
so as you can see we have here an enum
message
now this enum has different variants so
this variant quit doesn't hold any
additional data but while this variant
move here holds Fields it's very struct
like
and this variant right is tube alike so
it holds a value in a tuple syntax and
the same thing for change color
so we can then instantiate the move
variant from the message enum
with these values over here X1 and Y 2.
and as you can see because this is very
struck like you instantiate it basically
like a struct
and over here instantiating with hello
world as you can see this variant over
here
holds a string type
so
[Applause]
like that
and please notice over here that both of
these variables here hold the same type
message
because this is also a custom type A
type we have created
we can get the data which an enum
variant is holding by pattern matching
so
over here we have the same enum like we
saw before
and over here we have an instance
of team move variant
now we can here use E flat and we will
cover that in the next section
two
get out the data inside
this move variant so we are matching
here the message variable holding an
instance of the move variant
and then over here we can basically
destructure it so X should then be
destructured into a variable a
and Y should be restructured into a
variable B and then as you can see we
can use these two variables
now we are here asserting A and B
and a stands for this value and b stands
for this value and as you notice they
are not the same so this would fail
actually
so let me change that
and now let's run the program
fill in the blank and fix the errors
again same enum and over here we have an
array of
different variants from this enum type
right we have the quit variant the move
variant and the change color variant now
the neat thing here is that all of these
instances are of the same type message
right our custom type now I hope you
remember how we annotate an array
so first thing will be the type and then
the number of elements
Let's see we have over here three
elements right
and the type would be
I hope you know it
message right all of these variants
or instances hold the same type
and then over here we are looping over
this array here
meaning
message this variable will hold in each
iteration one of these instances
and then passing it to the show message
function and as you can see when we want
to take
an instance of this inner message we can
just use the type message here because
again all of them all
because all of them have the same type
and all we do then is just printing it
out
and again because this is a custom type
we cannot print it out just like that so
we have to use debug notation here
and derive over here
the debug trait
[Applause]
and as you can see
in each iteration over here we call the
show message function and it will print
out
the contents of this array
so let's see exercise five since there
is no null in Rust we have to use enum
option to deal with the cases when the
value is absent and I want to show you
some slides for that
so the option enum option is an enum
that represents a value that may or may
not be present it's known in other
languages as null and it's referring to
the absence of a value it's used to
handle cases where a function or method
might fail to return a value
so this is how the enum option looks
like as defined by the standard Library
as you can see it's an enum holding two
variants none and some now this over
here is a generic meaning that sum can
hold any type and we'll cover generics
very soon
but for now again think that this can
hold any type provided so let's see an
example over here
we are here initializing the variable 5
with
D variant sum holding an integer value
right
and then over here we are calling the
function plus 1 providing it five
so let's see here as you can see the
argument should be of type option
and the type parameter here would be i32
now we have to provide a concrete type
for this generic type parameter now
again we will cover that in much greater
detail but as you can see this is
exactly the type we are passing to the
function sum is a variant of the option
enum and it is holding an i32 value
and it is holding an i32 type now then
we are matching this argument over here
if it is holding a non we will return
none if it is holding a sum then over
here we are destructuring the value
wrapped inside this sum variant into the
variable I and then over here we are
incrementing I by 1 and wrapping it in a
sum because as you can see the return
type over here is defined as option i32
and
that means that this variable over here
will then hold some 6 right because we
have incremented 5 over here by one so
this will hold an option type
and the concrete value would be sum 6.
the sum variant and a value of 6.
now over here we are calling the plus
one function with none meaning the
argument will get matched and
this will then get
returned right a non
and as you can see the non is also a
variant of the option Ina
and this i32 just stands for the sum
variant if your turn if we are returning
none then this type over here is still
valid because the non-variant here
doesn't hold any value of generic type t
but again generics are a topic on its
own
and by the way this is exactly the same
that we have over here so let's do that
annotating the type so over here we have
an option holding an i32
type all right and as I've said
this is not necessary you can omit that
because again
the option type is in the prelude
then we are calling the plus one
function
again we are providing it sum 5 which is
an option
and then we are matching the argument so
if the argument is none
then we return none
it is some
then we destructure the value
that was passed over here
and we incremented by one and return it
wrapped in some because
the return type has to be of type option
that means over here the type annotation
would be option i32
and in this case we are passing a non so
a non will be returned
and by the way
[Applause]
the Returns value here would be sum 6
right because 5
plus 1 will be 6.
and over here we have non-anti-type
annotation would still be
option I 32.
now we want actually to unwrap this
value inside this sum variant and we can
do that by using IF let
so as you can see we are matching these
six variables holding some six and then
we can destructure it basically so
we can then say sum
and the variable n
meaning we then can use n over here
and I see right now never let this run
so we have to pack that into an else
block
just to ensure that this doesn't run
after we are running this conditional
here
and as you can see it will output
the value inside sum now again we'll
cover generics will cover a flat and
match over here this will actually be
the next topic so don't worry if this
seems a little difficult to understand
we will cover that in much greater
detail
Implement a linked list via enums now
over here
this linked list
I won't cover because there are a lot of
things we haven't seen so in here we
have
um
methods and other things that we didn't
really cover so I think this would be
more confusing than it would be helpful
what I suggest you is that you will come
back after we have seen some more topics
you come back to this exercise and try
to solve it it's not that difficult and
the solution will be on my GitHub
account
but I think this is just Overkill right
now
so see you in the next topic
the normal flow of execution in a
program would be from top to bottom line
by line but we can actually manipulate
the flow of a program
and flow control is a concept that
refers to the ability to control the
order in which statements or
instructions are executed in a program
it allows to specify which instructions
should be executed under which
conditions and in what order
so we have many ways to do that and some
of them are for example using
conditionals so we have the if else
keywords and match for example
and we can use Loops for Loops while
Loops there is a special Loop in Rust
called Loop we'll cover that
and we can even manipulate the flow
inside the loop by keywords such as
continue and break so let's see
so let's start with if else conditionals
over here we are initializing n with a
value of 5. then over here we have an if
conditional checking if n is less than
zero in this case this would evaluate to
false meaning meaning this this
instruction over here will get ignored
and the program will continue executing
on the next line now in the next line we
have another conditional
so we can use here the else if keyword
and over here we are checking is n
bigger than zero
in this case this would evaluate to true
meaning this line will get printed out
now we can also match anything else
using the else keyword
meaning if this evaluates to false and
this evaluates to false then this will
get executed
now in this case this evaluates to true
so this will get executed meaning this
over here will be ignored
as you can see this was the line that
has been printed out
number two if else expression can be
used in assignments again initializing n
and over here we have a variable
assignment
now we can even use if else conditionals
when assigning a value to a variable now
remember in a variable assignment is a
statement so we so we have to end that
with a semicolon like that
so let's see we have here an if
conditional and this is a Boolean and
operation do you remember we have two
inputs and both of these inputs have to
evaluate to true in order the end
operation to return true
so let's see we have here n should be
less than 10 which would evaluate to
True right because 5 is less than 10.
and 5 is bigger than -10 so this end
operation will return true meaning the
meaning the code in this if conditional
block will get executed and over here we
are just printing out a line and then we
are multiplying n by 10 and in fact we
don't have a semicolon so this will be
returned from this expression meaning it
will then be assigned to the variable
Big N so big n will then hold
a type of i32
now in case this would evaluate to false
then this else block would get executed
meaning again we are printing out a line
and then dividing n by 2.0
now as you can see we should omit this
semicolon because this should
because this result over here should
then be assigned to this variable
now
we actually can't do this operation here
because n is of type i32 and we are
dividing it by a floating Point number
so we can
so we can Typecast that when I 32.
and as you can see
this would be
the output
and we are printing out big n meaning 50
over here
so n
has been multiplied by 10.
so let's see we have here a for Loop D4
in construct can be used to iterate
through an iterator for example a range
A to B
now as you can see we have a for Loop
declaring a variable n and we provide a
range
now this range over here reaches from 1
to 100 and 100 here included because we
have here the equal sign
then we are checking if n is equal to
100 this program will panic
that's not what we want so what we can
do over here is just removing this equal
sign because that means 100 is excluded
meaning n will never be equals to 100
the largest it will get will be 99
because let's see
all right
fix the arrows without adding or
removing lines so over here we have a
so over here we have an array
holding two strings
now we want then to iterate over this
array meaning this name variable will
hold
in the first iteration this string and
in the second iteration this string
so what we can do over here is
pointing out
name right so this will iterate two
times
and it will output this and then this
now as you can see we are trying to
access names again over here and that
would then violate the ownership rules
because as you can see in a for Loop
the for Loop actually will take
ownership of the provided value
and we can pass here a reference like we
have seen before and that means we can
use names then again
so
and by the way
we don't have to dereference name over
here because the print line statement
will do that automatically
now over here we have three i32 integers
the elements in numbers are copies so
there is no move here so we are
iterating over each element in this
array
where n will then hold in each iteration
one element from this array so let's see
[Applause]
so and this would be the output
as you can see in the first iteration
name will hold this string and in the
second iteration it will hold this
string and it prints it out in each
iteration then we print out the whole
array
and over here the same thing but with
the integers
so again we have an array
so iterate the indexing and value in a
so there is a useful method called
enumerate
and this enumerate method takes a
collection for example an array or a
tube pillar or anything else
and it will then return a tuple
and this Tuple will then hold the index
and T value meaning for example in the
first iteration this Tuple will hold
for i 0 and for V4 right because
at index 0 we have a value of 4 and it
will then just print out the index but
we increment it by one
and the actual value
and of course we have to put a into an
iterator
so let's see
like that so we have to first put a into
an iterator and then we can call this
enumerate method on it because the
enumerate method is implemented in the
iterator trade we'll take a look at that
later
so as you can see this will be the
output and
that was the reason we have incremented
I by one because we don't want to start
with the zeroest element is four right
so we say here the first element is four
second three and so on
while the while keyword can be used to
run a loop when a condition is true fill
in the blanks to make the last print Ln
work
so as you can see we have here a mutual
variable n
Loop while the condition is true
so as you can see this is a while loop
and we provided a conditional meaning if
this evaluates to true
then this Loop will keep running until
this conditional evaluates two folds
so inside the while loop we have other
conditionals as you can see we here
check
the condition and modulus 15 is 0. if
that would evaluate to true then we
print out that
and by the way this was a question at
coding interviews at Google
so
we are
here having more conditionals and
a
an else conditional so meaning if
anything of this fails then this will
get printed out
so what we can do over here checking if
n is less than 10 then this Loop will
keep running now when you're using while
Loops then you have to ensure that
the while loop eventually stops right
that this conditioner over here will
evaluate to false eventually because
otherwise you would have an infinite
Loop
now to do that we can increment and over
here
so I increment at the end of this while
loop
n by 1.
meaning at each meaning in each
iteration in this while loop n gets
incremented by one so n will eventually
be bigger or equal to 10 meaning this
would evaluate to false meaning we break
out of this Loop
continue and break use break to break
the loop
so we have here a for Loop looping from
0 to 100 and 100 included
so if n is 66 then we want to break out
of the loop
[Applause]
anti-break keyword
will immediately exit out of this for
Loop so when this conditional evaluates
to true we immediately exit out meaning
the program will continue execution
after the for Loop in this case this
line over here
let's see
so as you can see in the end n will be
equal to 66.
because when I is 66 then we stop
iterating
continue will skip over the remaining
code in current iteration and go to the
next iteration
so as you can see we are here again
iterating from 0 to 100
and we have here an if conditional if n
is not equal to 66 then we increment n
by 1.
and we want them to continue
meaning
that
that the remaining code
in this for Loop will get ignored so
discontinue keyword the program will go
back to the beginning of the for Loop
now in case this evaluates to false
right so if n is in fact 66 this would
evaluate to false meaning we ignore this
code block and we go over here where we
want to break out of the loo because as
you can see we want n to be 66 at the
end
Loop is usually used together with break
or continue
so Loop is a special Loop in Rust where
this is basically an infinite Loop and
you have to manually
manipulate the flow of the loop and we
will see soon so this is a u32 over here
count
so let's count until Infinity
as you can see we are here using the
loop keyword
meaning this would keep looping to
Infinity
or we provide some keywords that will
break out of the loop or continue
so as you can see in each iteration we
are incrementing the count variable by
one
now if count is equal to 3 then we print
out 3 and we want to skip the rest of
this iteration so we can use here the
continue keyword
meaning again the rest over here will be
ignored
the program will go back to the
beginning of the loop
so
then over here if count is not equal to
this will get printed out so we print
out the count in every iteration except
if count is equal to 3.
and then over here if count is equal to
5 then we'll print out okay that's
enough and we want to break out
meaning count in the end should hold a
value of 5.
you can see we are iterating one two and
then in the third iteration this if
conditional evaluates to true meaning we
print out three and we continue we are
going back to the beginning so the
actual value of count over here is not
printed as you can see there is no digit
3 but will printed out three over here
because that was defined in this code
block here
and then
add iteration 5 we will stop and break
out of the loop
so Loop is an expression so we can use
it with break to return a value
and again we have here a counter
so over here we have a loop and we are
in each iteration
incrementing counter by one
then we check if counter is equal to 10
then we want to break out
but as you notice we want to assign a
value to the result variable right this
variable should then hold an i32 but we
don't return anything here
so you can Define after the break
keyword a return value meaning for
example we want to return counter
but in this case result will hold 10
right because counter when we break out
will be 10 otherwise this conditional
would not evaluate to true so if counter
is 10 then we break out
but as you can see we want result to be
20. so we can even pass here an
operation so we can double the counter
value
let's see
and
this is compiling
it's possible to break or continue outer
Loops when dealing with nested Loops in
these cases the loops must be annotated
with some label and the label must be
passed to the break continuous statement
so
as you can see we can even Nest
different loops
so when we do that we have to actually
provide labels so we provide here outer
for the Outer Loop and inner one for the
inner loop and as you can see we have
even two inner Loops so we have inner
one and inner two
alright so let's see in the first inner
loop
we are checking if count is bigger than
or equal to 20.
if this is the case we break out of this
inner loop
otherwise we increment the count by two
all right
and notice here this would break only
the inner one Loop so when we break out
of this Loop this outer loop will still
continue looping okay
so then over here in the outer loop we
are incrementing count by five
and in this inner two Loop we are then
checking if count is bigger than or
equal to 30 then we break out of the
Outer Loop
otherwise if count is smaller than 30
then
the outer loop will continue meaning
the program will go back to the
beginning of the outer loop and continue
executing from here
so let's go step by step
and as you can see we have to find out
here what the count value will be in the
end
okay let's go step by step we start at
zero then over here we are checking is
Count bigger than or equal to 20 no
right
so that means count will get incremented
by two
and this will continue because we are in
this Loop remember and this will
continue until
this evaluates to true meaning when
count is 20 then we break out of this
inner loop meaning we continue
executing here
then
count would be 20 and we increment it by
5.
then we enter this inner two Loop
so 25 is not bigger or not equal to 30
meaning we don't break off outer but we
will continue outer meaning we go back
over here
now we enter this Loop here and 25 is
bigger than 20 so we break out of this
Inner Loop and continue here
then we add 5 to count meaning count is
now 30.
so we enter this inner two Loop and this
will now evaluate to true because count
is equal to 30 meaning we break out of
the outer loop so in this case count
will be 30 in the end
and this succeeded and I will see you in
the next topic
pattern match is a powerful construct
that allows you to compare a value
against a set of patterns and then
execute different code based on which
pattern matches
and these patterns can be made up of
literal values variable names wild cards
and so on and in a match statement all
possible cases must be handled and this
is enforced by the compiler
and really this match keyword is
something that I really miss when I'm
coding in other languages so once you
get used to it you will love it and you
will see why
so let's see an example over here we
have in coin enum and this enum holds
variance of different denominations of
U.S currency
or U.S coins
and here we have a function value in
sense
this takes as an argument a variant of
type coin
then it matches the argument
and as you can see it matches the
variance of this coin enum meaning if we
provide an instance of this coin enum
which holds a penny variant for example
then it will return one right and this
will then be the return value of this
function so for each denomination over
here it will return its proper value
then let's see if let so I've said that
in a match statement all possible cases
have to be handled and this could
sometimes lead to annoying boiler play
code that is not really that necessary
so for example we have over here an
option type right a value wrapped inside
sum and then we match
this variable over here that holds this
option type and then we are matching as
you can see if it is sum then we the
structure
the value inside this Max variable and
then we just print it out
now as you can see we also have to match
any other case meaning if it is not some
in that case none then nothing will get
executed meaning it will return a unit
type
now this is sometimes two verbose
especially for cases like this for
example you just want to unwrap
something from a sum variant
now what we can do instead is just using
using E flat
so it's exactly the same as this match
statement but we know that config Max
holds a sum value right so we don't have
to
so we don't have to consider the case
where it holds a non-value
and as you can see this is how we would
destructure this value into the variable
Max we will see a flat keyword and then
the pattern so if config Max holds a sum
then the value will get
the structured
let's do exercises
fill the blanks so over here we have a
direction enum holding
directions over here as variance
then over here as you can see we are
instantiating
the direction enum with a variant of the
South
so the type over here would be Direction
[Applause]
then we match this variable here
and if this variable over here holds
Direction East then it will print out
east
now we want over here to match south or
north
so what we can do over here is pattern
matching either south or north and we
can do it like that
[Applause]
so we are here matching
so we are here basically saying if this
variable holds either a variant of south
or north then it will print out south or
north
now
in case it's not any of these variants
then it must be West right so we can
print out here West
let's see
and as you can see
the variable holds South so this will
get matched so this will get printed out
match is an expression so we can use it
in assignments
over here we have a Boolean value
[Applause]
fill the blank with a match expression
Boolean true binary one Boolean false
binary zero
so what we want to do is we want to
match this variable over here
and then we provided the cases so if it
is true
then we should return one
otherwise we return zero so that means
the return value over here will then be
assigned to this binary variable let's
store that as u8
and that means binary should then hold
one right because we are matching here
true
and then the return value should be 1.
using match to get the data and enum
variant holds
again we have the message enum we have
seen that before
then over here we have an array of
message variants
over here we are iterating over this
array and passing it
to this function
as you can see
the argument should be of type message
so we are then matching this provided
argument
so we want to match over here message
move
[Applause]
now as you can see the message move has
struck like syntax so we have to match
it like that
and
and as you can see we want the variables
A and B so let's do that
as you can see it holds Fields X and Y
and that means we will then destructure
these values into the variables into the
variables A and B so a should hold 1 and
B should hold three
then we match over here the message
change color variant as you can see this
is a tuple-like
variant
and this Tuple has three elements so we
can
provide it some variables and we use
here RGB red green blue and this is for
color representation
so in that case
G the second value should be 255.
and the last value B should be
in this case 0.
and again because we have to match all
the cases
if
there is anything else that doesn't
match here we will print out no data in
this parents
like that
matches matches looks like match but can
do something different
so the macro matches allows us to
test for example this array if a pattern
matches
so as you can see we are iterating over
the elements of this array
so over here we have the assert macro
and all this does is it asserts that the
given
argument evaluates to true
so we can over here use team matches
macro
and we provide it a b meaning the
character we are iterating over
and then we can
give it a pattern it should match
so as we are iterating over each element
over here it should match each of these
characters
and we can do that like this
so we want to match characters from a
to and including z
or
a to and including that lowercase
or zero
two nine
and notice these are characters and not
integers because we have here an array
of characters
let's see
and this succeeds as you can see all we
did is we iterated over each element and
we checked
over here for each element if it matches
if it matches this pattern
and in this case everything matched
because assert
didn't Panic right because if one of
them would evaluate to false insert will
cause the program to panic
let's see exercise five so over here we
have an enum with two variants full and
Bar
then here we have a count variable
which is initialized with zero
and over here we have a vector now we
didn't cover vectors yet but they are
very similar to arrays but their size
can shrink and grow meaning during a
vector is dynamic in its size
so as you can see we are
having a vector of my enum variance two
of them fool
and one bar
so this is a vector holding types of my
inner
then over here we are iterating over the
elements of this vector
now we want to match my enum Foo
and if conditionals don't allow to match
for patterns so we can't use that here
but we can do something else we can hear
instead using matches
macro
meaning we take e the element in the
vector we are iterating over
and we match it for
this pattern right
so if the element we are currently
iterating over matches my enum full
variant
then
we want to increment count by one
like that
and that means count after this for Loop
iterating over each element should be
two right because
matches matched two times because there
are two my enum full variants in this
vector
if let for some cases when matching
enums match is too heavy we can use if
let instead
so over here as you can see we have an
option
[Applause]
of type i32
we move the whole match block using IF
let instead so as you can see match is
really verbal so we can use E flat
instead
and we do that like this we use the E
flat keyword and then the pattern we
want to match in this case sum
and the variable should be I so the
inner value here will get the structured
into this variable I
and then we are matching on all
and if
this matches then we want to print out
these two lines
as you can see this is much cleaner
and this will get printed out this is a
really long string and seven as you can
see
we here provide I and I just holds the
inner value of this sum variant
fill in a blank we have here a full enum
with a bar variant holding a type of u8
then over here we have an instance of
the bar variant holding a value of one
now over here again we could do the same
thing we can use E flat and
then we match the pattern
so if
the pattern is full bar then we want to
destructure the inner value
to a variable I
[Applause]
and we are matching on a
as you can see this compiles
so we have a full Anum with three
variants and only the last one holds a
value
so over here we instantiate the full
enum with a variant of
cues and a value of 10. I hope I
pronounce it correctly
so remove the codes below using match
instead
so if I run this code
then this would actually work because we
are using IF let here but we can
do it in a match statement so we match
on a right
and then we can provide the pattern
so in case of full bar
then we would
then we will print out this line
in case of Foo Bass
we want to Output this line
and in case of anything else
like that
we print out this line
now I can delete that
[Applause]
and as you can see much cleaner
so in this case match others
shadowing fix the arrows in place again
we have here an option
with an inner value of i32
then we are here using E flat to
destructure the inner value to H
and that means we are actually shadowing
H because as you can see this variable
here has the name H and we are then
destructuring into a variable h
so that means
H has been shadowed
create a new variable with the same name
as previous age
now over here as you can see H would be
sum 30 which is wrong because we are
actually here
destructuring it right
so H doesn't hold some 30 anymore but it
will hold 30 because we are here
destructuring it
the new variable H goes out of scope
here
right so this variable over here
goes out of scope
and image can also Shadow a variable so
we can here essentially doing the
exactly same thing like in the uh like
in the E flat statement over here
foreign
this would be the output from this match
here
alright see in the next topic
so let's see patterns we can use this
sign to match several values and we can
use this one to match an inclusive range
so as you can see we have here a
function match number which takes an
integer as argument
then we are matching this integer and if
it is one then we will then we'll print
out one
and fill in a blank with this don't use
ranges okay so we have to match here two
to five
so we can do it like that
and this pattern is basically saying if
n is either 2 or 3 or 4 or 5 then we
will print this
match an inclusive range so if the
so if n is between 6 and 10 where 10 is
included then it will print out that
and for any other case because again
because again in a match statement we
have to match every case so in this case
we will print out that
the add operator lets us create a
variable that holds a value at the same
time we are testing that value to see
whether it matches a pattern
so let's see we have here the point
struct that has two Fields with I 32
types
fill in the blank to let P match the
second arm so we have to complete here
something we have here an instance of
the point type
now let's see the match here so we match
on P
and as you can see this is how we would
match a struct so we provide this track
name and then the fields as you can see
we are matching X and Y so
so if Y is equal to 0 that means this
arm here matches and this will get
printed out
and we then can use x over because this
is actually a destructuring assignment
so this would be the same as writing it
like that
but this is shorthand syntax so we are
then using X here
now in the second arm as you can see we
are matching X and Y Fields so X should
be between 0 and 5 5 included
and Y should be either 10 20 or 30.
now as you can see when we are matching
here this pattern we can't use x we
don't use x here but we can in fact use
y because we are using here the add
operator so this means we are
destructuring the variable y
of the field y so that means the value
that Y is holding over here will gets
we'll get this structured into the Y
variable
and at the same time we are testing why
if it is matching this pattern
and the last arm as you can see we don't
match for any pattern
other than this main pattern and then we
can use X and Y because again this would
be the same as writing it like that
all right
now we want to match the second arm that
means we have to provide values that
match these patterns so let's see
X between 0 and 5 so let's do three
[Applause]
and Y 10 20 or 30 I will do 30.
as you can see this second arm matched
fix the arrows over here we have the
message enum that's holding which is
holding one variant with a struct like
syntax as you can see this is one field
ID of type i32 then over here we are
instantiating this variant so this will
be an instance of the message enum
and then over here we are matching this
instance so if it is hello
then we match the ID field so is it
between 3 and 7 then
we want to output here the ID now the
problem here is that we did not actually
destructure this field here into its
distinct
variable right so we have to provide
here each variable let's do ID because
that's the one defined here and for that
we have to use the add operator so we
are destructuring and matching the
pattern at the same time
and over here
this is already done as you can see we
can also provide any a variable with
another name as you can see so the value
of the ID field then we'll get this
structured into this
new ID variable
right it doesn't have to be the same
variable name as the field we have
[Applause]
and again we are destructuring and at
the same time
pattern matching and that's
and that is the reason we are using the
add operator
and as you can see when we are matching
like that then this ID over here got
this structured because this is
the shorthand for this all right
and
when we have a pattern here we have to
wrap it inside parentheses
that's also important
and as you can see in this case the
first arm matched right because ID over
here the value is between 3 and 7.
in match card is an additional if
condition specified after the pattern in
a match arm that must also match along
with the pattern matching for that arm
to be chosen
fill in the blank to make the code work
split must be used
alright as you can see we have here an
option
[Applause]
with an i32 value
then we have here split
and we are here matching
the num variable and we are doing that
to basically restructure the inner value
so we are putting the value of 4 into X
right so we can then use x over here
but we over here also want a match card
to check if x
in this case this value over here is
less than split
we can do that like this
foreign
so this basically is just for
destructuring the this value into X and
over here we have an additional
conditional in match card to check for a
more specific condition to be true
so
if num is a sum so if num is of some
variant then we the structure X and
check it again and if all of that
matches then we
execute this
if it is a sum but yeah but the value
over here is actually bigger than split
then this will get executed and if num
holds a none then we just return a unit
type
ignoring remaining parts of the value
with with this
so as you can see we have here a tuple I
want annotate that so we are matching on
numbers
now we only care about the first as you
can see and the last one
so what we can do over here we are
matching on a tuple right so this is a
tuple and we want to destructure the
first and the last values into the
variables first and last we can do it
like that
right so we have the first
then anything in between and then the
last
so first should all two and last should
hold 2048.
using pattern mutable reference to V to
match a mutable reference needs you to
be very careful due to B being a value
after matching
let's see fix the arrow with least
changing don't remove any code lines so
over here we have a mutable variable
holding a string
and this would be a variable that holds
a mutable reference to a string
now we match r
and that means over here we can
destructure it directly into a value
like that so
this string over here will then be
destructured into the value directly we
don't have to match
mute the reference like that right
and that means the value variable
will hold immutable reference to a
string
and of course then we can modify
this stream over here
all right that's it see you in the next
one
a method is a function that is
associated with a particular type or
struct it takes parameters and returns a
value like a function but it's defined
as a member of a struct or an enum
it's called using dot notation like
accessing members of a struct and it's
implemented through an implementation
block
let's see an example over here we have
the struct rectangle with two fields
and as you can see we can then Implement
methods for this rectangle type using
the input keyword and the name of the
type we want to implement the methods
for
so then over here we can see that
rectangle has a method called area it
takes as an argument a reference to self
and self stands for the name of the
instance so
inside the method we are multiplying
self dot with this field by self dot
height this field and then we return the
result of this operation now again self
over here will be replaced by the name
of the instance
so when we create an instance of
rectangle with concrete values then as
you can see we can call this method on
the created instance right one
meaning when this method is called like
that then self over here will be
replaced by rect one so here rect1 dot
width times rect1 dot height meaning 30
by 50 will be returned
now let's see Associated functions an
Associated function is a function that
is associated with a struct or an enum
but doesn't take an instance as its
first parameter so you can recognize an
Associated function if it doesn't take
self as its first parameter
it's called using the name of the type
not an instance of it
and it's often used as Constructors for
a struct or an enum
so let's see an Associated function as
you can see we have again the rectangle
type and we Implement over here again in
an implementation block
the new Associated function for the
rectangle type
and notice we don't have a self here and
you will see in a minute why that is now
the new Associated function takes two
arguments with and height both of type
u32 and it will then create an instance
rectangle and returns it
meaning when we want to call this
Associated function we don't call it on
an instance right because we don't have
self here we call it directly on the
type
so in this case we take rectangle double
colon and then the function new and we
provide it two values 5 and 10 right
that means Rec 1 will then hold an
instance of the type rectangle
okay let's do the exercises we will skip
this example because I've showed you
that
before
and we will do the exercises directly
methods are similar to functions declare
with FN have parameters and a return
value unlike functions methods are
defined within the context of a struct
or an enum or a trade object and the
first parameter is always self which
represents the instance of destruct the
method is being called upon so as you
can see we have the rectangle struct
again and over here we have the
implementation block we can implement
the methods for this type
now as you can see we instantiate
rectangle over here with concrete values
and then assign it to right one select
one holds an instance of type rectangle
then over here we call this
then over here we call the method area
on rect one and we should get back
1500 so let's implement the area method
so
the first thing is we always start with
cell so every method takes as first
argument self okay
then the return type will be
Au 32 right because we are here doing
operation with these two fields
now what we want to do to get the area
of the rectangle is multiplying the
width by the height
so we use self.width
times self dot height
and I omit here the semicolon so this
will get returned
let's see
so when we so when we call the area
method on the rect one instance then
rect one dot width times rect1 dot
height
will result will result in
1500 meaning 30 times 50.
self will take the ownership of current
struct instance however reference to
self will only borrow a reference from
the instance
Let's see we have again destruct traffic
light with one field now over here there
is the implementation block we can
Implement methods for destruct
Now using self to fill in the blank so
we have been using self like this
right meaning we take a reference to the
instance
now this is actually syntactic sugar for
this
and as you can see itself with an
uppercase s refers to the type we are
implementing the method on right so in
this implementation block when we use
self uppercase it refers to traffic
light
and you can use this syntax or you can
use like we did before
using just self right
and here we want to take immutable
reference because we are here mutating
the
color field
and again
and this
and this and that are exactly the same
but this is not mutable so
if I would do it like that
then as you can see these are actually
exactly the same thing but I would
suggest just stick with that it's more
readable and it's clear what you mean
Associated functions all functions
Define within an input block are called
Associated functions because they are
associated with the type named after the
impul
we can Define Associated functions that
don't have self as their first parameter
and thus are not methods because they
don't need an instance of the type to
work with
so as you can see we again use the
traffic like struct
and here we have the imple block
so let's see first Implement an
Associated function new it will return a
traffic light contains color red must
use self don't use traffic light in FN
signatures or body
let's first see in main what's going on
so we call here the new Associated
function
and disassociated function is associated
with the traffic light type
and again notice the difference is we
call this directly on the type and not
on an instance otherwise it would be a
method
so we call new and then we want to have
an instance of traffic light back
write this new function should return an
instance of traffic light meaning we can
then call upon this instance light the
get State method and return Red
so let's see
over here we are expecting no argument
right
so let's leave it like that and remember
Associated functions don't take self
now the return type would be traffic
light instance
and because we should use self in here
we can do that and again self in an
implementation block refers to the type
in this case traffic light
then in there we want to create an
instance of traffic light so again we
can use self instead of this name
and then we like normally instantiating
it providing it concrete values
so in this case we want this self.color
field to hold a string of red
like that
and as you can see then we should get
and as you can see when we call this
Associated function we'll get back an
instance with this concrete value a
string red then we call upon this
instance light the get State method so
again self here refers to light because
we are calling the method on this
instance
and it takes just a reference to the
instance meaning light is usable even
after this method call and all it does
it will return the value inside the
color field of the instance in this case
slide
so light dot color will hold a string of
red
multiple input blocks each struct is
allowed to have multiple input blocks
again rectangle struct and using
multiple input blocks to rewrite the
code below so
we can either put all of the functions
and methods in the same input block or
we can even reorganize it using various
different input blocks
so we can for example put that
in its own implementation block like
that
and it will work exactly the same this
is just for organizing and restructuring
enums we can also Implement methods for
enums so over here we have the enum
traffic light color with three variants
Implement traffic light color with a
method
so over here in main we are
instantiating traffic light color with a
variant of yellow
this would be the type annotation and
then when we call a method color on the
C instance it should return yellow
so let's see
so we could Implement that using a match
statement
then we match a self and if match self
would be this
then we return the string yellow
okay
[Applause]
and we can over here instead of writing
the whole name of the type we can again
use uppercase self referring to the type
this method is implemented on in this
case traffic light color
and remember in a match statement we
have to handle all the possible cases
meaning we have to create an arm for
right and for green two so let's do that
let's see
and as you can see because we have here
an instance which holds the variant
yellow we will get back yellow when we
call the color method
all right that's it until next time
until now we have only been dealing with
concrete types but we can also deal with
generics and generics are placeholders
for concrete types it enables writing
more reusable and flexible code and it
avoids having duplicate code for
different types it's a zero cost
abstraction meaning the rust compiler
will add compile time fill out the
generics with concrete types
and there is also a concept called const
generics I will just briefly touch upon
it because this is more of an advanced
topic but I will show you one exercise
just so you get the idea from it
so const generic is a type parameter
that represents a compile time constant
value it allows to write generic code
that operates on values that are known
at compiled time and it's mainly used
for array sizes bitwits and other
constants and you will see what I mean
when you see the exercise
let's start with generics
so as you can see over here we have a
struct a now this would be considered a
concrete type
because we don't deal with generic types
in here
now destruct s takes as an argument an
instance of destruct a this is also
considered a concrete type because again
there are not
generics used here
now destruct s-gen is considered a
generic type because we are dealing here
with a generic type parameter and this
would be denotation when you declare
a type for example then after the name
of the type you annotate
a generic type parameter like that using
these symbols over here and then
providing a name and by convention this
is usually T standing for type and that
means this struct can hold any type
now as you can see we have here some
functions this function over here takes
s which is a concrete type the Gen spec
takes as an argument an instance of s
gen with a type of a
now again a would be a concrete type
meaning the type parameter over here
is specified to be a concrete type so we
can only pass to this S10 struct
an instance of destruct a
then over here we have the genspec i32
function which takes as an argument the
S-10
struct over here with a value that is of
type i32
and over here we have a generic function
meaning we are declaring after the
function name the the generic type
parameter T and then we can use it on
here meaning that we can provide
as an argument over here an instance of
S-10 with any type
so let's see using the non-generic
functions so these over here are all
non-generic as you can see because we
didn't Define a generic type parameter
and all the values it is using are
concrete right over here we have S over
here we have S10 and this is taking as a
value T over here the concrete Type A
and over here it takes as concrete type
i32 so all these are non-generic
functions the only generic function over
here would be this one
so let's see
so we want to call Direct F and function
and as you can see in the function
signature we are taking as an argument
a type of s
so let's provide that
now we have to pass into s
the concrete type a right because that
is defined
in this
struct
then gen spec t
so this function over here takes
an S10 struct with a type of a now again
a would be a concrete type
so we provide here S10
and a right
so we are passing to the S gen
struct over here
a value of type A
and in this case we want it to be S10
and let's say 7 because over here we
Define that this function should take as
an argument a type S10 which holds an
i32 integer
then explicitly specify type parameter
chart to generic
so over here we are calling the generic
function meaning we can pass to it and
S10 type holding any possible type now
we can explicitly specify a type
parameter for this T over here and we
are here saying T should be a char
meaning we are calling the generic
function over here with the type S gen
and passing as a value a type of char
let's say a
and implicitly specify type parameter
chart to generic so we don't have to
annotate the type here it will be
automatically inferred by the compiler
so if I do the same thing over here
let's go with Z this time
as you can see this is compiling now
again because sgen is defined to be
generic over its type
pass any value so let's pass for example
a floating point
as you can see this is also compiling
because
T over here is a placeholder that stands
for any type possible
but again when we annotate the specific
type then we can only pass a character
in this example so if I try 7.7 here
this would be in compiler error
if I Define f64 as you can see then it's
working
all right a function call with
explicitly specified type parameter
looks like that
and this is also called the turbo fish
syntax
so let's see implement the generic
function below
so as you can see we are calling here
the sum function with different types
and that's the whole point of generics
so here we are calling sum with two I8
integers over here we call this sum
function with 2i32 integers remember if
nothing is annotated then the default
integer type is i32 and here the same
thing but for floating Point f 64.
so we have to use here generics
otherwise this won't be possible over
here we are creating our generic type
parameter and again by convention this
is called t
then we take here the arguments
so let's say a should be of type T and B
should also be of type T and then we
return a type of t
meaning if we pass here to i8
integers then T will get converted to an
I8 right this is just a placeholder and
because we operate then on two i8s the
type the return type will also be I8 so
what we do is just adding together the
two arguments and return it
and over here we have to implement a
trade bound and we'll cover that in the
next section so we have to Define here
that t should implement the add trait
otherwise we can't use this plus sign
over here
and again we will cover that in the next
section when we look at trades
and as you can see this is compiling so
we can pass to sum
two numbers
of any type
let's see number three Implement struct
point to make it work as you can see we
are instantiating two point structs but
over here we are passing to the fields
different types so in the first instance
we would have i32 values
in the second instance we are dealing
with floats
so to make that possible we have to use
generic so let's implement the point
struct
and we are defining here the generic
type parameter
and then we can Define the fields
and as you can see the fields hold the
type
t
meaning if we pass it intervals then X
and Y Must both be integers if we are
passing it floats then both of these
fields must be of type floats
now because we are here defining a
generic type parameter this parameter
over here becomes part of the type
annotation so over here we are providing
to the fields of the point struct values
of type i32 so we must annotate that
and over here we are passing f64
and as you can see this is compiling now
again we don't have to do the type
annotations actually I just want to make
that clear as you can see the compiler
is able to infer that for us
modify the struct to make the code work
don't modify this code so as you can see
we are here instantiating a point but
the fields over here hold different
types so this is not working
because
T over here defines that both of these
placeholders will be filled with the
same concrete type
so in this case if we are passing X
over here with an i32 type then the
compiler thinks that y should also hold
an i32 now what we can do then is
defining another generic type parameter
and by convention you just go one letter
further so T and U meaning we can then
use here U right and this
indicates that the fields over here hold
different types or could potentially
hold different types they can also hold
the same types
and then when we annotate that
we have said that the generic type
parameter becomes part of the type
annotation so we would pass here for x
so we would pass here for T and i32
the value
the type the X field is holding and over
here a string
so this would be the type annotation for
this returned instance
number five at generic for well to make
the code work don't modify the code in
Main
so here we have the valve struct holding
one field and we have an implementation
block implementing one method for the
well type now how do I know it's a
method because it has as first parameter
this self keyword
and all this Value method does is just
returning a reference to the Bell field
value all right so when we instantiate
the Bell
struct over here we are providing a type
of f64.
but over here we are instantiating the
valve field with a string so again we
have different types so let's annotate
here the generic type parameter
then we can use T here meaning the Field
Val can hold any type
so let's annotate here
now over here as you can see
we are returning the value of the Val
field and we Define here that it should
be of type f64. now this would cause an
error because when we call over here
the Value method on the instance of Y
then self.wall would hold a string right
so it doesn't return an f64. now we have
to use a generic type parameter also in
this implementation block and we can do
that like that
so we have over here
the generic type parameter for our type
and as we've said this becomes part of
the type annotation
and over here we are also defining a
generic type parameter T so we are then
able to use it inside the implementation
block so over here we can Define that it
should be a reference to T right a
reference to any type that the wall
field holds
so in the first call of value it would
be an F 64 right
that is the type of The Returned value
that Val field is holding
and in the second call over here it
would be a string right so T then would
be string
number six we have here a point struct
and we are here defining that the fields
could potentially hold different types
but they could also be the same
and here we have the implementation
block for our point struct
now as you can see over here we are
instantiating a point with I 32 values
right so they can be the same even if we
here have two generic type parameters it
doesn't matter they can be the same but
over here we are instantiating point
with two different types right
we are instantiating point with a string
literal this here and HR that over here
so they are different in its types
then we call over here the mix up method
on P1
and provided an argument of P2
and then over here as you can see we
want then P3
to look something like that
so we want the newly created instance
here P3 to hold the value of the first
instance in this case P1
as you can see we are taking X from P1
and we want the Y field to hold the
value of the P2 instance of the P2
instance this character
right so how would we do that with
generic type parameters
now let's first Implement here the mix
up function
and again the convention is just the
more generic type parameters you are
declaring you just go further in the
alphabet so T U V W all right
and as you can see as a first argument
we are taking P1 now let's take
ownership we don't care because we don't
use P1 after this point meaning we can
take ownership and we don't have to use
a reference to self here
and
as an argument here we want P2 meaning a
point
with generic type parameters we are
declaring here
and the return type will be a point
with
a generic type parameter t
and a generic type parameter of w and
you will see why that is
so then what we want to do is creating
here a new instance
and we provide here x which should be of
self because self here refers to P1
right so we want self and we want the x
value
and Y should take it from the second
argument the P1 over here and we want
the Y field
so let me actually annotate that as
order
[Applause]
right we take here another
Point instance and this would refer to
P2 because we are passing P2 over here
to this mix up method so we take from P
to d y field
and then we are returning this instance
meaning P3 will then look something like
that right
so let me annotate the type
we would have a point with the x value
of P1 and i32
and a character type of P2 the Y field
right and that is what we will get
let's first see if this even compiles
and this is compiling
now
as you can see we have here a lot of
generic type parameters so
when we take a look at the mix-up method
as you can see we are here declaring new
generic type parameters because we want
to Define over here that the types self
and self again refers to the instance
over here P1 that these types are
different from the types provided on the
second argument the instance of P2 right
if we compare it together then P1
instance holds different types than the
P2 instant so we need new generic type
parameters
because t and u
are for this P1 instance and the other
the argument we are here providing P2
will hold different types right
and as you can see we are then taking
from P1 the X field and from P2 we take
the Y field
and this would be the return type a
point
with t this is from P1 X and W this
would be the second type from DP to
point
all right
fix the errors to make the code work as
you can see we have here is tracked
point which has two fields which are
generic over its type
and we Implement over here
a method for the point struct over here
now this method over here is in fact
only implemented for a struct point that
holds F 32 types of fields right so if
we would pass floats then this method is
not implemented for a point
so this is only implemented for point
with a concrete type of F32
now
then over here we are calling on the
fields X
the power integer method
and let's see that in the rust
documentation
so as you can see
the power integer
method over here is actually implemented
for f 64 types right so self in this
case must be of type f 64.
as you can see over here we have X which
holds an F 64 type so we can we can call
this method on X right again this is a
method and not a function
so the problem over here is that self in
this case would be F32 which is not the
right type so let's change that f64
and that means self over here would be
of type f64 the concrete type we are
providing here
and then of course the return type would
be f64 right because we are here
performing an operation on two f64 types
now
over here of course we have to provide
floating Point values right because
again this method is only implemented
for a point that holds as Fields F 64
types
like that
all right and then we can use this
method as defined in the standard
Library
and of course over here
we just have to annotate one type right
because we only have one generic type
parameter
and as you can see this is compiling and
I will see you next time
so I've told you that we will take a
brief look at const generics and I will
just solve one exercise and leave it at
that because constant generics is a more
advanced topic and you don't need it
that much in your everyday programming
so they're useful at some situations but
they are not that much used
so let's see an example over here we
have here a struct array
so we have here destruct array which
defines two generic type parameters t
and n
now T is a generic type parameter and
n over here is a const generic type
parameter
and as you can see each array struct
holds a data field with an array
of type t and n elements
all right
so when we look over here we have an
array and I will now annotate this type
of type array
right this struct
distract we have defined over here we
are holding three instances as you can
see one two three three instances of
this array struct right
like that
now I've told you that when
we have generic type parameters it
becomes part of its annotations we have
to annotate it over here too
in fact we don't have to do that because
it's usually inferred by the compiler
but I will do it right now so
this over here cares about the types in
the aerated data field holds so as you
can see we have here integers we have
here
floats and over here we again have
integers
and what that means is that in this
array over here these actually should
all hold the same type because we have
to provide here a concrete type right
for T and that means
this data field over here will then hold
in its array this type so in this case
we will do i32
and we need to provide it a constant
meaning for the length of the array in
this case we Define three all right
and what that means is that the arrays
inside the data field of these instances
must be of i32 type and they must have a
length of 3. right so we can't use
floats here we have to use i32
and over here we need to add another
element
now they can't be different for example
let's do it like that
that is possible
but all of them over here must have the
same type and the same amount of
elements because we are annotating that
here
so it complies with the generic type
parameter annotations here
now let's create another array
with floats
now I want this to hold array instances
of type f64
and let's do two elements
and I will pass here
let's say also three
and that means
inside here
let's first look at the outside array at
this array over here so we want three
elements of
type array this array struct right
so let's define that
like that as you can see we have here
three
elements of type array now we Define
here for the generic type parameters
that
the data field
the data field should hold an array
right because this is defined over here
in the array struct
so each data field should hold an array
of f64 right the T over here
of two elements right
this is the const generic parameter so
we are passing here a constant and not a
type
so in this case
we the data field would have concrete
types of f64 and two elements right so
let's fill that out
like that
as you can see this is compiling because
we are here complying with the generic
type parameters
we have three
array instances
right and each array instance holds a
data field with these types
f64 and they have to be two elements
inside the array
all right see in the next topic
we will now cover trades so a trade is a
set of methods that can be implemented
for multiple types in order to provide
common functionality and behavior
between them a trade consists only of
method signatures which then have to be
implemented by the Target type it's
similar to classes in other languages
but not quite the same and it defines
shared behavior in an abstract way so
let's see how that might look like
as you can see over here we have two
custom types sheep and Cal now we want
to indicate that these are somewhat
related so over here we have created a
trade anime which defines one method
then over here we are implementing the
animal trade for sheep and for cow now
when we Implement a trade for some type
then we have to implement all the
methods the trade
defines so in this case as you can see
in the trade animal we only provide it
with a function signature and then the
concrete types for example sheep and cow
will implement the method and Its
Behavior
so as you can see both sheep and cow
then implement the animal trait meaning
they automatically implement the method
right
so both of them
take a reference to its instance for
example an a ship instance and then just
return the string over here
and the same thing for cow
now there is also derivable traits and
we have seen that before a trait can be
automatically implemented for a struct
or an enum by the rust compiler these
are called derivable because they can
beat derived automatically
and the most common derivable traits are
debug allowing to Output content via
this debug notation we have seen that
clone which enables a type to be
duplicated with the Clone method
copy enables a type to be copied
implicitly without requiring explicit
clone method and partially queue enables
comparison
now we can pass trades as parameters so
the notify function over here takes as
an argument any type that implements the
summary trade
meaning we can ensure that the item
argument over here implements this
summarize method right if we provide
here A type that didn't implement this
summary trait then it wouldn't have this
summarize method
trades can be used as parameters for
functions the function notify takes as
an argument any type that has
implemented the summary trait
now there is also a concept called trade
bounce
meaning if we declare over here a
generic type parameter we can define
that
the type over here must implement the
summary trade so the argument we pass to
this notify function must implement this
summary trait
and this is similar to the example using
the impulse summary but more verbose
so as you can see this would actually be
exactly the same like we did over here
trade bounds are declared like generics
after the name of the function and use
trade bounds if you have lots of
parameters to avoid this so if we would
have here an argument which takes a
typed Implement summary and another
argument which
again takes a type that implements
summary we can do it like that so we
Define here a trade bound meaning the
generic type T must implement this
summary trait so both argument 1 and
argument 2 take a reference to a type
that implements the summary trait
and if you have big trade bounds like
for example this we have here generic
type parameter T and we say here that
the type T has to implement the display
and decline trades
and the generic Type U has to implement
the Clone anti-debug trait right and
then over here as you can see the first
argument must be of type T and the
second one of Type U and we are taking
references
so we can write that in a more concise
way using a verb Clause meaning after
the return type in a function we can use
the verb keyword and then over here
Define our trade bounds and this over
here is exactly the same as this but
instead of
defining the trade bounds directly on
the generic type parameter we do it in a
separate block
foreign and we can also
return from a function a type that
implements a specific trait so as you
can see the return dog function over
here returns an instance of the dog
struct
and because the animal trade over here
has been implemented for torque we can
also Define the return type as follows
we return here an instance of talk
meaning we return here
a type that implements the animal trade
because as you can see animal is
implemented for the dog struct
let's see exercise one feeling the two
input blocks to make the chord work
don't modify the code in main now we
have here a trade hello
finding two methods now over here you
can see that we didn't only provide the
function signature but we implemented
basically the whole method why is that
because this is considered the default
implementation meaning any type that
implements the hello trade automatically
gets this default implementation of this
method so we don't have then to
implement it manually it will
automatically get implemented for the
type that implements the hello trade
but as you can see over here we have a
method which is here just a function
signature so we have to implement that
manually
then over here we have two structs
student and teacher and we Implement
over here the hello trade for student
and for teacher
so let's see we have here an instance of
student
and as you can see this is just a struct
that doesn't hold any values right so we
instantiate it like that
but because
we have here implemented hello for the
student struct that means we can then
call upon it
this method over here as you can see we
call this say hi method on the S
instance and then it should return high
now we don't have to implement this say
hi method over here again like that
we don't have to do that because it's
already implemented by default right
but what we have to implement is to say
something method because as you can see
we are calling the say something method
on the instance of s and remember when
we Implement a trade for a type in this
case student we have to implement all
the methods
except the default implementation here
so let's actually
take this and copy it over
because the function signature must be
exactly the same like defined in the
trade
and then over here we want the return to
be I'm a good student
so let's return this string here
like that
so when we call
on an instance of student this say
something method then it will return I'm
a good student
now over here we are instantiating the
teacher struct
and as you can see we are calling the
method on the T instance and this should
be the returned string so as you can see
this is different from what is
implemented in the default
implementation and that means we have to
re-implement this say hi method for the
teacher type
and the return string should be hi I'm
your new teacher
so as you can see if a trade defines a
default implementation we can also
overwrite
the default implementation and provide
another return value
and of course because we have to
implement
this over here I will copy that
and I will implement it for the teacher
type
so as you can see when we call
the say something method on an instance
of teacher then we should get back this
string
so as you can see we have then
implemented the hello trade for our
custom types student and teacher let's
see if that compiles
and this is compiling
derived the compiler is capable of
providing basic implementations for some
trades via ddrive attribute for more
info please visit here
let's see over here we have a tuple
struct centimeters which holds a value
of type f64 now as you can see this
truck here derives to trades partially q
and partial order meaning the compiler
will automatically Implement these
trades for our type centimeters
now partially Q is for comparing
equality and partial order is for
ordering
so over here we have inches and and
inches is a tuple struct that holds an
i32 type
and it derives the debug trade meaning
we can print it out using the debug
notation
and as you can see over here we
Implement a method two centimeters for
an instance of the inches type
so when we call
this
method on an instance of inches then we
will convert it to centimeters right so
we hear the reference self meaning the
instance
of inches and then we destructure over
here
the inches basically the value
that the Tuple struct inches holes so
this variable then will hold the value
of
the instance provided here okay and then
as you can see we are multiplying inches
by 2.54 to convert it to centimeters and
we are wrapping that
and we are returning that as an instance
of centimeters as you can see
add some attributes to make the code
work don't modify other code
so as you can see over here we are
instantiating this seconds struct
[Applause]
so then we are printing it out using
debug notation so we have to derive over
here the debug trade
then we are here comparing for equality
so we have to
derive The partially Q trait
and over here we are checking if one
second is bigger than one second meaning
we need to implement the partial order
trade
like that
and as you can see we are here
instantiating the inches struct
providing it a value of 12 right this
i32 type
and then we print it out
and let's check debug is implemented so
we can print it using debug notation and
over here we are instantiating the
centimeter struct
[Applause]
as you can see centimeters takes a value
of f64.
and over here we are comparing
as you can see over here this foot
instance
holding an instance of inches with 12.
so in the U.S 12 inches equal one foot
and then we call the two centimeters
method on it mean meaning this will then
return an instance of centimeters right
so we are taking here inches 12.
and that means
12 over here will get destructured right
here we have
here self would be inches 12 and we take
it as an reference like that so
we destructure it like that using the
let keyword the reference because we
want to take the value and not a
reference and then 12 will be put inside
the inches variable
then we are multiplying by
2.54 and returning an instance of
centimeters and that means
we can then compare this over here
with the meter because the meter holds
also the same type namely the custom
type centimeters over here
right
so both
types would be here of type centimeters
and if this is smaller than this then it
will
assigned to this variable
a string smaller otherwise bigger and
these are string literals by the way
and over here we are outputting
the result of this compare
let's see
and as you can see this is compiling
so we are outputting here one second
looks like seconds one as you can see we
can
output this
type over here seconds because we have
derived the debug trade meaning we can
use debug notation
then one foot equals inches 12.
and over here this one foot is smaller
than one meter
operator in Rust many of The Operators
can be overloaded via trades that is
some operators can be used to accomplish
different tasks based on their input
arguments this is possible because
operators are syntactic sugar for method
called example the plus operator in a
plus b calls the add method as in a at B
over here this would be a method this
add method is part of the add trade
hence the plus operator can be used by
any implementer of the add trade
so Implement implement the function
multiply to make the code work as
mentioned above plus needs T to
implement standard Ops add trait
that's why we are here importing the Ops
module from standard Library
so let's implement the multiply function
as you can see over here we are
providing two u8 integers to the
multiply function now in the second call
over here we are providing flow means we
need a generic type parameter like that
so this function takes two arguments
and it will return T basically the same
type of the provided arguments
and then over here we basically just
want to multiply a by B now as you can
see over here we are using the operator
for multiplications
and that means we have to ensure that
the T over here
the type of the arguments that the
multiply function takes
implements the Mal trait
now the mall trade like the add trades
over here
then knows that if both of the types of
A and B Implement The Malt rate it is
possible to multiply these two together
so we can use here a trade bound meaning
the type T over here should implement
should implement the standard of malt
rate
because again this is just overloading
and syntactic sugar for this call
right
so this actually would translate to this
and we are seen in the add over here
that it would be a at B right
these operators are just overloaded so
it's easier to use
and that's why we have to ensure that a
this argument here of type T has
actually implemented the Mal method
and we make sure that this is the case
when providing here a trade bound
meaning T must Implement The Malt rate
meaning then that t has implemented the
Mal method let's see
and we have here to also
find that the output will be of type t
because as you can see the mult rate
over here
has an Associated type of output so we
have to Define and we will take a look
at Associated types
but we have here to Define that the
output should of type t
that the output should be of type T
right
let's see again
and this is working
fix the arrows don't modify the code in
main so over here again we are using the
Ops module from the standard Library
then we have here two structs full and
power and full bar and Powerful
the standard Ops add trade is used to
specify the functionality of the plus
operator here we make add bar to trace
for addition with a right hand side of
type bar the following block implements
the operation full plus bar should
return powerful so if we
USD plus operator with these two types
over here we should return this type
right full plus bar should return full
bar
now let's see the add
tray
now the add trade over here takes as
default parameter
rhs standing for right hand side
if we don't provide anything to right
hand side then it will be self meaning
the type we implement the add trade on
and as you can see we have an Associated
type here for the output
and over here as you can see it takes
self and basically becomes the owner
when called on an instance that
implements the add trade
and right hand side is off type right
hand side which means by default it
would be self
and this looks confusing I know but you
will get it when we Implement that over
here
so as you can see we are implementing
from the Ops module the add trade so we
can Implement from this standard Library
trades for our custom types
and
let's see
again
when doing something like that
[Applause]
then
then the compiler will actually do
something like that
right it will call the add method now
this over here is the type here would be
an instance of Foo but just so you get
the concept
and as you can see we have here to
define the right hand side meaning the
right hand side over here would be poor
and we are implementing the add trade
for Foo right
because we want the instance to be of
Type 4 so we implement it for Foo
and we want the right hand side to be of
type bar now if we wanted
to add for example
then we could omit that because you are
seeing that the default
itself right so the default right hand
side would be
self as you can see
so we can omit that but
the
bow but that means both types must be
the same in this case Foo and fool right
because self over here refers to the
type we are implement the trade four
right but in this case it would be bar
right because the right hand side is
different from the left hand side
and the output should be of type full
bar so as and again Associated functions
we will cover that very soon
so over here we have to implement the
add method right because the
add trade over here defines an add
method so we have to implement it
and that means we take self and this is
taking ownership of an instance of Foo
right
and right hand side would be of type bar
again
as you can see Foo would be the instance
then we call the add method upon the
instance and this argument should be of
type par and then we return full bar
so in Main
when we call
so in main when we perform this over
here full plus bar we will get back full
bar right
so we have implemented the plus operator
on our custom types
now let's do the same for minus sign but
in this case full minus bar would be
powerful
so let's see as you can see this would
be distract we want to return powerful
so
minus sign
is actually the same but implementing
this sub trade
so we will type full sub
R right this would be the sub method
defined in this sub trade as you can see
we are here implementing
the substrate from the Ops module
for bar
now again we want actually to implement
it for Foo because here
we
call Foo support meaning we would
implement it for the foo instance
because cell 4 here refers to the
instance the method is called upon right
so the sub will be called upon self
meaning we have to implement it for Foo
and the right hand side would be bar
now we want to return bar food that's
true
and
over here as you can see
the sub method is implemented but as
right hand side the type should be bar
right this is the right hand side of the
operation
and we are returning powerful so when we
do this full minus 4 we will get back
powerful so we have overloaded this
operator
and of course to do assert EQ here
because this is a custom type we have to
implement the partial EQ trade so let's
do that
and we also have to implement the debug
trade
as you can see this is compiling meaning
when we use our custom types with these
operators they will return a custom type
and we can do that by implementing from
the Ops module from the standard Library
the appropriate trades
for our custom types
use trade as function parameters
instead of a concrete type for the item
parameter we specify the input keyword
and the trade name this parameter
accepts any type that implements the
specified trade
as you can see we have here a trade
summary
Implement function summary to make the
code work fix the errors without
removing any code line
so over here we have a struct post with
three fields of type string
and we Implement over here this summary
trade for the Post struct meaning we
have to implement the defined method in
the trade
so we implement it for post like this as
you can see we are accessing from the
instance remember this is a method so it
refers to an instance
it is called upon right
so we access the fields self.title and
self dot author all right
then over here we have a struct Weeble
with two fields of type string then we
implement the summary trait for Weeble
and we then have to implement the method
from the trade all right because again
when we Implement a trade for a type we
have to implement its methods
so this over here accesses the username
and contact field and prints it out
now here we have an instant of post
and here we have an instance of weibo
so as you can see we are here calling
this summary function with an argument
of post and weibo so we have to
implement this summary function below
let's do that
now
as an argument
it takes
now as an argument it takes
in the first call Post and in the second
call Weeble right two different types
but now think about it what do they
share in common
write they implement this summary trade
right we have implemented it for post
and for Weeble so we can Define over
here that the argument provided must be
a type that implements the summary trait
and we do it like that
and then inside the function body we
want to take this argument
and again a is an instance of a type
that implements the summary trait so we
are taking a and we call upon it the
summarize method
meaning
the first one it will be post dot
summarize
now post over here is of type post
meaning we go to post and as you can see
this would be the summarize method as
you can see self would refer to the
instance in this case post
this instance over here
so then the summarize method will return
a string
so let's actually
assign this to a variable
[Applause]
this would then hold this string and we
can then output
like that let's see
and of course
when we are calling the summary method
with an instance then we can't use the
instance again so let's define here that
it should take a reference
right
and as you can see this is compiling
now what we can do over here
and this would be exactly the same we
can Define here a generic type parameter
T and here Define that it should
Implement summary right so we Define
here the type t
and it should be a type that must
Implement summary and then we can write
it like that
so a should then be a reference of type
T which implements summary trait let's
see
as you can see exactly the same thing
returning types that Implement rates we
can also use the infiltrate syntax in
the return position to return a value of
some type that implements a trade
however you can only use input trade if
you're returning a single type use trade
objects instead when you really need to
return several types
so over here we have two custom types
sheep and Cal and we have one trade
animal which has one method
so over here we are then implementing
the animal trades for both of these
custom types
and as you can see when we Implement a
trade for a concrete type then we have
to implement the given method
so over here we have a function random
animal it takes a random number and then
and then looks if the random number is
less than 0.5 it will return a sheep
instance otherwise it will return a cow
instance
now over here the return type of the
function would be a type that implements
the animal trade which both of them do
and as you can see in main we have here
our random number
and we call this random number on the
random animal function so let's for now
assume that this really is random okay
so that means that when this is passed
over here it could either be a sheep or
a cow to be returned here
but the problem here is that the return
type in a function must be of known
fixed size at compile time
which in this case sheep might be bigger
than cow or cow might be bigger than
sheep so the exact size is not known at
compile time so when we do that
this doesn't work
and to make that work we have to know
about trade objects so let's see
so trade objects using input traits
doesn't work when returning multiple
types different implementations of a
trade probably with different amounts of
memory but sizes of types must be known
at compiled time in this case a trade
object can be used a trait object is
essentially a pointer to any type that
implements the given trade where the
precise type can only be known at
runtime
so
over here for example we have a trade
animal and two custom types token cat
then we implement the trade animal for
both of these types
and as you can see we have a function
return animal it takes a string and if
this string is dark then it returns a
dog instance now if it returns cat then
it returns a cat instant but as you can
see we are here providing a reference to
the instance and not the incense itself
because when we return a reference to a
type that implements the animal trade it
means that the size of this type is
known at compile time because remember a
reference is a pointer and the size of a
power and the size of a pointer is known
at compile time meaning it's of Type U
size and U size is 8 bytes on a 64-bit
computer
so the size of the return type is known
it's just a pointer sized type
at compile time it's of size U size
right because we are here returning a
pointer meaning it doesn't matter if dog
is bigger than cat or otherwise
it's always the same size because
pointers have a fixed size at compile
time
and that is how we would
solve this problem so again here we have
a function which
so here we have a function which returns
a type that implements the animal trade
this could be dog or cat as the trade
object is behind the pointer the size is
known at compile time which is U size
the size of a pointer this allows for
more flexible code as the exact return
type doesn't have to be known at compile
time as long as the size is fixed
so we don't care anymore about the size
of dog and cat because they're behind a
pointer
and to understand what's going on you
have to know about static and dynamic
dispatch so let's first look at static
dispatch
static dispatch resolves method calls at
compile time the compiler will generate
function code for each concrete type
that implements the trade
it calls the appropriate function based
on concrete types it's faster and more
efficient than Dynamic dispatch but it
doesn't provide great flexibility
so we have here the trade animal
holding one method say hi then we have
Talking Cat and we implement the animal
trade for dog and for cat
now as you can see when we create an
instance from dog and from cat and call
the say hi method on it because as you
can see every
every type that implements the animal
trait must have this method
and when we then run this program then
the compiler will actually generate
methods for each concrete type in this
case stock or cat
because then the say hi method we are
calling here on the dog and cat instance
is known at compile time
so the compiler then knows when we call
the method on the dog or cat instance
which method has to be resolved for
which type
so let's see Dynamic dispatch
in Dynamic dispatch the specific methods
to be called is determined at runtime
and not at compile time like static
dispatch
it works by creating a reference or
smart pointer to a trade object using
reference din or boxed in when trade
object is created the compiler will
build a v-table for that trade a v table
is a table that contains a pointer to
the implementation of each method in the
trades for the specific type of the
object that the reference points to
the compiler will do a lookup in a V
table to determine which method should
be called for which type that implements
the given trade
and this lookup will cause overhead but
allows for more flexible code
so exactly because of this lookup
static dispatch is faster than Dynamic
dispatch but on the other hand Dynamic
dispatch allows for more flexibility
so let's see how that might look like as
you remember with box we are able to
allocate a type to Heap memory meaning
the type will then get allocated for
example a
i32 integer like 7 will get allocated to
the Heap and we will then get back a
pointer this is what box is for and we
have seen examples of that now when we
use box with a trait object it means
that the
type that implements the specific trade
will get allocated in Heap memory get
back a pointer to the location where the
type that implements this specific trait
was allocated and we will get back a v
pointer right this is happening when
dynamically dispatching so the V pointer
points to the V table
and in the v table there are certain
Fields now there is also a field called
Methods and this is where all the
methods for the concrete type over here
are located meaning at runtime the
compiler will check this V table and see
in the methods over here which methods
are implemented for the concrete type
that was allocated in Heap memory
so let's see an example
so we have over here a trade animal and
we have two custom types cat and talk
and we implement this method defined in
the trade for both of our types right
because when we Implement a trade for a
custom type we have to implement all of
its defined methods
so over here we have seen we have a
random animal function which takes a
random number and based on this
conditional it will either output a cad
instance or a dog instance
so then when we call this random animal
function with the random number and for
now just assume that this is really a
random number
that means the compiler first of all
cannot determine the size of the type
which gets returned and this is of type
that implements the animal trade right
cat and dog both implement the trade but
we can't know the exact size at compile
time meaning we put it behind a pointer
in this case a box but a reference would
also be possible and that means the size
is now known right it's the size of a
pointer basically U size 8 bytes in a
64-bit computer
but we have another problem over here
the return value will be
a type that implements the animal trade
but at compile time when we call the
noise method over here the compiler
doesn't know
which
of these types get returned so he so the
compiler can't know which method he has
to call is it for the implementation on
cat or dog right
so this is why we use Dynamic dispatch
because that means this over here will
get decided at run time so again the
compiler will then look up in this B
table over here using the V pointer
which points to the V Table stores in
heaped memory and and then it will check
for the concrete type that got allocated
on Heap memory this specific methods
so for example again this is happening
at runtime
we return a cat then the compiler will
see that the type over here which is
concrete is cat so it will see in the v
table the methods implemented for the
concrete type of cat
I hope this makes sense
so this is why we need Dynamic dispatch
here static dispatch doesn't work
because again the output of this
function is random
so let's see box box is a smart pointer
that allows to store data on the Heap
rather than this stack and you can use
box when you have a type whose size
can't be known at compile time it
returns a pointer to the data stored on
the Heap
so what's the difference between a
reference and a box in terms of memory a
box allocates the data on the Heap and
owns it
is also responsible for deallocating
when the value goes out of scope and the
reference only points to a value that is
already in memory meaning the reference
points to something that is already
there while a box allocates and a and
the reference also doesn't own anything
it just points to something
in terms of lifetimes a box can be
passed across Scopes while the reference
has limited lifetime and we will cover
lifetimes very soon a box can be cloned
and the reference cannot and the Box can
also be used in pattern matching
so
we have left off over here and I hope by
now you know that this over here is not
possible we cannot return a type which
implements the animal trade because
these could vary in size
and again over here we return
a type that implements the animal trade
now if this over here would be really a
random number then we don't know exactly
at compile time which type gets returned
meaning we can't use here the noise
method because the compiler can
impossibly know at compile time of
course which
method he has to call is it this one
or is it this one right
and for that we will use Dynamic
dispatch so again we can put
this in a box
and using here the pin keyword meaning
we want to go with Dynamic dispatch here
and that means we have to box these
instances
so now
the return type over here is known at
compile time meaning we can annotate it
it would be a box
which holds a type that implements the
animal trade
and this is using Dynamic dispatch
meaning we then can call
this noise method on this instance here
because the compiler can check for this
noise method at run time and not at
compile time meaning it is determined
which of these will get called at
runtime when the program is running
let's see
and this is working
trade bound the infiltrate syntax works
for straightforward cases but is
actually syntax sugar for a longer form
which is called a trade bound when
working with generic type parameters
often must use trades as bounds to
stipulate what functionality a type
implements
so over here we are calling the sum
function with two arguments
in this case
2i32 arguments
and as you can see we could also call
this with floats because we have here
defined
t t generic type parameter
so as you notice X and Y Must Be of the
same type T and the type will be T which
gets returned and all we do over here is
adding X Plus y
now again to use this plus operator here
we must Define that t over here is a
type that implements the add trade
because remember this would actually
translate to this
so it's critical that X
implements the add trait right
and we also have to Define over here the
associated type output to be of type t
let's see
this is compiling
let's actually call the function
[Applause]
and print out the result
so as you can see the output would be
10.
and we can call it with float right
so let's see exercise 8 fix the errors
as you can see we have a pair struct
which has two Fields holding values of
type t meaning they are generic
and then we have an implementation block
for repair and we Define here an
Associated function and this is not a
method because it doesn't have self as
parameter
now over here we are instantiating a new
pair
and remember self over here uppercase s
refers to the type of the implementation
block meaning pair
and then we return this instance so if I
write pair here it would be the same
thing
then over here we have another
implementation block
for the type pair
and as you can see we Define here that t
over here should implement the debug and
partial order
so the type T over here the type of the
two fields
the type of the two Fields must
Implement debug and partial order
then over here we are defining a method
compare display which takes a reference
to an instance of pair
and then checking over here is the value
of the X field bigger than or equal to
the value of the Y field
if that is the case then self dot X will
get printed out using debug notation
that is why we need
T to implement the debug trade otherwise
we print out the value of the Y field
so as you can see over here we have a
custom type unit that holds an i32
integer
now over here we are instantiating a
pair struct
and as you can see we are passing here
as concrete values for X and Y Fields
the unit type
our custom type
and over here it holds one and here
three write an i32
the type annotation for that would be
we would have a pair instance
and T over here would be unit right
because X and Y hold a type of unit so T
over here will be unit
now remember we have over here an
Associated function so let's actually
use that to
instantiate a pair
as you can see this is exactly the same
thing as this but here we are using the
new Associated function that got
implemented on the pair type
so I can delete that
and again when we call on this instance
the compare display method then we would
have an error because as for now
doesn't implement the debug and partial
order trades
so we have to derive them
and by the way we also need the partial
EQ trait
[Applause]
and that's because we are here
checking for equality all right so we
knew so we need partial equality
and because we have now derived these
trades for this type it means unit
implements debug partial order and
partial EQ meaning we can over here
compare for equality and ordering and we
can print the field out using debug
notation
let's see
and this is running so the largest
member is y you will need two
so we have here a pair with an X field
of unit 1 and the Y field of unit 2.
and then the compare display method will
give us back you will need two right
because the wife
because the Y field holds a value that
is bigger than the X field compare these
two because this is a custom type is
only possible because we have derived
these trades
alright see you in the next topic
so before doing more exercises on trade
objects I want to cover Associated types
now an Associated type allows to specify
a type that is associated with the trade
when implementing the trade for a
specific type we have to specify the
concrete type
it's basically a type placeholder that
the trade methods can use in their
signature
and it's similar to generic types but
they are more flexible because they
allow a trade to have different
Associated types for different
implementing types
let's see an example we have here the my
trade and this has an Associated type
called my type and as you can see we can
then use this Associated type over here
in the methods we are defining in the
trade so we here for example Define that
the return type should be of type my
type
meaning when we implement this trade
over here for a concrete type like for
example my struct then we have to define
the concrete type as you can see when we
implement the my trade for my struct we
Define here that my type should be i32
and as you can see this method over here
will then return an i32 type and this is
defined over here and we can access the
associated type using self uppercase
double colon and the name of the
associated type
now again self here stands for the type
we are implementing this Trade four so
in this case my struct
all right let's do some more exercises
practicing trade objects
as you can see we have here a trade bird
that has one method
then we have here two custom types duck
and Swan so let's see for duck we have
an implementation block
and here we Define a method
and this method takes a reference to the
instance and prints out something
and for Swan we also Implement a method
now notice this has nothing to do with
the trade these are methods that are
defined directly on the struct right so
here we
Define a method fly which again takes a
reference to the instance and prints out
something
now over here we are implementing the
birth trait for duck and Swan
meaning we have to implement the method
defined by the trade
so as you can see this Quark method we
have to implement for both types
then over here we want to instantiate a
duck
so we then can call on this stack
instance the swim method
so this will then get executed
then over here we call the hatch a bird
function with an argument of two
and over here we call the hatch a bird
function again with an argument of one
so as you can see when we provide two we
want over here
duck
when we provide one we want over here a
swan
and I see that because of the output
when calling the quack method
so let's implement this function we have
seen that the function takes as an
argument and interfer so let's call the
argument species
and let's define it as u8
now I will keep the return type open we
will see that then
so let's see when we get one let's
actually match the species argument
when we get back one
we want to return
a swan if we get here for the argument
A2 we want to return a duck instance
and because we have to handle all the
cases I will just panic in case anything
else has been passed
so over here what would be the return
type now think about it when calling
this function over here
we have to provide the
return type
now again the return type has to be of
known fixed size at compile time
now over here we don't know what we'll
get actually return that compile time
right especially if this argument over
here would be something that is
generated at runtime
meaning we don't know the exact size
because this one struct could be larger
in size than the duck struct or
otherwise
so we have actually seen the solution we
need to box
the return type and
V over here Define that it should be
dynamically dispatched and that means we
have to box these concrete values here
and now we are good to go because also
another problem would be that in a match
every return type has to be of the same
type now again over here the function
could sometimes return a swan or
sometimes a duck right depending on the
argument
and when we do it like that we actually
return a type of box right so they have
all the same return type now again
because we are here using Dynamic
dispatch we have to put it behind a kind
of pointer
and that means over here we will get
a box
holding a trade object
and the trade object in this case is
bird
so that means and we have seen that the
compiler will then
allocate the concrete type for example
over here a duck
in the Heap memory and we'll create a v
table with all the methods because when
we call over here the Quark method on
bird then at this exact point Dynamic
dispatch happens
because it is not known at compile time
which
concrete type got returned here this
will be determined at runtime so at
runtime the compiler will check the V
table and see the right
and will execute the right method call
right in this case it would be for duck
so the compiler will look this method up
in the v table for the tag type which
has been allocated in Heap memory and we
got
and notice something over here when we
return a trade object the trade object
actually only implements
the methods from the trade in this case
Bird right so we then can't call because
we have here a trade object we can't
call a method directly defined on the
type so for example this swim method is
not in the v table that the compiler
creates
I hope you see that because again we are
returning a trade object meaning in the
v table are only the methods from the
trade
so over here because we have
created an instance on the concrete type
we can call this three method but over
here because we have a trade object we
can only call methods from the trade
let's see
and as you can see this is compiling
array with trade objects again we have
the birth trait with the same method
then we have duck and Swan and as you
can see these are methods that are
implemented directly on the concrete
type
then over here again implementing the
birth trait for duck and so on we have
seen that fill in the blank to make the
code work so over here we want to have
an array because we are here iterating
over this Birds
variable meaning we want to iterate
over
an array
now let's first annotate
we want over here an array of birds
right
so we want a type that implements the
bird trade meaning in this case stock
and Swan and this time I will use a
reference instead of a box so we Define
over here that we want an array
holding
a type that implements the birth trait
and is dynamically dispatched all right
and again because using Dynamic dispatch
requires that we put it behind some kind
of pointer either box or a reference
now with this array let's say we want to
have two elements one
duck and one swan
so let's provide here the instances
and again we have to put that behind a
pointer so the size is known
so the size is known at compile time
because remember the size of the
elements in an array must be known at
compile time in this case it would be
you size
the size of a pointer
now then we want over here to iterate
over these elements here
and then as you can see for each element
we are calling on it the Quark method
now again because this over here is
happening at runtime the Quark method
will be determined at runtime which one
to run here
for stuck or for swan
right
let's see
and this is compiling now overs and here
we have the same thing bird.fly
the method we have directly implemented
on the type isn't available
because in a trade object over here only
the methods from the actual trade birth
are in the v table other methods won't
get into DV table and so the compiler
cannot look it up at runtime
referenced in and boxed in so we have
here a trade draw which has one method
and we implement the draw trade for u8
and f64.
as you can see we can Implement our own
custom trades for types in the standard
Library
and all this does over here
is it will take
a reference of the instance and and it
will output the value now in the newer
version of rust we don't have 2D
reference self here this is happening
automatically
like that and for f64 the same thing
now as you can see we have here an f64
and an u8
basically the types that implement this
draw trade
then over here we are calling the
function draw with box
and as you can see this function over
here expects a trade object of the draw
trade and this trait object should be
boxed all right and then it is calling
the draw method again the compiler will
then look in the v table and will
execute the appropriate method at
runtime
so let's pass the argument for the draw
with box function and in this case we
want to draw X so let's pass it X
and of course this has to be boxed right
like this
now over here we want to draw Y and this
time we are passing a reference meaning
we over here expect a reference
to a trade object
that implements the draw trade
all right
and then we are calling the draw method
again this time on y
let's see
and this is compiling
let's see exercise four we have a trade
full which has one method then we
Implement Foo for u8 and string types
and as you can see we can Implement our
own trades on types that are defined in
this standard Library so in this case u8
and string
then over here in main we have
a variable X holding a u8 and Y holding
a string
basically the types we are implementing
for for right
and let's see now the function called
Static dispatch so we pass here X tu8
type and this should be statically
dispatched so let's implement this
function Implement below with generics
so we need here a generic
type parameter and we Define here a
trade bound meaning we want T to
implement the foo trade
right
because we want the argument to be of
type
t
so it's important that we Define here
the trade bound because we call
this function only with arguments that
implement the full trade
and we are defining that in order to be
able to call the method
method on it basically this method
defined here right
because then we can pass types of u8 and
string to this function and it can call
the method because the full trade is
implemented for this type any other type
that doesn't implement the full trade
won't be allowed to be passed to this
function
so this is static dispatch because the
compiler at compile time will actually
expand this code and create a function
for the concrete types so in this case
we are passing u8 to this function so
the compiler will create
a function like this
right and then we'll call it and this is
happening at compile time meaning the
compiler will fill in the concrete types
over here
and then of course the compiler will
know when we do a method call which
method over here it should call right
and
static dispatch is usually a lot faster
than Dynamic dispatch because you don't
have to do a lookup it's everything in
the binary itself but when you have to
do a lookup you have to follow a pointer
to Heap memory and then get the data
from this memory location which is more
expensive
so let's see Dynamic dispatch in this
case
and we use Dynamic dispatch because
sometimes it's just not possible to use
static dispatch right when the size of
the returned type it cannot be known at
compile time then we use Dynamic
dispatch
and let's see how that looks like so
over here
we are passing a reference to Y so we
are passing here
a reference to a string
now as an argument over here we want a
reference right that's what we are
passing
to a trade object
implementing the full trade all right
and again because this is dynamic
dispatch so this happens at runtime
must be behind a pointer so this size is
known at compile time
because it pointer is always of size U
size we have covered that
and then we call the method on the
argument right
the difference is that over here this
will then be determined at runtime which
method over here to be called right
because the compiler will then do a
lookup in the v table at runtime and
then determine for which type the method
should be called
let's see
this is compiling
object safe you can only make object
safe trades into trade objects a trade
is object safe if all the methods
defined in the trade have the following
properties the return type isn't self
and there are no generic type parameters
so let's see exercise 5 use at least two
approaches to make it work don't add
remove any code line
so
I think we will go first with static
dispatch because it's easier
so I will remove this box here
and let's see we have a trade here
defining one method
now this defines that it takes a
reference to a self
meaning a reference to an instance of my
trait and it returns self their self
over here refers to the type for which
the nitrate is implemented so in this
case for example over here my trade is
implemented for u32 meaning we implement
this method over here
and self over here would refer to u32
right we can write it either way
and
u32 and string Implement my trade all
right so they both implement the F
method
then over here we have a function that
takes a trade object now in this case
you want to use static dispatch so we
Define here
a generic type
right because we are calling it with new
32 and a string
now we want to ensure that t this type
implements my trade so we can be sure
that it implements this F method
so this is called trade bound and this
makes sure that t implements my trade
so we then can call the F method on the
provided argument here which is of type
t
and
that's basically it we have implemented
the static dispatch for this function
over here
and what then will happen is
when we call this function the
roscompiler
will take this generic function here and
it will provide it with concrete types
and it will provide it with concrete
types so in this case u32 right we are
passing it to 32.
and
we have we forgot to define the return
type so the return type over here would
be the return type of the F method
now in this case it would be
T type right
so if we are calling it
so if we are calling the F method on a
new 32 then the return type will be u32
in if we call it on a string then the
return type will be string so again we
pass here T right
because the type we are passing for
example u32 will be the return type of
this function u32 and that in case means
that the return type of this function
over here will be
u32 right
okay
and then the same thing happens for a
string
so the compiler will actually
put into these generic type parameters
concrete types
and that means when we are using static
dispatch these method calls here are
known at compile time so the compiler
knows if you're passing a u32 type then
it will call the F method from the eu32
implementation of my trade right and in
case of string then the compiler will
know that the F method can be found in
the
my trade implementation of string right
so everything here is known at compile
time and also the size is fixed
and this is working
now
we want here
to now use Dynamic dispatch so we solve
it in two approaches
so before we can even use this straight
object over here we have to make the
trade itself object safe and we do that
when the return type isn't self and
there are no generic type parameters so
we cannot Define here self we have to
provide it concrete types now in this
case we want
the F method to return a trade object
meaning
we return a pointer
that points to the type that implements
my trade all right
and over here
because we are taking here this function
signature and implement it for each type
we Implement in my trade for so as you
can see the return type must
implement the my trade
and it has to be boxed so we have to box
this over here
turn over here A U 32 right
which implements the my trade and over
here a string
[Applause]
which also implements my trade
so as you can see we got rid of self
because again
at compile time the return type size has
to be known
that's why we are putting it behind a
box
now
again the return type of this function
would be the return type of Team method
calls in this case it would be a boxed
trait object
right
let's see if this is compiling
and this is also compiling
now I hope you see the difference here
when we pass here a trade object
basically a type in this case u32 that
implements the my trade trade
then this method call will be determined
at runtime
and that's why we have to put this
behind pointers so the size remains
fixed and known at compiled time
and again use whenever possible static
dispatch because it's faster and I guess
easier to write but Dynamic dispatch has
its advantages and you can use it for
more flexibility in your code
alright see you in the next topic
so we have reached the topic of
collection types and string is also a
collection type meaning we are just
repeating because we have covered
strings but I think these exercises are
good for some repetitions
so string is a utf-8 encoded growable
string it is the most common string type
we used in Daily development it also has
ownership over the string contents
so let's see fill in the blanks and fix
arrows don't use to string don't add
remove any code line
so as you can see over here we want a
string type because we because we are
here modifying the swing meaning it has
to be growable
so let's
allocate this data over here on the heat
so we have now a string type we can
now let's see the poster method
as you can see this push stir method is
implemented on the string type and it
takes as a type for its argument a
string literal
as you can see we are calling it on a
string and providing it an argument of a
string literal
so we have to delete that because this
would actually be a string right
we want here a string literal
like that
and push is for pushing single
characters so we want to push here an
exclamation mark So s will then here
match with this string literal
and as you can see we are calling the
move ownership function here meaning
this function will then take ownership
of s and that's not what we want because
we are using here as again so what we
can do is just clone it
so the data passed to move ownership
over here is actually cloned
right it is copied on the Heap memory
and that means we can still use S
because s Remains the owner of this data
all right
then a string is stored as a vector of
bytes but guaranteed to always be a
valid utf-8 sequence
string is Heap allocated growable and
not null terminated a string slice is a
slice
basically a slice to u8
integers because as you can see
this string type is a vector of u8 inter
source
that always points to a valid utf-8
sequence and can be used to view into a
string just like a slice to T is a view
into Vector T and we'll cover vectors
after this topic
so fill in the blanks
we have here a string
and we want to take a string slice from
this string now the easiest method would
be just to take a reference to s
which means we take a reference to a
string type
and this can then be inferred by the
compiler to a string slice
and the second way would be to call the
askster method on it
this will essentially do exactly the
same thing it will take the string s and
we'll convert it to a string slice
now over here we also want a string
slice
but we want to provide a specific offset
we just want this data over here
and that means we take a reference to s
and provide it here an offset from zero
we can omit the zero on here
until index 0 1 2 3 4
until index four now we would provide
here 5 because 5 is excluded meaning we
go from index 0 to 4.
and over here as you can see we want to
modify the string holding then hello
world because we are pushing to it this
exclamation mark as you can see we want
it hello world and with an exclamation
mark
so what we can do is taking
s over here s mutable reference
so this would then hold a mutual
reference to a string
let's see
and this is compiling now notice over
here we could also take ownership of s
meaning slice 3 will hold a string
because we are not using S after this
point so slice 3 can be the owner of s
but in this case we have to make the
variable mutable
and this is also working
question how many Heap allocations are
happening here so we have here a string
and
when we create a string type then the
data that is provided is allocated in
Heap memory
so this would be the first allocation
then over here we are taking from this
string over here a reference meaning a
string slice and remember a string size
is just a view into some data so we are
just going to this location and checking
what's in there
so no allocation is happening
and over here we are taking this string
slice and convert it to a string meaning
a heap allocation is happening over here
right because we are taking this string
slice
[Applause]
holding this
and then we allocate this
into the Heap once more being because we
are calling this two string method
let's see indexing
so we have a string here
and we want to index into the first
element so slice one should then hold h
so we want a string slice
so we take a reference to S and provided
the offset from 0 to 1.
1 is excluded meaning we just take the
first character
and that is because H only takes one
byte in utf-8 format so
ASCII characters in strings usually take
one byte while this Unicode characters
over here take three bytes so when we
take a string slice here
we want to access this character
now for that we have to provide the
right offset so we go from 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7.
starting at index seven and as you can
see these Unicode characters hold three
bytes meaning
we must provide here an offset of 10. 10
is excluded meaning we go from 7 8 9.
three bytes iterate through all Source
in s
so to iterate over characters in a
string type we use Stitch Source method
but that will actually just return the
Char we are iterating over but as you
can see we want here as return type a
tuple which holds the index and the
actual character so we can use here to
enumerate method
and enumerate will return a tuple with
the index and the specific character so
in the first iteration you would have
zero and H right the index and the
character
so here we are checking if the index
over here is 7 then the variable C
should hold this character
right
let's see
and this is compiling
now there is a crate called utf-8 slice
you can import it into your project and
this then allows you to slice into a
string
not using bytes as offsets but just
indexing into the individual characters
so over here we provide an offset from
four to five meaning we want the
character at index 4.
so we don't have to worry about the byte
size of this symbol
then fill in the blanks we have here a
string
now we have seen that a string is
actually a vector holding u8 intervals
and as you can see we have here some
bytes in a vector so this Vector holds
u8 inters right
and that means these are bytes that can
be converted to ASCII characters
so in this case these over here will
translate to hello
all right
if you look up this code over here in
the ASCII table then we will find that
this is represented for the character
age
and this e l l o
so we want to turn a bytes Vector like
this into a string so we want to be
string here
so let's see this method here
so in the documentation you can see that
the string type implements a method from
utf-8
and this just takes a vector of bytes
and then we can call this Associated
function on the string type and provide
it as an argument a vector of bytes
and this will then convert it to a
string so we can try it out
so first of all we want to actually
mutate the string here to hold the same
data as this Vector holds namely hello
so we can do that by using poster
and we push hello meaning this string
then holds hello
and
then we can take this string type and
call from utf-8 method providing it this
vector
and this should then convert this Vector
of bytes into an actual string meaning s
and S1 will then hold the same value
namely a string hello
and of course this actually
and this returns a result so we have to
unwrap it
and as you can see this is compiling
so in fact a string is just a vector of
bytes right
and we'll cover vectors very soon and
you will then see how this is actually
stored in memory
so a string is made up of three
components a pointer to some bytes a
length and a capacity the pointer points
to an internal buffer string uses to
store its data the length is the number
of bytes currently stored in the buffer
always stored on the Heap and the
capacity is the size of the buffer in
bytes as such the length will always be
less than or equal to the capacity
we have seen that the string type is a
three bird object holding a pointer to
the actual data stored in Heap memory
the length which shows the length of the
string in this case 5 and the capacity
and the capacity as you can see here is
the total amount of memory received from
the allocator
so when we allocate a new string type on
the Heap the allocator we will find an
empty spot and then we'll return a
pointer to that location
number six if a string has enough
capacity adding elements to it will not
really allocate
so
when we run this program over here
then we see the capacity of string s
now over here we are initializing an
empty string
meaning we have an empty string so
nothing gets allocated to Heap memory we
still have a string object but with a
length of zero and a capacity of zero
then we print it out as you can see Zero
over here we are iterating two times
modifying this string so in the first
iteration s will then hold
hello
so it would have a length of five but
when we print out the capacity it will
show 8. so we have a string object that
points to this data with a length of 5
and a capacity of 8. now this is the
default behavior when we don't specify a
capacity ourself so
when the length exceeds the capacity
then rust has to reallocate the data
meaning it has to find a new spot in
Heap memory that is big enough to hold
the data and then we'll return a pointer
to the new location so in this case
because we have modified the string the
length 5 exceeds the capacity zero so it
has to reallocate because remember in
Heap memory
the data is allocated as contiguous
block of bytes all right
and the default behavior is that the
capacity will always double so it starts
from 1 then 2 4 8 16 and so on and
that's the reason we have here a
capacity of 8 even though we only need
five right this is a length this is a
string of length five but because of the
default behavior of the allocator we
will get back a capacity of 8. and then
in the second iteration we again push
hello
right so we would have a length of 10
but as you can see the capacity doubles
so 10 exceeds the length of 8 meaning
the allocator will then find a new spot
in hit memory to allocate
this string over here of length 10. and
it will then
Reserve 16 bytes of memory in Heap
memory and so on if we then exceed 16
bytes then it will allocate to a
location which holds 32 right it always
doubles
and this is when you let rust allocate
so this is the default Behavior but as
you can see this might be expensive so
if you
start with a capacity of zero and then
you modify the string multiple times it
means rust has to reallocate your
daytime
and that means it could potentially be
expensive when you mutate this over here
multiple times and a lot of
reallocations are happening so there is
a function called with capacity
and then we can Define over here that we
want an empty string meaning the string
length is zero but we want a capacity of
25 meaning s
is allocated in Heap memory and
there is enough space reserved for this
data
to hold 25 elements right so when we do
that again
then as you can see
no reallocation has happened we have
only allocated the string one time in
heat memory with a capacity of 25.
now because the length doesn't exceed
the capacity in any of this modification
of the string it means that there is no
need to re-allocate the data right so
when we print out
swing s over here in the end
then as you can see this is the
string that in the end hello
hello so we have here 10 elements
meaning
there is no need for reallocation
because a capacity of 25 can hold
the string of this size and this can
make your program a lot faster
so let's see vectors a vector is like an
array but dynamically sized meaning they
can grow and Shrink it's allocated on
the Heap as contiguous block of memory
all elements in a vector have to have
the same type and there is a special
macro vac which you can use to
initialize a new vector
so all this time we've been dealing with
an imposter so in actuality this string
type is just a vector of utf-8 bytes
that gets allocated in Heap memory
so as you can see when we have the S1
variable over here then again S1 won't
hold the actual data but a pointer to
the data allocated in Heap memory
alongside a length and a capacity
meaning S1 is a three word object of
size 24 bytes
now
as you can see this would be a vector
allocated in Heap memory that holds the
utf-8
bytes over here of course in memory this
would be in binary but as you can see
this then holds the
character code for this character inside
the string
so let's do some exercises vectors or
resizable arrays like slices their size
is not known at compiled time but they
can grow or Shrink at any time
so over here we have a normal array
holding three u8 elements
now we can convert this array to a
vector using the from Associated
function and then passing it the array
meaning we will then hold a vector
of u8 elements and here you can see the
difference between an array and a vector
we don't provide here the length of the
vector because the vector can actually
grow or Shrink meaning it's dynamic in
its size
now the isvac function basically just
checks if the provided argument is a
vector
then as you can see we are shadowing V
and we are here initializing it with a
vector of these elements so as you can
see you can use the VAC macro to quickly
create a new Vector like that
so this will then hold a vector of u8
elements
and by the way you can either use square
brackets or you can use parentheses it's
both exactly the same
now as you can see here we are
initializing V or basically shadowing it
and then we are passing it to is back
meaning ownership would be transferred
but we are using V here again so let's
clone this
and over here as you can see we are
initializing V1 with Divac macro now we
are passing to the back macro the array
Mac macro over here won't convert it
directly to a vector like this from
Associated function did instead we would
here have a vector
holding
this array all right
I hope you can see the difference
here we have a vector of u8 elements
over here we have a vector holding an
array of three u8 elements
so
when we compare over here V and V1 they
won't actually be the same right
and again let's do clone here
just so we can then reuse B1
now what we can do over here to fix that
is using the VAC new
like that
and back new basically will then create
a new empty Vector meaning it would be
an object with length of 0 and capacity
of zero
now over here we want to iterate over
the elements in v
let's take a reference here because we
are using V again and we don't want this
for Loop to take ownership
now all we want to do is pushing all the
elements from we into V1
and because we are here iterating over
references of elements we have to
de-reference it and by the way we will
take a look at that in much greater
detail
so what we also have to do is making
this V1 variable mutable because when
pushing to it it has to be mutable
alright let's see
and this is compiling so in the end V1
will hold a vector
of U 8 elements meaning V and V1 are
exactly the same
but remember when you have an array use
the from Associated function and not the
VAC macro because it won't convert it
directly to a vector instead it will
create a vector holding an array
Evac can be extended with extend method
so over here we have a vector
let's say these are i-32 values
and as you can see we can pop meaning
removing the last element so over here
the vector will then hold 1 and 2
because the last element got popped then
we are pushing to it 3.
meaning we have a vector holding one two
three
now over here again we are initializing
an empty vector
now as you can see we want V1 and V2 to
be exactly the same
so what we can do is using the extent
method
and providing it the V1 vector
meaning the elements
foreign
and we have to pass here a reference
meaning the elements then from V1 will
be
put into V2 so again V2 will then be a
vector of I 32 elements and they hold
exactly the same data right
it's basically copying the contents of a
vector into another vector
turn X into back fill in the blanks
so over here we have an array
and this array holds i32
types and the size of the array would be
3.
then as we've seen we can use the from
Associated function
so we create a vector from this array
meaning V1 will then hold a vector of
i32
types
or what we also could do is calling the
into method and if a type implements
from then it will Implement into and we
will take a look at that
so we then take this array over here and
convert it into a vector of i32
values right so that means V1 and V2
will be exactly the same
now converting a string into a vector
so the from trade over here
is actually implemented for the vector
type so over here we have a string
and remember basically a string is a
vector of u8 elements
and then again we can call here into
right converting s
into a vector of u8 elements
and then over here we have again a
string and we call the method in two
bytes meaning
V2 holds a vector of utf-8 bytes
represented as u8
and this is actually exactly the same so
meaning V1 and V2 will be identical
then over here we have a string
literally
and we want to create a vector from this
variable meaning we again use the from
Associated function and provide it as an
argument over here meaning B3 will then
hold a vector of u8 types right
so V2 over here and V3 are identical
iterators can be collected in two
vectors
so when we have here an array of 10
elements of value 0 and we put it into
an iterator we can then collect it into
a vector all right and we will see these
methods over here in Twitter and collect
in much greater detail meaning V4 will
then hold a vector
and of 10 times 0.
like that all right let's see
and this is compiling
fix the error and implement the code so
let's see over here we have an array
and we convert this array into a vector
using the from Associated function we
have seen
so this will then hold a vector of I 32
types all right
now then we are iterating here five
times
and
just print out each element at the
specific index
here we have to implement some code and
actually V in the end should hold a
vector with these elements
so as you can see
we have we are starting with a vector
holding one two three and we end with a
vector 2 3 4 5 6.
now what we want to achieve here is we
are adding one to each element
then we would have 2 3 and 4.
now
if we exceed the boundary over here then
we want actually to add the new element
over here
now
let's see first in the for Loop here
this would actually panic because we are
trying to access indexes that are out of
bounds so over here we are iterating
from 0 to 4 right 5 excluded but we have
only three elements meaning meaning
indexes 0 to 2.
now we can here you stick get method
and we have seen this get method before
and and this is generally safer because
it will return an option
[Applause]
in this case option i32 because we are
dealing with i32 types here
and what we then can do over here
we want to actually manipulate this
Vector so let's first access the
elements
and as you can see again I use the get
method because we want to actually see
if
the index is out of bounds or not so in
case it's not out of bounds we would
return a sum right the get method will
return a sum
and the actual value at that specific
index
so if we found an element at the
specific index over here then we want
to access the element and just add to it
one right
we are then taking the element over here
let's see for example in the first
iteration I will be zero then we pass 0
to this get method meaning we will get
back some 1 right so we'll get back some
1 meaning
e over here will then hold a value of 1.
then we access
this array at index 0 right and what we
want then to do is taking 1 E over here
and add to it one meaning then
the first element in this Vector has
been modified to then hold two
now in the second iteration to do it
would be exactly the same thing so I
would be 1 we get over here
the element at index one and E will then
hold two and then over here V at index 1
should then hold two plus one right and
we assign it meaning
in the modified vector the second
element will then hold three
now we do that again and after we are
out of boundaries meaning we return a
non here
and then we want to push to the vector
the index plus two right
so for example in the third iteration I
would be three right this would be out
of bounds there is no index 3 here so we
get back a non
and then over here we push to V the
index in this case 3 plus 2 meaning we
then get back 5 right
and let's see if this is actually
working
all right and let's remove this type
annotation because this would be of Type
U size because of the get method
now as you can see
when we print out here the output of the
get method we would get someone sum two
and some three and then two times none
because at iteration 3 and 4 we would
get back none because there is no
element in this index
and we are succeeding here because again
we have three times sum here and when we
have a sum we just add 1 to the value
meaning we then have 2 3 and 4.
and then we will get back two times none
meaning we take the index and
increment it by two pushing it to the
vector so we get five and six
slicing a vac can be mutable on the
other hand slices are read only objects
to get a slice use reference in Rust
it's more common to pass slices as
arguments rather than vectors when you
just want to provide read access the
same goes for string and string slices
so over here we have a vector
let's say i32
then we are taking a slice from V over
here
meaning this would then be a slice of
i32 elements right
and this would be the offset meaning we
would take from the first element to the
last element
out of bounds will cause a panic you
must use the length here so as you can
see again we are taking a string slice
foreign
but we are here out of bounds right
because
this would iterate from 0 to 3 for
excluded and we have here only zero one
two indexes
so what we can do is using B dot length
meaning we just iterate
meaning we provide an offset from zero
the first element to V length where the
length here is excluded meaning vlanth
minus one all right
slices or read only node slice and
reference to back are different
so as you can see we take here immutable
reference to a vector
and then we can push to this Vector over
here
the value 4.
now we have seen that slices are
immutable they are just a view into some
data so we can't use a slice to mutate
the vector right
so over here we want to have a slice
of i32 elements right
like that and we can remove the mute
keyword over here because again we can't
modify slices so we have pushed to it
for meaning when we take the slice we
want to take also this last pushed
element right
and this is compiling
capacity the capacity of a vector is the
amount of space allocated for any future
elements that will be added onto the
vector this is not to be confused with
the length of a vector which specifies
the number of actual elements within the
vector if a vector's length exceeds its
capacity its capacity will automatically
be increased but its elements will have
to be reallocated for example a vector
with with capacity 10 and length 0 would
be an empty Vector with space for 10
more elements pushing 10 or fewer
elements onto the vector will not change
its capacity or cause reallocation to
occur however
however if the vector's length is
increased to 11 it will have to
reallocate which can be slow for this
reason it is recommended to use the
width capacity function whenever
possible to specify how big the vector
is expected to get
and this we have already covered with
strings but now let's see with vectors
so over here as you can see we are
initializing an empty Vector but with a
capacity of 10 so this object here would
hold length of 0 and capacity of 10
meaning the actual elements inside
Vector are zero there are no elements
but
in Heap memory there were 10 locations
allocated for this data right
the vector contains no items even though
it has a capacity for more so when we
call the length method over here we
would get back zero right because back
doesn't hold any values but it has a
capacity of 10 because we have defined
that over here
these are all done without reallocating
so we are then pushing 10 times to the
vector right
now this means
back here holds enough space that this
is happening without re-allocating the
vector right
so after pushing to the vector T Vector
with would be of length 10. and capacity
10. right
so the length must never exceed the
capacity otherwise a re-allocation is
happening
as we can see here but this may make the
vector reallocate so we are pushing
another element to the vector meaning
the length will be 11. this would exceed
the capacity meaning then
this whole Vector will be reallocated in
Heap memory so when we have a length of
11 then the capacity will be at least 11
but it can be more because we have seen
that the default behavior when
reallocating is that the capacity
doubles
feeling an appropriate value to make the
four done without reallocating
so as you can see we have here a vector
we want to initialize with a certain
capacity then we are pushing 100 times
to this vector meaning the length here
will be 100 so what we want to do is we
want here to initialize a vector with a
capacity of 100 meaning we can push 100
times without this Vector to be
reallocated in Heap memory
store distinct types in Vector the
elements in a vector must be the same
type for example the code below will
cause an error
so we have here integers and a float
this would cause an error because again
all of them have to be of the same type
but we can use enums or trade objects to
store distinct types so over here we
again see the IP address enum we have
seen before in the examples
now fill in the blank we want over here
a vector that holds IP addresses
meaning at index 0 we want this variant
here and at index 1 we want this variant
now we can use the back Macro for that
and then over here I just copy
this
variant
and
this over here right we would then have
over here a vector holding types of IP
address
and because this is a custom type we
have to actually Implement partial EQ
here
so I hope you get the concept we have
here a vector holding types of IP
address right
then over here we have a trade IP
address that
defines one method display and then we
have two Tuple structs V4 and V6 we
implement the IP address trade for v2
struct and V6 tract meaning we have to
implement the specific method
and all it does it then basically prints
out the value that is stored inside
destruct
so fill in the blank as you can see we
won't hear a vector holding trade
objects remember a trade object is boxed
or put behind a reference
so over here we have a vector
holding boxes right
and the Box holds
a trade object meaning again this is
using Dynamic dispatch and we won't hear
a type that implements the IP address
straight right in this case B4 and V6
both are types that Implement IP address
and as you can see even though we are
holding here different types we can use
it using here trade objects to store it
in the same vector
typo
so and then
we are iterating over the vector and for
each
element in here we just call the display
method that has to be implemented
because we only have types in here that
implement the IP address trade
and this is exactly where Dynamic
dispatch happens and we have covered
that
let's take a look at hash Maps so a hash
map is a data structure to store key
value pairs it's allocated on the Heap
as it is dynamically sized meaning it
can grow and Shrink
it allows for efficient lookup insertion
and deletion of data so when talking
about time complexity this means
accessing and modifying elements or
entries as they are called in hashmaps
would be in the best case at constant
time meaning Big O of 1 while in the
worst case if you have a lot of
collisions then it would be still linear
time which is still pretty fast which
means Big O of n
each key is hashed to a unique index in
the underlying array so there are
vectors stores values by an integer
index hashmap store value spy key it is
a hashmap implemented with quadratic
probing and simd lookup by default a
hashmap uses a hashing algorithm
selected to provide resistance against
hash those attacks so over here we find
some information about the used
algorithm for the hash Maps
but let's dive into the exercises
so the first thing is we actually have
to use here a namespace so we are
basically importing from the collections
module from this standard Library the
hashmap type
and when using vectors or strings these
are all in the Prelude meaning we don't
have to import it but a hash map you
will have to basically import
so over here we are initializing an
empty hash map
then we insert some entries and again a
hash map holds entries of keys and
values now important here is that all
the keys must be of the same type and
all of the values must be of the same
type so this over here would cause an
error
and let's go with integers
like that and we annotate the hash map
like this
[Applause]
where key stands for key and v stands
for value
so over here we use string literals as
keys
and i32 integers as values
then as you can see we can access
the entries in a hash map by using again
the get method which returns an option
we have seen that before when dealing
with vectors
so we provide the get method
the name of the key all right and then
we will get back the appropriate value
in this case 98 because we are accessing
the entry sun phase right so we would
get back here
a sum
an option
i32 right this would be the return value
some 98 and this would be the type
option i32
so we can check if
the hashmap contains a certain key so
for example if the hash map contains the
key Daniel this would evaluate to true
meaning the code block here will be
executed
and we can also index into a hashmap
using bracket notation like that
so again this would then hold
the value of the entry Daniel it would
be 95 right
this would be an i32 again notice the
difference between indexing like that or
indexing using using get method
we will get back the value here directly
while here we get back an option so get
is generally safer
and then over here we are removing
Daniel from the hash map
right so we can use the remove method
and provide it the key
the entry we want to delete meaning
after deleting Daniel over here the
length of the hash map would be 3 right
and we can also iterate over a hash map
so we provide it here
the variable holding the hash map and
then
the return would be a tuple holding the
key and the value and then we just print
out the key and the value
let's see
all right and we would get back here an
option
holding a reference to i32 all right
and over here too we would get back a
reference
this is what the get method will
actually return so as you can see we are
printing out the hash map
and this would be the key for example
Ashley and this would be the value
as you can see
now notice that the order here is
different from what is over there and
that's because a hashmap is unordered so
the order won't be retained all right
and of course we have only three
elements here because we have removed
the entry of Daniel
then over here we have an array holding
tuples which holds a string literal and
an integer right
so we have an array of three elements
and each element is of type Tuple
and inside the Tuple is a string literal
and an i32
then over here we are initializing a new
empty hash map
then we iterate over here through the
elements of this team's array
so for each element here
we insert into this empty hash map here
the name over here the string and the
value
all right
Implement team map 2 in two ways tips
one of the approaches is to use collect
method so we can also
implement
a hash map from an array holding tuples
of keys and values by using the hash map
from function so we provide it here
teams
and this will then directly convert this
array holding tuples of keys and value
pairs to a hash map
meaning we then have a hash map
holding string slice keys and i32 values
all right
and over here we would have the same
thing
and then when we compare teams map 1 and
teams map 2 they should be equal let's
see
this is compiling
now the second approach would be taking
this teams array here
and we want to put it into an iterator
and again we will cover that
and then we call collect
now when we call the collect method it
will basically collect the elements in
this iterator into the type we have
annotated here
again this would compile because we have
in teams map 2 the same
keys and values as we have in teams map
one
and as you can see we don't need to
write a full-blown for Loop we can just
use some simple methods
let's see number three fill in the
blanks so
type inference lets us omit an explicit
type signature which would be hashmap
string slice and u8 in this example so
again we don't have to annotate the
types I do it just to make things more
clear
but we can leave it at that
insert a key only if it doesn't already
exist
so here we are
accessing player stats this empty
hashmap and we call the entry now the
entry checks if
an entry exists with this specific key
and then we can call over here the or
insert method meaning if this entry
doesn't exist then we insert this key
with this value meaning when we then
access player stats with a key of Health
we would should get back 100 right
because this has been inserted over here
insert a key using a function that
provides a new value only if it doesn't
already exist
so
again we are trying to access player
stats and look for an entry Health now
in this case this exists right because
we have inserted it at that point
now we can also use here the method or
insert with the difference to our insert
is that we don't provide a concrete
value but a function pointer meaning
this function will then get executed so
this function only returns 42 so that
means if the entry Health doesn't exist
we insert this key with the value of 42.
now again Health exists meaning when we
Access Health we will still get 100
right
because this only executes if N3 isn't
found
ensures a value is in the entry by
inserting the default if empty and
returns immutable reference to the value
in the entry
so we are here
checking for the entry health
and if it doesn't exist we insert 50
right
so in this case Health already exists
meaning we would get back immutable
reference to the existing value 100
right
so this would be immutable
reference to 100.
and because it is mutable we can then
modify the entry manually so we can hear
decrement from Health which holds 100 we
decrement 50 meaning the health will
then hold
50 right this health variable holds 50.
let's see
this would be u8 in this case
and this is compiling so as you can see
when we call entry it will give us back
a mutable reference to the value
if it already exists to the existing
value if it doesn't exist it will here
create an entry because this is what the
or insert method does and will return
immutable reference to the created value
and then we can
modify
this mutable reference
right
requirements of hashmap key any type
that implements C EQ and hash trades can
be a key in a hashmap this includes pool
intu in string and string slices
note that F32 and f64 do not Implement
hash likely because floating Point
Precision errors would make using them
as hashmap Keys horribly error prone
all collection classes Implement EQ and
hash if their contained type also
respectively implements EQ and hash for
example a vac holding a type T will
Implement hash if T implements hash so
if the elements in a collection for
example a vector or a tuple or an array
implement
the hash trade then the collection
itself will Implement hash
let's see fix the errors tips derive is
usually a good way to implement some
common use traits as you can see we have
here a struct viking with two fields of
type string
and here we have
an associate function for Viking just
creating a new Viking instance from the
arguments we provide
and as you can see use a hashmap to
store the Vikings Health points
so we are creating here a hash map from
an array holding tuples of keys and
values
now notice we have here a hash map
and the type of the keys would be the
custom type y King all right
the value would be i32
use derived implementation to print the
status of the Vikings so here we are
taking this created hash map as a
reference and we would get back a tuple
holding the key and the value and then
we just print out the key and the value
here
so we have seen that in order
a type can be used as a key in a hash
map it has to implement EQ and hash so
let's Implement that
let's also use the partially queue over
here
and debug so we can print out the key
over here in debug notation let's see
and of course we have to implement the
hash trade
and as you can see it will print out
each element in the hash map we have
created so we have now a hash map
using as key our custom type y King as
you can see this would be the key
this would be the value
of the hashmap
capacity like vectors hash maps are
growable but hashmaps can also shrink
themselves when they have excess space
you can create a hash map with a certain
capacity using hashmap with capacity or
use hashmap new to get a hashmap with a
default initial capacity this is
recommended
so like we did with strings and vectors
we can Define when initializing an empty
hashmap the capacity right
ensuring that when we know we will push
a lot of entries that there are no
reallocations because remember we
allocations are slower
so then we are here inserting two
entries
and as you can see this would be an
entry of
key i32 and value i32 so the key entity
value can be of the same type and over
here we insert again another entry
indeed the capacity of hashmap is not
100 so we can't compare the equality
here
so even though we have here defined that
the capacity should be 100 it could
actually be more than 100 and this is
just in case there are collisions there
are some
internal stuff going on so the RAS
compiler will actually allocate more
capacity than 100 we defined here
shrinks the capacity of the map with a
lower limit so when we call map over
here our hash map holding two entries
and then we can shrink the capacity to
50 right so again the capacity won't
probably be exactly 50 then but around
50 so we can shrink the hash map
and shrinks the capacity of the map as
much as possible so because over here we
have only a hash map of two entries 50.
spaces in Heap memory would actually be
more than we need so we can use this
shrink to fit method so that the
capacity will shrink around
the amount of elements it actually holds
again it won't probably be 2 exactly but
around this number
ownership for types that implement the
copy trade like i32t values are copied
into hashmap for owned values like
string the values will be moved and
hashmap will be the owner of those
values
fix the errors with least changes don't
remove any code line
so over here we have initialized a
variable with a type of i32 and an empty
hash map
right
then we insert here
and N3 into M1
and using the same exact value for the
key and the value meaning we have here a
hash map
with keys of type i32 and values of type
i32
over here we have a string
and we initialize here an empty hash map
then over here we are inserting a new
entry using V2 this string here as the
key and V1 over here as value so we
would have here a hash map
using
keys of type string and value of type
i32
and because this is an owned type
meaning it doesn't Implement copy this
will then actually be moved into the
hash map so we can't use V2 here
but what we could do to fix that is we
could use a string slice of this string
right we just provide a reference
meaning then the hash map will have
type for the keys of string slices right
and that means we can then again use V2
and again because V1 is of type i32 it
means it implements the copy trade
meaning even if we pass it as a key in
the hash map or as a value it is still
usable
but when you are dealing with types that
don't Implement copy the ownership will
get moved meaning hashmap will then be
the owner of the type
alright and there are some third-party
hash lips but I won't cover that in this
beginners course so we'll see you in the
next topic
let's now look at type coercion and we
have already seen the S keyword and this
is mostly used for converting integers
so type conversion also called type
casting is coercing a primitive type
that can be performed by as keyword
as conversions can be Chained and when
casting to an unsight type T for example
then T Max Plus 1 is added or subtracted
until the value fits into the new type
and using unsafe methods can lead to
undefined Behavior
so let's see an example as you can see
we have here the largest unsigned 8-bit
integer 255.
and this would be the binary
representation
this means that u8 right this data type
for unsigned 8-bit integers Max meaning
255 plus 1 will be
256 so for example if we Typecast 1000 s
u 8 then let's see what the compiler
will do
it will subtract
256 this value over here from 1000
and then it will check seven hours
744 is still bigger than the largest
value it can represent meaning it will
do the same thing
subtracting
256 will leave us with
488 still bigger than this value so
again the same thing it will subtract
256 and this will leave us with
232 meaning this will then be the
returned value when we cast 1000 s u 8
because remember an 8-bit unsigned
integer can't represent 1000 it's out of
bounds
now when we Typecast
-1
as u8 then remember an unsight integer
cannot represent negative numbers
meaning what it will then do it will
basically rotate so 0 would be the
smallest possible number an 8-bit
unsigned integer can represent and then
-1 will just basically rotate it will go
back to the biggest one meaning this
type casting over here will result in
255.
so convert by S rust provides no
implicit type conversion coercion
between primitive types but explicit
type conversions can be performed can be
performed using the as keyword
fix the errors and fill in the blank
don't remove any code
so over here we have an F 32 float right
then we Typecast this float into an u8
meaning over here the fractional part
will get removed so the value would be
97.
and of course this will then hold a u8
now we want to Typecast this decimal
into HR now this is not possible
directly but we have seen that we can
chain as statements so we can convert
this first to an u8
meaning we will get 97 like we did here
and then Typecast it to a character so
C1 will then hold a character
and by the way 97 would be the ASCII
code for a
and over here as you can see we can
Typecast this integer holding an u8 type
as Char directly so C2 would also hold
HR
now as you can see we are here comparing
the integer holding 97 with this type
casting now this type casting over here
converts the B character to its u8
representation now B would be
represented as 98.
so what we can do over here is adding
one
297 because remember 97 would be a
meaning when we add 1 to 8 we will get
back B right so both of them will hold
98.
by default overflow will cause compile
errors but we can add a global
annotation to suppress these errors
so as you can see the largest possible
number u8 can represent would be
255 meaning this would cause an error
because again 1000 is larger than the
largest possible number a weight can
represent meaning we have here an
overflow error now we can actually allow
overflowing
by using this attribute
so
distance won't complain right
and then when we print out B
[Applause]
as you can see we would get back
232 because we have seen over here
that
this would be the result when the
compiler performs this operation
so we allow here overflowing literals
right
if we didn't if we comment this out
then the compiler will complain because
this is actually not possible
when casting any value to an unsight
type T T Max plus one is added or
subtracted until the value fits into the
new type that's what we have seen so in
this case 1000 as u16 would return 1000
right because a u16 can represent a
number of 1000 but over here we would
have an overflow meaning this would
return
232 like we have seen over here
for positive numbers this is the same as
the modulus
so this would actually be the same as
uh doing a thousand modulus
256 remember
u8 Max
plus one
meaning 256.
now we have also seen in the example
when we have
-1 and casting that to an unsigned
integer it will then basically just
rotate so this will return
255. since rust 1.45 the S keyword
performs a saturating cast when casting
from float to int if the floating point
value exceeds the upper bound or is less
than the lower round the The Returned
value will be equal to the bound crossed
so in this case we have a float here
casting it to u8 meaning a saturating
cost will be performed so it will just
return the largest possible number u8
can represent which would be 255.
now in case we have here A minus 100 as
floating point and convert it to u8 this
just would return 0.
it's a possible number u8 can represent
this Behavior incurs a small runtime
cost and can be avoided with unsafe
methods however the results might be
overflow and return unsound values use
these methods wisely we can use here in
an unsafe block
the method to int unchecked
so the compiler here won't actually
check what's going on so as you can see
we are casting 300 floating Point 2 and
U int
to a u8
so as you can see we are here casting
300.0 floating point to
and u8 integer and this won't be checked
by the compiler that's because it's in
an unsafe block
now this would return 44 right because
300 minus u8 Max
plus one
would be 300 minus 256
meaning we would be left with 44.
and minus 100 Su 8 as you can see we are
typecasting this floating point
2 and u8 integer and again this is
unchecked so again what the compiler
will do here it will take u8 Max
plus one meaning 256 and it subtracts
100 meaning we would get 156.
and not a number
would be converted to zero okay
thank you
and of course here we have to use again
the attribute allow
overflowing
literals
just so this will actually compile
because usually this won't compile
and as you can see this would be the
output
now over here we are dealing with raw
pointers and we won't cover that in this
beginner's course because this is more
of an advanced topic
so see you in the next topic
so we have seen type conversions for
integers and types from the standard
library but what if we want to convert
types that we defined basically custom
types and rust has for this T from
entity into trade so let's see from and
into trades are used for type
conversions between different types
without requiring explicit costs it's
part of the standard library and can be
implemented for custom types
implementing the from trade for a type
will give us the intu implementation for
the given type for free meaning when we
Implement from we implement it into
automatically
so always implement the from trade and
not the into trade
let's see here an example we have a
custom type number
and then over here we are implementing
the from trade right so we want to
convert from an i32 to our custom type
number right and the from trade
implements a method from
so we take here as an argument an i32
and we will then create a new instance
of the number type with the provided
value and then return it and that means
when we use here the from Associated
function on our custom type
number and provide it in i32 then this
can directly be converted to our custom
type right
and we can do it in two ways from as
we've seen because we have implemented
it and I've told you that when we and
I've told you that when you implement it
from trade T into trade is automatically
implemented meaning we can also call the
into method on the type we want to
convert to but when you use into a type
annotation is needed so the compiler
knows into what type you want to convert
this type right so we convert here
a type of i32 into a number
and this would be the implementation
so the from trade allows for a type to
Define how to create itself from another
type hence providing a very simple
mechanism for converting between several
types deformant into trades are
inherently linked and this is actually
part of its implementation it means if
we it means if we write something like
this
we Implement here
so we Implement here the from trade for
the custom Type U then we can use
U from T right we can then
create a u-type from the type T we have
implemented the front trade on
or we could also use into so we convert
T into U
the input rate is simply the reciprocal
of the from trade that is if you have
implemented the from trade for your type
then the input rate will be
automatically implemented for the same
type using the into trade will typically
require to type annotations as the
compiler is unable to determine this
most of the time
so for example we can easily convert a
string slice into a string
as you can see we have over here a
string slice and then we can call string
and the from Associated function
providing it this string literally
meaning this will then be converted to a
string
and we could also use the two string
method again this and this is exactly
the same
and we could also then use the into
because remember when we Implement from
we get into for free so we can so we
convert this my string string literal
into a string and again type annotations
are needed
because the sender library has already
implemented this for us
input from string slice for string so we
can easily convert a string to a string
slice and vice versa
some implementations of form can be
found here
so as you can see we have here input
from Bool for i32 meaning we can convert
Boolean into an i32 so when we have here
a Boolean value and call into it will
convert this Boolean value into an i32
integer in this case this would
be zero zero for false and one for true
and again when we can use the into
method we can use the from Associated
function
so we call the associated function on
the type i32 and provide it here the
Boolean value right
so this will then actually be exactly
the same
fix the error in two ways first
Implement from Char 4 maybe you should
check the docs mentioned above to find
the answer
second a keyword from the last chapter
so let's see the docs
so
we want here to convert a character
so let's see over here as you can see
you can see all the types that
implemented from trade so we want to go
from character
and as you can see we can convert a
character to either u32 u64 or
u128 as well as string so I 32 is not
supported
and as you notice these are only
unsigned types because it's logical a
character can't be negative right it
can't hold a negative number so we only
have
unsigned intervals here
so we can
so we can then in fact convert HR into a
u32 let's say
so in this case
Char implements
we use here u32 right we can convert
from HR to Au 32.
meaning when we change this over here
this should actually work so we provide
here a character called the into method
and then we should have a new 32.
fix the error in two ways so we can't
use the as keyword here this is not
implemented but what we can do is let's
first use the from method
so we can create a string or basically
converting a character into a string
because we have seen in the
documentation this is actually
implemented
and the second way would be to call a
and then into right like we did over
here
Implement from for custom types from is
now included in standard Prelude so
there is no need to introduce it into
the current scope so we don't have to uh
so we don't have to import the from
trade it's actually in the Prelude
meaning we can use it
without importing anything so over here
we have a custom type number with one
field
now we want to implement the from trade
for our custom number meaning we should
be able to convert from an i32 into a
number
so when we call over here
from
right
then
we should get over here number
this would then create an instance of
the number struct
and the value field here will hold a
value of 30 right
so
and the same thing is when we would call
like that
and call into right this should then
convert the
i32 integer into the number type
automatically
and remember we only have to implement
the from trade because then we can use
from and into
both of them
so let's see so this over here is the
from trade and
let's take this function signature over
here
and copy it like that
now in this case self refers to number
right
and what we want to do is create here a
new instance
and we just take the value in this case
the i32 right
and we provide it as a value for the
value field
and again because the name of this
argument matches the name of the field
we can use it like that and this is
sufficient so let's see
and this is compiling so as you can see
then it's really easy to convert one
type to a custom type we have created
when performing error handling it is
often useful to implement from trade for
our own error type then we can use
question mark to automatically convert
the underlying error type to our own
type now we didn't cover that this will
be the next topic but let's see the
exercise we have here an enum CLI error
now
the two variants here IO error and parse
Arrow hold Arrow types from the standard
Library okay
and
these are actually the error types that
get returned in case of an error when
using these specific methods
that are implemented in this standard
Library
so as you can see we want here to
implement the from trade for different
error kinds from this standard library
and we want to convert that to our
custom error type CLI error
so let's see over here we have the
function open and pause file it takes a
file name as argument
and it returns a result and we will
cover results so a result basically says
in case of
success it will return a result with i32
and otherwise CLI error
so then we call the read to string
function and as you can see this is
defined in the fs module FS is used for
file manipulation
and we provide to this function over
here the file name
now we pass a reference because this is
defined in the documentation of this
function we are here using the question
mark operator meaning in case of success
the result type that will get returned
will be unwrapped and contents will hold
a string
in case of an error it will return the
CLI error meaning the rest of this code
won't get executed and we just get acli
error instead
now
the error type returned from this
function would be IO error
so in order this error to be converted
to a CLI error we have to implement for
this error type the from trade right but
let's see what's happening here we then
take the contents meaning this string
over here that gets returned in case
this function call is successful
and we then hold over here the contents
of the provided file then we trim and
then we pause now pause could
potentially fail and parsing is
basically converting a string to an
integer value right so in case of
success we will get out an i32 in case
of error we'll get back a num pulse and
error this is defined in the num module
again we will cover error handling and
all of that don't worry this is now just
about the type conversion
and then we return an OK with the num
value here we have to wrap it in OK
because we return a result type
now let's see how we would Implement
that so again I will just go to the
documentation and copy the function
signature
like that
so we have the function signature
and then we can over here see what we
want to do so in case we get an i o
error we want to convert that to our
custom CLI error now how would we do
that let's change here
the argument to e for error and the type
would be IO error right we are
implementing it
from this type
now what we want to do is we just want
basically to pass the i o error into the
io error variant in our custom type so
we can access the variant
so we can create an instance
remember this is the syntax to access
the enum so we access CLI error and then
the io error variant
and all we do then is just passing this
IO error type
meaning we then have an instance of this
variant holding our i o error and that
means we have then implemented the from
trade for our custom type so any IO
error type can be
implicitly converted to CLI error
meaning in case this function over here
returns an IO error it will implicitly
be converted to a CLI error
let's do the same thing over here for
parse int error this would be the error
type from the parse method
so again let's change here the argument
name and the type would be over here
and then we again just access this enum
access the pause int Arrow variant
and we pass it the actual error that
gets returned
and this would mean we then create
another instance of the pause error
variant
let's see if this works
and as you can see this is compiling
meaning in case of an error over here
both these Arrow types from the standard
Library I or error and parse int Arrow
will be implicitly converted to CLI
error right
try from try into similar to from and
into try from and try into our generic
traits for converting between types
unlike from into try from and try into
are used for valuable conversions and
return a result instead of a plane value
now again we use the result type we will
cover that when there is a possibility
of an error of something going wrong
so as you can see we have here an i16
holding 256.
into trade has a method in two hence try
into has a method
try into right this is the method
defined on the try into trade so we take
this value here and call the try into
method on it
meaning this will return a result so we
match this result in case of an okay
then we unwrap the value from the result
and if it is an error then we just print
out the error over here
and
return 0.
right
so in case this succeeds then n will
hold a u8
and the value in case this fails n will
hold a value of 0. now we have seen that
when we want to convert an u8
then this would actually fail because
this is out of boundaries
but because we are here
basically error handling that means that
the program here won't actually panic
so in case this fails here which it does
then we will just assign to n the value
0 and print out the error so in this
case n would be zero
and again error handling will be our
next topic so don't worry if this seems
a little bit strange
then over here we have a tuple struct
even num and it takes an i32 type
we Implement here the try from
trade for the custom even num type
now here we have an Associated type and
we Define that it should be of type unit
type okay and then we Implement here the
try from function
so all this function basically does it
takes a value and it checks if it is
divisible by zero and then we will
return the result in this case okay even
num and inside it t value provided
otherwise if it is not divisible by 2
then we return an error holding our
unit type we have defined here as you
can see the type
in case of an error would be this
Associated type error meaning a unit
type so we have provided that over here
so then we can use the drive from
function so when we call even num and
try from 8 then this would return okay
right because 8 is divisible by two so
we would get back a result in this case
okay even num and T value we have passed
right that's what we defined here
now in case we try from a value of 5
this would return an error with a unit
type inside because again 5 is not
divisible by 2.
now with try from and try into it's
exactly the same like with from and into
when we Implement try from then try into
is automatically implemented so we can
use this try into method here directly
so we try here to convert eight into
this result right and the result in case
of success will will hold the type of
even num and otherwise a unit type like
defined over here
and in this case result will then hold
ok
even num
and the value we have passed eight
now when we call try into on 5 then this
will actually return error
and a unit type inside like we have
defined over here
let's see
and this is compiling see you in the
next topic
let's now see two more exercises and
this time we are converting a custom
type into a string
so to convert any type to string you can
simply use the two string trade for that
type rather than doing that directly you
should implement the fmt display trait
which will automatically provide
tostring and also allows you to print
the type with print line
so again
same thing like with from and into if
you implement from then into is for free
so you usually don't implement this
trade directly for a type you implement
display and you will get two string
implementation for free
so let's see we import here fmt
and we have here our custom type point
now here we are instantiating a point
so what we want to achieve here is that
when we take the point instance here we
have instantiated and converted to a
string
this should then be the output
and we can also use the format macro
here
basically just providing origin because
the format macro will automatically
convert that to a string in order to
print it out and the output will be the
same
so let's implement the display trade
here so as you can see this is the
display trade and it provides one method
now let's take it from over here
they provide here an example
and we can just copy
this over here now I remove the lifetime
it's not needed
and
let's implement the fmt
method here so as you can see the fmt
method provides here a formatter meaning
we want to write we can use the right
macro here and the right macro works
like println or format but the
difference is it will write to a buffer
in this case f
this is the formatter from the fmt
module and then
we here provide what we want to print
out
so in this case we want to print out the
point is entity values so let's do that
[Applause]
and then like in a print Ln macro we
provided the values so in this case we
want cells dot X
and self.y we want to print out
the X and the Y field
and that's basically it we have
implemented the display trade for Point
meaning our customly created type Point
can be converted directly to a string so
let's see
and this is compiling so
if we pass origin here let's see the
output
as you can see this would be the output
so we can even
manipulate how the output should look
like so instead of just so instead of
just printing out the two fields we have
even
provided the output with a whole
sentence right
this will be the last one we will be
doing we can use parse method to convert
a string into an i32 number
this is because from string is
implemented for i32 type in standard
Library
to use from string method you need to
introduce this trade into the current
scope so we have to import this
trade from the stir module
so over here we want to pause
and parsing again means converting a
string into an integer so we would here
have an i32 type of this value and over
here the same thing
now we can either annotate the type over
here or we could use the turbo fish
syntax meaning we can directly annotate
the type on the method
like that
and then because the from string trade
is actually implemented for the i32 type
we can also
call the associated function from store
let's do 20 here
so this will
convert from this string literal into an
i32 meaning this will then hold an i32
now because all of them hold i32
integers we can then do a mathematical
operation meaning we just add together
all of these values 5 10 and 20.
so to be variable will hold an i32 and
it should be equal to
and this is compiling see you in the
next topic
now we will cover error handling
anti-simples form of error handling is
to use the Panic macro Panic will print
out an error message unwind this deck
and finally exit the program now
unwinding the stack means that when you
actually execute the program then we
have seen that the local variables and
the function calls will be pushed to
this stack now when panicking that means
that the compiler will actually delete
everything step by step from this stack
memory and then exit the program
and in multi-threaded programs it will
exit the thread in which the Panic
occurs not the whole program so we don't
deal here with a multi-threaded programs
this will be another course but I just
want to mention it
so let's see exercises
as you can see we have here a function
drink which takes a string literally
if the string literal is lemonade then
we print out success
otherwise we actually want to panic
right
because we want to ensure that this line
never gets reached meaning never gets
printed out
so when we pass over here lemonade
then this will print out success and
then will panic
and this would be the output if a
program panics threat main panicked at
explicit panic and it will provide you
the line number
at which the Panic occurred in in this
case an explicit panic because we have
here called the Panic macro
common Panic cases make make the code
work by fixing all panics
so when we call here the S bytes method
on a string then it will give us back
the array holding the utf-8 bytes of
this string now we have seen that
actually the utf-8 representation of a
would be 97.
B would be 98
and C would be 99
so again if srtq doesn't match if this
does evaluate to another value then this
then assert EQ will cause a panic over
here we have a vector
and we try here to access the third
index now we only have now we only can
go to index 2 right it's the outmost
index we can provide
so let's change that
and this will then hold an i32 right
because we are accessing a specific
element
unwrap May panic when get return a none
so the get method over here will return
an option meaning it either returns a
sum with a value or a non now in this
case this would return a non because we
don't have any value at index 3. so when
we try to unwrap a non
value then we will panic
now let's hear excess index 1 for
example
then it will return a sum
two right the first element
write the element at index one
and unwrap we basically just unwrap the
inner value so
La will then hold a value of 2 of type
i32
sometimes the compiler is unable to find
the Overflow errors for you in compile
time so a panic will occur
so when we call here the production rate
per hour function with a value of 2 then
let's see we have here speed
the provided argument of type u8 and
here we have cph of type u8
now as you can see we are inside here
multiplying the speed in this case 2 by
cph
222 now this would actually result in an
overflow because
2 times 221 would be
442 right now remember an u8 can only
represent up to the number
255 so this would actually cause a panic
but what we can do is just actually
taking here a u16 and converting that to
u16 meaning when we multiply these
together then
the result of u16 will still be able to
represent the resultant number
and over here we can do the same thing
and then let's see because of the same
reason as above we have to wrap it in a
function to make the Panic occur so here
we are calling the divide function with
two arguments 15 and 0.
so to divide function takes two
arguments of type u8 and just divides it
now this would also panic because we
can't divide by zero this is a
mathematical Rule and this will always
lead to a panic so let's here divide by
1 for example
let's see if this is compiling
all right and again when we use the get
method we will get back a reference to
the value and not the actual value so
let's change that
and this is compiling
detailed call SEC by default is stack
unwinding will only give something like
this
so this would be the output if your
program panicked though there is the
reason of panic and the line of code is
showing where the Panic has occurred
sometimes you want to get more info
about the call stack
fill in the blank to display the hole
called stack tips you can find the clue
in the default Panic info so when we run
cargo run this is basically how you
execute a program you have written and
will cover that then you just provide
over here this rust back Trace equals
one environment variable and it will
then give you
detailed information about the Panic
that occurred
so over here unwinding and abort by
default when a panic accuracy program
starts unwinding which means rust walks
back up to stack and cleans up the data
from each function it encounters
but this work pack and cleanup is a lot
of work the alternative is to
immediately abort the program without
cleaning up if in your project you need
to make the resulting binary as small as
possible you can switch from unwinding
to aborting by adding below content to
cargo.com
so
we can here Define in this cargo.tamil
file and I will show you an example of
that
how Panic actually behaves so we have
two
um so we have two options here either
unwinding or aborting when choosing a
board here then the stack won't get
unwinded meaning this will then be the
responsibility of the operating system
and not of the rust compiler
alright see you in the next episode
so we have seen the option type and the
option type stands for a value that
could potentially be absent so let's now
look at the result type result is an
enum type that represents the outcome of
an operation that could potentially fail
it has two possible variants okay a
value T was found and error and error
was found with a value e and as you can
see the variance hold the specific
information
the expected outcome is okay the
unexpected outcome is error since result
is an enum the possible variance can be
matched using a match pattern and that
is what we call error handling
so let's see an example
let's again consider the divide function
we have seen before so again we can't
divide by zero meaning if the second
argument here is 0 then we should return
an error otherwise the program will
Panic now we can do here error handling
meaning we check if Y is zero right or
in this case 0.0 because the arguments
are floating Point numbers now in case y
what's the value of 0 then we return the
error variant of the result enum and we
provide it an error message all right so
in this case
we use an explicit return keyword
meaning when this returns it won't
execute any further it will directly
return the error type and stop execution
now in case Y is not 0 then we will just
divide X by Y and wrap it inside okay
because remember result is an enum
meaning we have two wrapped the
resultant value inside the variant so
that means when this function succeeds
then we will get back an F 32 right the
result of this operation and this is
wrapped inside okay because as you can
see we are returning a result type now
in case of an error we would return this
string over here wrapped in the arrow
variant
and this allows us then when we call the
function divide with two arguments
that we can then match the result we get
back here as you can see we would get
back a result type meaning the result
type has two variants either okay or
error and we can here use pattern
matching to the structure the inner
value for example this F32 into the
variable Val which we then can print out
and in case of an error we will get back
this string over here the error message
and we destructure it into this variable
here and then print it out
unwrap the unwrapped method takes as
input a value of type result and takes
out the value which is wrapped inside
okay in case of success or panics in
case of an error in case it returns an
OK variant we just take the value that
is wrapped inside
otherwise the program will panic
so you should use unwrap only if you're
a hundred percent sure that the return
variant will be okay otherwise you
should use match
and let's see the question mark operator
the question mark operator is a
shorthand way to propagate errors or
unwrap OK results
basically it's the same as unwrap but
instead of panic it returns an error it
replaces an entire match statement and
can and it can even be used in the main
function
so as you can see over here in the main
function we can Define here that main
should return a result type
and
as you can see we have here a string
holding a number then we try to parse
this string over here into an i32 type
now we have seen that the parse method
could potentially fail right if we have
here a string holding T for example the
compiler can't convert it to an i32
because it's not a valid number
so in case we get back the OK variant
remember parse will return a result if
we get back okay then we just take the
inner value and return it meaning the
inner value will then be assigned to the
number variable
in case of an error we want to return
meaning this over here won't get
executed it will return before and we
just provide the error message over here
and in this case because we are using a
function from the standard Library this
error message is actually provided right
so we just take the provided error
message and return it
and if this didn't fail it means this
will get executed and we just print out
the unwrapped number now because we
return here a result type we have to
also return an OK in case everything
succeeded now because at the end of Main
basically the end of the program has
been reached so it doesn't make sense to
return any meaningful value so we just
return a unit type like that so I've
told you that the question mark operator
actually replaces an entire match
statement meaning
this over here would be exactly the same
so let's see again we are in Main and we
return a result
now as you can see we have again a
string holding a number
then we try to parse over here and again
pause returns a result so we have to
handle the error case
now we can do that appending to it the
question mark operator
meaning
in case this succeeds
and it returns an OK with the value in
this case 10 but post as an integer then
it will just assign it to this variable
meaning number will then hold 10 as an
i32
in case this fails then it will return a
pause int error as defined in the parse
method
okay
so this over here is exactly the same
like we did over here
and when this returns an error
the following lines won't be executed
in case this succeeds then we have
number which holds 10 of type i32 then
we'll just print out the post number and
then we return a unit type because
remember we are here returning a result
meaning we have to also return OK
variant in case of success
but again because we are in Main and
this would be the end of the program we
don't return any meaningful value we
will return a unit type and there is
also a concept called type Alias so it's
basically just a way giving a name to an
existing type
so if you like to write u64 like this
then you can create a type Alias meaning
we can use the type keyword and provide
a new name for a specific type and as
you can see over here we are then using
the new type we have created here and
this would at compile time then be
replaced with the real type
and please don't confuse that with
Associated types in trades they are
different okay let's see result is an
enum to describe possible errors it has
two variants okay and error in short
words the expected outcome is okay while
the unexpected outcome is error
so let's see fill in the blanks and fix
the errors first of all we are importing
the pause and arrow from the num module
because we are using here the parse
method meaning it will in case of an
error return the parse and error
now we have here the function multiply
that takes two arguments of type string
literals okay now
as you can see we are here returning OK
meaning
the return type will be of type result
and in case of success
or let's actually wait with annotating
that let's first see what's happening
here so we are taking this string
literal and try to parse it to an i32
right so again this parse method over
here will return a result
in case of success we would have
okay
and the value that was paused so for
example when we call here multiply with
an argument of 10 for the first
parameter then we would have a parsed
number 10 right
so we would have in case of success and
I 32 here
in case of an error we would have the
parse into error
like that
and parsing terror is the error type
that is defined for this method again
this is implemented in the standard
Library so this has to comply with what
is defined there and N2 is exactly the
same
but for the second argument
then over here
we unwrap
and remember unwrap will take a result
and just unwraps the inner value so in
case we have okay
let's take the first argument 10
then unwrap we'll just unwrap the inner
value
meaning it Returns the integer i32 right
that is wrapped inside the result enum
and
then over here we are multiplying by N2
again we have to unwrap because this is
a result type
and
if this succeeds actually then we will
return an OK meaning
OK will then hold
in this case 10 times 2 will be 20 right
like that so we return an i32 in case of
success
in case of error we we will return a
pause and error because that is the
error that is defined from the parse
method
so let's see when we call multiply with
these two string literals 10 and 2 then
this should actually work right because
the compiler is able to parse these into
integers
so it will pause here and this will then
be okay
and over here we would have okay 2.
then we unwrap both of these over here
meaning we unwrapped the value from the
variant
and here are two meaning we multiply 10
by 2 and then this would be 20 and we
wrap it inside okay because we have to
return a variant of the result enum
which means that the return type over
here would be
this right
so result in case of success will hold
ok
and 20. right
now in this case this would actually
fail because the compiler can't convert
T to an integer
now we want this to actually assert to 8
so let's do here four
and this means this will get passed to
four
and this will get paused to 2 right
and then again we just multiply these
together and return it wrapped inside
the OK variant
meaning over here
we get back a result
and result will then hold ok
and eight
right now if we unwrap the result over
here then it would unwrap the inner
value
as you can see so unwrap method allows
us to unwrap the inner value so
okay 8 would be unwrapped to eight
question mark operator is almost exactly
equivalent to unwrap but question mark
operator returns instead of panic on
error
so let's see we have again the percent
error Implement multiply with question
mark don't use unwrap here
so let's see again we are taking two
arguments of type string literal right
three and four in this case
and
let's start to implement so we declare
here N1
and we take N1 string
and try to parse it into an i32
right now again we should here use the
question mark operator so we append it
after the method call here
and then we can only use the question
mark operator when the return type of
the function is a result right because
the question mark operator
in case of an error will return
the error variant and inside it the
error value so we return error a result
in case of success it should be i32 and
in case of failure it should be
dispersed in error because again this is
defined as the error return value of the
parse method now for N2 we do exactly
the same
and that means if any of these fail then
it will immediately return meaning the
rest of the function won't get executed
and a pause end error will be returned
now the question mark operator in case
of success it won't return a result it
will unwrap so for example when we pass
here 3 and this will get passed it will
return
okay and three
right and then the question mark
operator like unwrap will unwrap the
inner value
so N1 will then hold three meaning an
i32 integer
and N2 the same thing
and then all we want to do is just
returning and OK in case of success
because the return type is result
and we want to multiply N1 by N2
notice over here that I didn't have to
unwrap because we have here I 32 types
right
while over here we had to unwrap because
this held result types
you have to remember that
let's see
and of course I have to change that over
here
typo
and this is compiling
so what we had over here when we provide
Forum as a string we would have okay
four
right and then the question mark
operator unwrapistic value
and then over here we are multiplying
three by four which would be 12.
then we wrap it inside ok to comply with
the function signature
so this will then be the returned value
right
and then over here as you can see we are
calling the function and unwrap it
because we have here a result type so we
unwrapped the inner value
because this would return okay 12. and
we unwrap it meaning the inner value
gets unwrapped
let's see over here we have the file
type from the fs module and over here we
are importing some stuff from the i o
module
so over here we are opening a file
providing here to the open Associated
function the name of the file in form of
a string literal meaning this will then
return a result
and in case of success it will hold a
file right
and in case of error it would be IO
error
all right
and then we are matching f
now F holds a result meaning we must
over here handle both cases from
in case of success and in case of
failure so if it is okay then we unwrap
the inner value meaning the file and we
just assign it to f
in case of an error we return the error
wrapped inside the error variant of the
result type
right because this function over here
returns a result
all right
and then over here we are creating a new
empty string
we then take F over here and read to
string meaning the contents of this file
over here will be copied to this string
meaning s will then hold basically the
contents of the file we have opened
and we have to provide here a mutable
reference because this is defined in the
standard Library
and then again because this read to
string method returns a result we have
to match it so in case of okay then we
will return over here
a string right this string s over here
in case of error we will return the
error
and both of them
file open and read to string return an i
o error all right
now over here fill in the blanks with
one code line don't change any code
lines
as you can see we have here the function
read File 2 which returns a result in
case of success it's a string in case of
error it will be the i o error from this
standard Library we here declare a new
string
and we here initialize a new empty
and
I told you that the question mark
operator replaces a whole match
statement
so we can write all of this in one
single line so first of all we are
opening the file so let's take this
and as we've seen open will return a
result so we can use the question mark
operator here to replace this whole
match statement
so in case of error it will immediately
return and it returns this error type
in case of success then
we will get OK and a string and this
will then unwrap it to the string right
and in case of success we will have
a value of type file like we saw over
here and again file is a type defined in
FS module
so
we have seen that the question mark
operator will then unwrap we will
basically get something like that
and it will unwrap the file inside the
OK variant
what we then can do is call the read to
string method on it right
so we are calling read to string and
then again we have to append this
question mark operator because we need
to string also returns a result type
right so in case of success we'll then
over here mutate s meaning the contents
of this file will get read to this
string all right or written to the
string
and then we just return s right the
string and that means in case of success
we will have as return type a result
that is holding a string in case this or
this fails then it will return an i o
error meaning if this fails then over
here a i o error gets returned and this
will never be executed
and if this fails again we return this
error and this will never get executed
let's see
this is compiling
map and then map and then are two common
combinators for result t e also for
option t
so we have over here the parse into
error fill in the blank in two ways map
and then
so we have here the function at 2 taking
a string literal and returning a result
in case of success holding an i32 in
case of error parse and error all right
because this is the default error type
of the parse method
then we are taking this then we are
taking this string literal and try to
parse it to an i32
and then as you can see when we provide
here at 2 with a string holding four
then we want to get back six
so as you can see when we provide four
we will get back 6 over here and that
means we want to parse this string and
then add 2 to the post number and for
that we can use map which is really
convenient
because we not only want to handle this
result case but also then
modify the value right so
n here takes a closure and we will cover
closures very soon so we provide here an
argument n and n would then hold the
parsed number and all we do is adding 2
to n
right
and that's all so
let's actually see the map
method in the documentation
as you can see maps a result te to
result u e by applying a function to a
contained okay value leaving an error
value untouched
so
when we call the map over here
it will perform it will apply a function
if
this method returns an OK value if it
returns an error then it will leave it
untouched
all right so in this case this would
actually succeed right so pause over
here will pause this 4 into an i32
integer meaning it will then take the OK
value
and unwrap it so n will then hold A4 and
then we just add
and
and then we just add 2 to 4.
right
let's see
and this compiles now the second
approach would be using and then
now and then is very very similar to map
the difference is here
in the
closure that the end then method takes
so let's go back to map here
so over here you can see this is the
argument for the closure right and the
closure over here returns
directly the value
all right and over here it will the
closure itself will return a result
now both of these methods return results
over here
but the difference is in the closure and
you will see what I mean when we are
looking at this
so
this is very similar
it will take this past integer and then
put the unwrapped value into n and then
over here we add 2
to 2N now we have seen that map would
work like that
and and then method will actually return
in the closure itself a result so we
have to wrap that into ok
like that but otherwise they are exactly
the same
and this succeeds
number five with the return type we
written we can use pattern matching
without unweb but it's all verbose
so here again we have the multiply
function taking two string literals in
case of success it returns an i32
otherwise parse and error
so over here we are using the match
keyword now we want to pause the first
string literally the first argument in
case of okay then we destructure it into
T variable N1 so N1 will then hold the
parsed number in case of an error we
just return the error type
then we match inside this
[Music]
match arm over here again so we match
the second argument parsing it and if
this is okay then we get out and two all
right and then we can multiply N1 by N2
and return the result wrapped in the OK
variant
because as you can see the function
returns a result type
and in case of an error it just returns
an error
so this would be very verbose so
rewriting multiply to make it succinct
you should use both and then and map
here
so let's see
we take first of all the n one star over
here the first string literal all right
then
we want to parse it
to an i32 integer right
and let's then use and then
so if this succeeds then we will have
here n which holds the past integer
right and let's actually
write it more beautiful like that so we
take then n
or let's call it or let's call it N1
just to make a distinction
and then over here we want to parse the
second one
right we want here the second one
and then if this also succeeds we want
to multiply N1 and the post and two
together so let's use a map here
and we would here have N2 right because
map over here is called upon the parse
method so we would then get back and two
and then we just return
N1 times N2 and notice because we are
using map here we don't have to wrap it
inside okay right
so this will then return
for example when we call it by 10 and 2
it will return 20.
all right
and
and then we have seen that it will
return the result type so in case of
success it it will return okay with an
i32 value inside otherwise it will
return a pause end error let's see
and this is compiling so as you can see
when we are calling the multiply
function with
with 10 and 2 as string literals it will
pause the first argument meaning we then
have over here
okay 10. right
and then over here we call the end then
Method All right so we take this N1
value here
basically unwrapping it
and inside and then we parse the second
number so in this case two right so this
will then get parsed into an i32 and we
then can map meaning we have N2 over
here and two in this case would be okay
2 right
and map will take an unwrap the value
inside OK meaning we then have N2
which holds two
over here and then we multiply N1 by N2
and return it all right
and all we then do is here The Returned
value would be of this type right
and in this case this would return
okay 20.
right because it could parse these two
numbers and it multiplied it and
returned it so we get okay 20 then we
pass that to the print function
as you can see it takes as an argument a
result type then we match it if it is
okay then we print out the
value wrapped inside okay in this case
20 otherwise we will print out the error
and when we call multiply with an
argument that can't be paused
then you would get a pause int error
right so this would then hold a percent
error we are providing that 2D print
function and then we match the argument
this TT and this will then match the
error meaning the error will get printed
so in the first one so in the first
print call n is 20 so we have
successfully paused these two numbers
and unwrapped the value printing it and
in the second one because we provide
here an argument that can't be paused we
get
and pause into arrow and this would be
the error message that is provided in
this standard Library
so type Alias using this type over here
everywhere is verbose and tedious we can
use Alias for this purpose so at a
module level creating aliases can be
particularly helpful errors found in a
specific module often has the same error
type so a single Alias can succinctly
Define all Associated results this is so
useful even the standard Library even
supplies one IO result
so as you can see we have here again the
pulse and error and we want here to
create a type alias
now we have here the same multiply
function we have seen above so I won't
cover that anymore but the return type
is defined as res i32
and the print function over here takes
as an argument a type of rice i32
now as you can see exactly the same
functions as we had over here
but we don't write out the whole type we
use here A type Alias so we can Define
that here
we use res
i32 and we want to Define that as a
result
in case of success holding an I30 tool
in case of an error
as you can see the parse method would
return a parse and error
and then instead of writing that all the
time in our functions we can use this
simple type alias
and of course at compile time
these type aliases will then get
replaced with this
concrete type here
let's see
and as you can see the same output as
before
using result in F and Main typically the
main function will look like this
however main is also able to have a
return type of result if an error occurs
within the main function it will return
an error code and print a debug
representation of the error debug trade
the following example shows such a
scenario
so as you can see we have here again the
percent error and we Define here in the
main function that the return type
should be of type result in success
returning a unit type in case of error
it will return a parse and error so over
here we have a string literal
and we are then trying to parse this
string literal to an i32 now again pulse
returns a result so we have to handle
both cases in case of ok we just take
the wrapped value and assign it to
number right in this case this would
hold an i32
in case of an error it will just return
the error and it will stop execution
from this point
and then all we do is we will print out
the number so let's see if this is
compiling
as you can see this is compiling we are
printing out the number and don't forget
because we return a result type here we
have to return
the result variant okay with a unit type
in case of success we provide here a
unit type to the OK variant because
the end of main means the end of the
program because the end of main means
the end of the program so we don't have
to actually return anything here right
because if the program ends this
returned value won't be beneficial but
we can just provide the unit type so we
comply with the function signature
and by the way as we've seen we can here
just use the
question mark operator so we can replace
this match statement by this
and this is actually the reason most
people use here in main the result type
because then it allows us that we use
the question mark operator otherwise if
we didn't have result here we can't use
this operator
let's see
of course I have to remove the match
keyword here
and as you can see this would be the
same thing
all right see you in the next topic
let's take a look at cargo now cargo is
the official package manager and
building tool in Rust it helps automate
tasks such as creating new projects
building running testing code and
managing dependencies a crate is a
compilation unit of rust source code so
basically a crate is the smallest amount
of code the RAS compilers considers at a
time and crates.io is the repository for
rust packages
so as you can see this is the website of
crates.io and here you find
some libraries for example we have here
the rent Library
and this allows for creating random
numbers
and as you can see you can add this very
quickly into your own project and we'll
see how this will work
what is a crate a crate can be of two
types either it's a binary crate and
that means the program is compiled into
an executable binary it's basically a
program you can run and binary crates
always have the main function in it
and a library create a library create is
compiled into a library and it doesn't
contain a main function but it's
considered a collection of reusable code
that can be shared across multiple
projects
and the create route is the source file
that is the root module of the crate in
binaries it would be source main.rs and
in libraries it would be the file lib
dot RS
then we have modules and a module is a
way of organizing code by grouping
together related items modules can be
imported using namespaces avoiding
naming collisions
it also controls the privacy of its
items like functions trucks enums and so
on when compiling the compiler starts
from the create route we have seen in a
binary crate this would be in main.rs
and in a library it would be lib.rs
then it checks if the modules are
declared and looks for sub modules
sub modules could be directly written in
line with curly braces it could be
written in a separate file which has the
module name ending in dot RS or it could
be in a separate director which has the
same name of the module and a mod.rs
file inside it and we'll do exercises
and you will see how that works so in
case you want to follow these exercises
you actually have to install rust on
your system so you can go to
rosslang.org
and then you can click install
and over here it will give you a command
you can copy
then running a terminal
and you can just copy
this into your terminal now I'm on a
Unix like operating system meaning
I will use the Linux command but the
website will recognize your operating
system and provide the appropriate
command so if you're on Windows it will
give you a command that you can paste
into Powershell for example
so proceed with installation default you
can then press 1 and enter now I have
already
downloaded that so I want
um run it again
and then to check if everything is
installed correctly you can use these
commands
first of all we check is the RAS
compiler installed if you get back a
version it means everything is installed
then we check for cargo
[Applause]
this is fine and rust up
and rust up is used for
um updating the version of rust on your
local system
all right
all right so let's now see the exercises
a package is a project which you create
with Cargo in most cases so it contains
a cargo.tomel file in it
so create a package with below layout
now I will do that directly in the home
directory but you can do it at any
location you want
so
to create a new package we can use cargo
new
and then provide the name of the package
so we want the name here to be hello
package
and as you can see that we
and as you can see the package has been
created so let's C CD hello package and
we are now inside our created package
right so we have here cargo Tamil and a
source directory let's see source
and if I print out the contents in main
as you can see it contains a simple
program
that prints out hello world
so
let me actually
do it like that
so over here if I now do A3 command
as you can see we have exactly the same
file structure here we have a cargo
Tamil and then resource directory with
main.rs inside
let's print out the cargo toner
and as you can see this matches the file
in the exercise
create a package with below layout
so over here we want to create a library
so I'm back in my home directory and we
can create the library create right now
let's do Park on you then the package
name here
and then we have to write the lib flag
right so this will then create a library
and then let's CD into that
as you can see we have corgotomel and a
source directory
now
let me print out the cargo thermal file
and as you can see again this matches
and if we go to the source directory
as you can see over here we have a
lib.rs file and this just has a basic
add function over here together with
some tests
all right
fill in the blank with your answer
what's the difference between package
number one and package number two
now the difference would be package
number one is a binary crate
and package number two is a library
crate
all right
create a crate is a binary or library to
create rules
the create route is a source file that
the rascompiler starts from and makes up
the root module of the crate
in package hello package there is a
binary create with the same name as the
package hello packet and source main.rs
is the create root of this binary crate
similar to hello package hello package
one also has a crate in it however this
package doesn't contain a binary crate
but a library crate and source lib.rs is
the great root
so what's the name of the library crate
in package hello package one the answer
would be it would be hello package one
right because as we've seen over here in
the package hello package there is a
binary crate called hello packet
and that means in a package hello
package one
the name of the library crate would be
hello package one and by the way a
package is what we have seen over here
basically
when we create a new project right when
we create a new project we create a new
package and the package consists of a
cargo.tomel file and a source directory
together with other stuff
add a library create for hello package
and describe its files 3 below
alright so we want to add in the hello
package
a library crate
so let me remove this over here
and we will go inside hello package
now over here in this Source directory
we want to create a new library create
as you can see we have until now a
binary crate so let's create
a lib dot RS touch is a Linux command
that allows to create a new file
so then we would have lib RS and Main RS
so when we look at T3
as you can see we then have the cargo
terminal The Source directory and two
crates one Library crate and one binary
crate
so this will then hold lip.rs
and main.rs
after this step there should be two
crates in package hello package a binary
crate and a library crate both with the
same name as the package
a package can contain at most one
Library crate but it can contain as many
binary crates as you would like by
placing files in Source bin directory
each file will be a separate binary
crate with the same name as the file so
create a package which contains three
binary crates hello package main one
main two one Library create
so what we want over here is to have in
this Source folder the lib.rs
and main.rs
then inside the source folder we want to
have a bin directory which holds main 1
and Main two
right
so
so as we've seen we can have as many
binary crates as we want in a package
but only one Library create
and over here we have some other
directories so we have tests for
integrated tests benches for Benchmark
and examples
so let's create these over here
so as you can see inside source we
already have a library crate and a
binary crate now we want to create a new
directory
called bin
then we see the into bin and we create
main1.rs and main2.rs
so again when we go to the
root of the package as you can see we
have cargo terminal The Source directory
we have inside the source directory a
bin directory holding two binary crates
main one main two and we have in the
source directory
lib.rs and main.rs
yep as you can see the above package
structure is very standard and is widely
used in many rust projects
so let's see modules modules let us
organize the code within a crate into
groups for readability and ease of reuse
module also controls the privacy of
items which is which is whether an item
can be seen by outside code public or
it's just an internal implementation and
not available for outside code private
we have created a package named hello
package in previous chapter and it looks
like this now we actually created over
here a bin directory so let's delete
that
I go into source and then remove the bin
directory
so as you can see T3 looks exactly the
same
now it's time to create some modules in
the library create and use them in the
binary crate let's start
so as you can see we can
Define some code in the library create
and then use it in the binary crate
so Implement module front of house based
on the module tree below
so in the library create we want to
create a module front of house
and this should then hold two sub
modules hosting and serving now hosting
holds two functions and serving holes
for functions
so as you can see
we will do that in the library crate all
right
and again modules allow us to structure
our code
so
[Applause]
let's open lib.rs and I will copy this
over here so we have to implement front
of house
now we have seen that front of house
module should contain two sub modules
namely hosting and serving
like that so we have a front of house
module that contains two sub modules
hosting and serving
now we want to add these functions over
here add to wait list and see it at
table in the hosting module
uh
at waste list
adds to wait list
and
see it at table
so as you can see front of house
containing one sub module hosting
holding two functions over here
now let's see serving
I will just copy that
like that and
doing it like that as you can see it is
serving module holds three functions
and when we run the code actually
we can use the cargo run command
and as you can see this is compiling but
it gives us warning that we didn't use
these functions over here which is okay
and of course hello world will get
printed from the binary crate
right because main just prints out hello
world
let's call add to waitlist from a
function eat at restaurant which is
within the library create route
so inside lib.rs
we are below
the module front of house we are
creating a new function
like that call add to wait list with
absolute path
so it's like in a file system you can
have absolute paths and you can have
relative paths so in this case we want
to use the absolute path to the add to
wait list
function over here
so we would use for the absolute path to
create root
then we want the front of house module
and we want the sub module hosting right
and then over here we can call the
function like that add to wait list now
this would be considered the absolute
path
now over here we are using the relative
path so we are actually already in the
create route right so that means we
don't need to use crate here we can
directly access front of house
hosting
and then call the add to wait list
function
now as you can see it gives me here an
error
module hosting is private so we can make
this public using the pub keyword all
right
now the same thing with the functions
let's make them public
like that
you can use super to import items within
the parent module
so
again in lib.rs we want to create
another module so let's copy that
put it below the front of house
and as you can see over here we have the
back of house module with two functions
declared inside it
so we have fixed incorrect order and
inside this function we call the cook
order function over here
fill in the blank in three ways using
keyword super using absolute path
so in order to access the function over
here serve order let's first use this
super keyword so super means we go one
level up right so we are here inside the
module back of house we go one level up
which would be the create route right
lib dot RS so we use super
and then we can access front of house
and I guess hosting
no serving and serve order
like that and again serving is private
let's do that
let's make it a public function
and again serving here is private so
let's make that public
and also the function here
like that
and the second way would be using
absolute path so again you can use here
create right create would refer to
lib.rs because it is the great root of
this package
separating modules into different files
so
as you can see we want to put these
modules into their own distinct files
please separate the modules and codes
above into files resident in below third
three
so as you can see we have here Main and
leap RS crates and here we have the
modules we want to split up so we have
the module front of house
holding hosting and serving this r sub
modules and mod.rs and we have over here
back of house.rs now we have said that
there are three ways to declare modules
right the first way would be in the
create route for example lib.rs we
Define
in module and put it right inside the
curly braces right all the code is
inside these curly braces right the
second way would be
two
in lib.rs
declaring the back of house module but
without curly braces right only
declaring like this for example
only declaring the module
and that means the compiler will then
check
is there in Source directory a file
named as the same name as we gave it to
the module right so we declared a module
in lib.rs and then we have to create a
file ending in dot RS with the same name
as the module we have declared
and the Third Way would be if we want
the module to be a subdirectory of
source then we have to again declare
front of house inside lib.rs the same
way we did before
but we create a directory instead of a
file with the same name as the module
and then very important
the code of the module will then be in
mod.rs now in our case we are declaring
in
mod.rs2 sub modules hosting and serving
all right
so we want to have this code separated
in different files and this is how it
should look like
so let's start
with back of house
all right
I will copy that
and first of all
I will delete anything in here
and let's declare the module back of
house
right
now we have here declared a module as
you can see the file is not found so we
can here declare
and
back of house
dot RS
and then we can put
and then we can put the code of the back
of house module directly into this pack
of house file removing this over here
because we have already declared
T module and as you can see back of
house file now contains
only the code related to this module
again we have in lib.rs
declared the back of house module then
we have over here created a file that
has the same name as
the module right and in here we are
providing the code
like that
and because we have already declared the
back of house module we don't have to
redeclare it inside here right
now as you can see we also want front of
house now the difference is front of
house should be a directory holding two
sub modules
so let's first of all
in lib
we want to declare front of house module
like that
then we create the directory with the
same name as the module
foreign
like that
then the first thing is we create a file
mod.rs this is now
the create root of this this will be
considered the root of this module
mod.rs
and as you can see we want here inside
front of house two sub modules hosting
and serving let's declare them
like that
and then we can create both of these
files let's start with hosting
and we just take all the code from the
hosting module here
like that and let's create serving
and we just take the code here from this
serving module
like that
let me remove the comment
so
and now if we go back
to the source directory
as you can see we have back of house
this is a module we have front of house
hosting and serving these are two sub
modules and we have here
mod.rs exactly like we wanted here now
over here by the way
this function eat at restaurant will be
directly in the lib.rs
so as you can see instead of defining
the module and putting all the code in
curly braces meaning inline
we can use
um different files to restructure and
reorganize our code and this makes the
lib.rs file much more clean and readable
assessing code in library create from
binary crate please ensure you have
completed the fourth exercise before
making further progress you should have
below structures and the corresponding
codes in them when reaching here
so we have done that
now we will call a few Library function
now we will call a few Library functions
from the binary crate
so let's copy that into the binary crate
like that now we want to call a function
so the output should be sit down please
and then a second function which returns
yummy yummy now
as you can see over here
we have to call the eat at restaurant
function
to get back yummy yummy and sit down
please would be in the front of house
module in hosting and seat at table
function so let's see first of all I
want here the module front of house
right because the binary crate and the
library create are separate from each
other so the binary crate over here
can't know what is defined in the
library crate
and then over here we can SD create
module
and then here we can use an absolute
path providing the create route now we
have to actually provide here
the name of the crate meaning hello
package all right
and then we can call font of house
and
let's see
front of house hosting seat at the table
at table
like that
and then over here we call hello package
and then eat at restaurant
this is defined in our
lib.rs so again instead of writing here
a crate
we write the name of the package because
we are here in the binary crate so we
can use the create keyword in lib.rs but
in main.rs we have to write the name of
the package
let's run that
and as you can see we have some errors
module serving is private
and module hosting is private
so to actually access that
from the binary crate we have to make
them public
so let's see
first of all we go to lib.rs and we want
these two modules to be public so let's
make them pop like this which means that
these two modules are now accessible for
our binary crates the main.rs file then
let's go to
um front of house
and let's here make these two modules or
these two sub modules also public
like that
and
if the module itself is public that
doesn't mean that the inner functions
for example or structs or anything that
is inside the module is also public so
we have to declare here as you can see
this is already done that these
functions are also public if we want to
access it
and as you can see serving also has the
public functions
now let's check again in lib.rs because
we are calling here a function all right
this is also public
let's run it again
and as you can see this is actually
compiling it just over here
and complaints that we didn't use some
of the functions which is okay at the
moment
now instead of just assorting let's
actually print that out
and let's do it like that
as you can see the output will be sit
down please
let's call the second one
so we want to get this
like that
let's see
all right
I copied here the holy uh
I copied here the whole assert
we don't need this actually let's see
and as you can see the output will be
sit down please and yummy yummy
so we have successfully restructured and
reorganized our whole code into
different files and folders meaning it
is much more organized and much more
readable
all right see you in the next topic
we will now take a look at the debug and
display trades so types which want to be
printable must Implement either debug or
the display trades
and automatic implementations are only
provided for types in this standard
Library so this doesn't apply to our
customly created types
a debug trade can be implemented by
simply using derivable trade
and a display trade must be manually
implemented
let's see
we have here print Ln and format
printing is handled by a series of
macros defined in standard format some
of which include format write formatted
text to string
print same as format but the text is
printed to the console print Ln is the
same as print but a new line is appended
ePrint is the same as format but the
text is printed to the standard error
and e-print Ln same as e-print but a new
line is a pendant
all parse text in the same fashion
all porous text in the same fashion as a
plus rust checks format correctness at
compile time
so let's see we have here a string
literal
and we use here the format macro meaning
the return type will be string
and we want here s to hold a string of
hello world
so again we use the format macro like we
would use the print L and macro we have
been using so in this case we want to
take S1 over here
and then just append the rest
so we take hello this will be placed
here and then the rest
and this is compiling
let's actually print that out
as you can see this would be the output
when printing out s
print print Ln fill in the blanks to
make it print a hello world I am and
turn on the new line Sun face
so over here we want to use print
because as you can see I am should be on
the same line
so as we've seen print macro doesn't
append a new line character
now a new line is defined in C
like that all right and this is a symbol
that the compiler knows that it should
treat it as a new line but in this case
print doesn't append it so the next line
will be on the same line as this print
statement
so let's use here print Ln
because as you can see after I am we
want to have a new line
and then over here we can again use
print Ln
and this would be the output
debug and display so all types which
want to be printable must implement the
standard format formatting trade debug
or display
automatic implementations are only
provided for types such as in this
standard Library all others have to be
manually implemented
let's first look at debug
the implementation of debug is very
straightforward all types can derive the
debug implementation this is not true
for display which must be manually
implemented
and we have used that before this is the
debug notation must be used to print out
the type which has implemented the debug
trade
so as you can see over here we have a
custom type
this structure cannot be printed either
with display or debug to make this
struct printable with debug we can
derive the automatic implementations
provided by rust
so again we can use a derivable trait
meaning this struct over here implements
the debug trade meaning we can print it
out using debug notation
so fill in the blanks and fix the errors
as you can see we have here a custom
type structure holding an i32 value
types in standard and rust have
implemented the debug trade
so as you can see this is of type i32
now all of the types in the standard
Library have implemented debug or even
display so we can use here
to display notation
and this will print out fine now over
here we must use debug notation
because this is a type that we have
created and again to use the debug
notation we have to derive the debug
trade
like that
and that means structure implements the
debug trait and we can then print it out
so this i32 type will be printed
automatically because it's a type
defined in this standard library and
over here we just had to derived debug
trade and then use debug notation here
so format debug definitely makes one
type printable but sacrifices some
Elegance
maybe we can get more elegant by
replacing this notation with something
else but not this
alright let's see we have here
a custom type that derives the debug
trade
then we are here instantiating it
and when we now execute the program
as you can see the output will be like
this now we want the output to look
something like that and we can for that
use the pretty notation
just adding this hashtag symbol between
the colon and the question mark
and then the output should look much
more pretty
as you can see the output will then be
like this
and notice we first had to derive the
debug trade in order to print it out
using debug notation
we can also manually Implement debug
trade for our types
so as you can see we have here two
custom types structure and deep
now structure holds a type of i32 and
depos a type of structure meaning
these are basically nested so we have
keep
which holds a structure
which holds an i32 right
the problem with derive is there is no
control over how the results look what
if I want
what if I want this to just show A7
so as you can see we are here
instantiating it with a value of 7. now
when we print it like that then as you
can see the whole structure will get
printed out but we only want tip value
over here
so what we can do is we implement the
debug trade manually meaning we can
manipulate the output
so let's see the debug trade in the
documentation and as you can see this is
the debug trade as defined in this
standard Library so let's copy this
function signature
so we can then over here implement the
debug trade
and this is found in a module M and this
is inside the module fmt from the
standard library and we want to
implement it for the Deep over here now
we remove that
and we also remove that because we are
implementing debug trade manually right
we don't need the derived implementation
so let's see deep
then I will copy the
function signature
so here we can use a custom type fmt
result
and you know what we can use a namespace
here
so then we don't have to write here
standard all the time
like that I can delete this lifetime
and now we can implement the debug trade
namely this fmt method
so again we want to write to a buffer so
we will still write macro
and it should write to this formatter
which is provided by the debug trade
and then over here all we want to
actually print out is
in this case self right the instance
over here
and then we access the first element so
when we access the first element in a
tuple we use the dot notation like that
and inside here we have now accessed
structure and we want to access
this value this structure
struct holes right so we again use zero
and that's basically it now it should
print out
and of course over here
fmt formatter this is also from the fmt
module and as you can see now 7 will
print
so all we did over here is manipulating
how the output of the debug trade looks
like when we use debug notation
and as you can see we have defined for
the Deep custom type over here how the
output should look like so the output
will just be the inner element of deep
and structure right this i32
and we just access that and write it to
this buffer
all right
display here debug is simple and easy to
use but sometimes but sometimes we want
to customize the output appearance of
our type this is where display really
shines unlike debug there is no way to
derive the implementation of the display
trade we have to manually implement it
another thing to note the placeholder
for display is this and not that so this
would be for debug trade for display we
are using that and you know that already
so make it work as you can see again we
are using the fmt module and we have a
custom type 0.2d holding two fields of
type f64.
now we want to implement the display and
the debug trade for this custom type
meaning when we instantiate this point
2D
then we can pass the instance over here
and it will
give us this output right so we are
using here the display notation and
debug notation
and as you can see we can here Define
different outputs
so when we pass an instance of point
then the display trade actually will
output something like that
if we use debug notation then we want
the output to look something like that
and that's what I mean when I say we can
manipulate how the output of a custom
type will look like
so
I will
take over here this
method
and I will just copy it over here
now let's first implement the display
trait as you can see we want the output
to look something like that so we Define
here
lay
the X field the value of x field and
then plus the value of the by field and
we have here an i okay
like that
and we can access these fields using
normal notation self
dot X and cell dot y
right
and for debug notation we want the
output to look something like that so
let's copy this
put it inside here
and as you can see we want here
the value of the X field and here the
value of the Y field
and as you can see we are here using
curly braces and this is usually for the
placeholder so what we have to do here
is using two of them meaning this
calibrases over here will basically be
escaped all right
and then over here we have to provide
the arguments self.x and self dot y
let's see
and this is compiling now let's see the
actual output
[Applause]
as you can see I'm using display
notation and debug notation and just
provided an instance of the point to the
type
and as you can see this will then be the
output
so question mark operator implementing
fmt display for a structural whose
elements must be handled separately is
tricky the problem is each right
generates a fmt result which must be
handled in the same place
fortunately Russ provides the question
mark operator to help us eliminate some
unnecessary codes for dealing with fmt
result
so
let's see again we are using the fmt
module and we have here a custom type a
struct list
a tuple struck list holding a vector of
i32 elements right over here we are
instantiating this list with a vector
holding one two three
now as you can see when we put this
list over here into the format macro
then we want the output to look
something like that so we want to print
these square brackets the index colon
and then the actual value
now let's see how this would be
implemented notice over here we are
implementing the display trade so we can
then use it to display the type directly
so as you can see this is the function
signature from the fmt module
and
as you can see over here we return a
type of fmt result now this is a third
now this would be a type Alias and we
have covered that
now over here
we want to extract the value using Tuple
indexing and creating a reference to
back
so the first thing we do is we want to
access the vector in the list struct and
we do that using Tuple indexing right we
want the first element because there is
actually only one element on here
so we access that meaning we'll get back
a reference to a vector
holding i32
types right
here we are taking a reference
now then we have basically unwrapped
this Vector into this variable
now as you can see we use the right
macro to write to this buffer this
square bracket
because as you can see this is what we
want to Output
so the first thing added to the buffer
will be this square bracket then iterate
over V in vac while enumerating the
iteration count in count so we take this
vector and we iterate over it and
enumerate meaning we will get back a
tuple holding the index and the actual
value
then for every element except the first
add a comma use the question mark
operator to return on errors
so as you can see if count is not equal
to zero
meaning if it is in fact the first
element then we don't add this comma all
right because we don't want to look
something like that
so this is only after the second
iteration that this comma will be added
and then we write the actual value over
here
and this iterates three times right for
each element and then in the end it will
put into the buffer this square bracket
so when we run that
as you can see the output would be
something like that
but this is the output that we want
so what's missing over here is we didn't
include the indexes right so what we can
do over here
we want here to be the index and then a
colon like here and a space and then the
value so we have the index in this count
variable so let's use that
and again we can then
run the program
and this succeeded so let's actually
print that out
as you can see this would be the output
so we can really manipulate the output
of our custom types using the debug and
the display trades and by the way as you
can see we are here using the question
mark operator because this over here
could potentially fail right
that's why we are using this here and
we use here the result type from the fmt
module just in case any of these
operations here fail
alright see you in the next topic
so let's take a look at lifetimes now
lifetimes are only necessary when
dealing with references and even then
most of the time the compiler can
actually infer the lifetimes and we
don't have to worry about it so let's
see
a lifetime is another kind of generic
ensuring that references are valid as
long as needed
every reference has a lifetime which is
the scope for which the reference is
valid
most of the time this is implicit and
inferred so we don't have to worry about
it
sometimes though lifetime annotations
are needed and that's the case if the
compiler can't infer it and lifetime
annotations is a concept which most
other programming languages don't have
so even for experienced programmers this
sometimes looks a little bit confusing
but in actuality it's a very simple
concept and you will understand it very
quickly
so
actually the main aim of lifetimes is to
prevent dangling references also called
dangling pointers
so let's see we are here in Main and we
declare a variable R we don't initialize
it with a value but just declaring it
meaning
the compiler will actually infer a
lifetime of a for this variable and the
lifetime a in this case is valid until
the end of the main scope right
then over here we have an inner scope
and in this scope we are initializing
variable x with a value of 5. so the
compiler will annotate this variable to
be of Lifetime B
and as you can see lifetime B is only
valid until the end of this scope
now then we are assigning a reference to
x to the variable R meaning the variable
R we have declared here holds a
reference to the variable X
the problem here is that when X goes out
of scope at this point then R Points to
something that is not valid anymore
right and that's the aim of references
to avoid exactly this scenario
now to understand lifetimes you have to
understand the borrow check or in Rust
so the borrow Checker Compares Scopes to
determine whether all borrows are valid
it's a key part of Russ ownership system
it tracks lifetimes of references and
ensures that they don't violate the
ownership rules these rules ensure that
the value is not accessed after it has
been moved or freed from memory
an important a reference to a value must
never outlive the value itself
so you have to remember
especially the last line
a reference to a value must never
outlive the value itself
so when we go back here as you can see
we have here a reference to value 5. now
the problem is that this reference
outlives the value itself meaning X
holding this value we are referencing to
goes out of scope meaning the reference
on here lifts longer than the actual
value it is referring to
all right
let's see the compiler uses lifetime to
ensure all borrows are valid typically a
variable's lifetime begins when it is
created and ends when it is destroyed
so the scope of Lifetime annotate the
lifetime of I and borrow 2.
lifetimes are annotated below with lines
denoting the creation and destruction of
each variable
I has the longest lifetime because its
scope entirely encloses both borrow1 and
borrow two the duration of borrow 1
compared to borrow 2 is irrelevant since
they are disjoint
so when we look at this program here
what you see is that we have here
initialized variable I right
now this variable I over here lives
until the main scope ends
all right
basically it outlives this scope and
this scope
now over here we are assigning a
reference to I to borrow one
right so borrow one lifetime starts
and then we are just printing out borrow
one now over here borrow one will go out
of scope
but it doesn't matter because the value
itself still lives on all right
and over here the same thing we have
power 2 which holds a reference to I
meaning
that borrow 2 lives inside the scope so
we print here borrow two and then it
will here go out of scope
but again the value here lives on so the
actual value outlives
T borrows or the references
all right
example two so over here we have a
variable X
with a value of 5.
and then over here we have a reference
to X
assigned to variable r
and then we are printing out R right so
if we execute that it will compile
because again as you can see we are
declaring here the variable X in this
scope so variable X we live until the
scope ends and the same thing for the
reference to X
so the reference to X is assigned to R
meaning R will live until the end of
this scope
so the value and the borrow to the value
are both valid
all right and over here you can see the
lifetime annotations the important thing
here is that
both
the value itself and the reference to
the value or valid right the reference
here doesn't outlive the actual value it
is pointing to
annotate R and X as above and explain
why this code fails to compile in the
lifetime aspect
that's actually the example we have seen
so we are here declaring r and over here
in this inner scope
we declare a variable X and initializing
it with a value of 5. then we are
assigning a reference to X to R
the problem here is X will go out of
scope so R still points to
dislocation but this over here has gone
out of scope right so rust won't allow
you to compile this program and you will
get a compiler Arrow saying X does not
live long enough right
because
the reference to the value lives longer
than the actual value lives right
meaning the lifetime of X is shorter
than the lifetime of r
or the lifetime of X holding the value
is shorter than the lifetime of R
holding the reference to a value and
this should never happen
so lifetime annotating The Borrowed
cycle reuses explicit lifetime
annotations to determine how long a
reference should be valid but for us
users in most cases there is no need to
annotate the lifetime because there are
several illusion rules before learning
these rules we need to know how to
annotate lifetime manually
so
ignoring illusion rules and that's the
next topic lifetimes in function
signatures have a few constraints
any reference must have an annotated
lifetime any reference being returned
must have the same lifetime as one of
the inputs or be static so over here we
have a function print one
and it takes as an argument a reference
to an i32 type alright
now this is how we would annotate a
lifetime it's actually very similar to
generics but we use this apostrophe
syntax and a lowercase letter by
convention just going from a b c d and
so on
so in this case we annotate here
that the reference
that the reference here is of Lifetime a
so when we have over here a lifetime
annotation
then we can provide here
then we can annotate it here for our
reference right and again we are just
dealing with lifetimes when we are
dealing with references
so in this case we say the reference to
the i32 type should be of Lifetime a now
when we annotate that to our function it
means that
the lifetime a must at least live as
long as the function itself or we all or
we could also say lifetime a must
outlive this function so the past
reference over here must outlive this
function this is just ensuring that the
reference passed here lives longer than
this function meaning we can ensure that
this function always deals with a valid
reference right
and all we do here is printing out X
mutable references are possible with
lifetimes as well so if you would have a
mutable reference you would annotate it
like that
first after the Ampersand of course you
will always put the lifetime annotation
and then the mute keyword and then of
course the type
multiple elements with different
lifetimes in this case it would be fine
for both to have the same lifetime a but
in more complex cases different
lifetimes may be required
so as you can see we can
Define more than one lifetime over here
we have lifetime a and lifetime B
meaning the references pairs to this
function could be of different lifetime
but again
lifetime a and lifetime B must outlive
this function so the past references
over here must outlive the function
right
and returning references that have been
passed in is acceptable however the
correct lifetime must be returned
so let's take a look at the function
pass X as you can see it takes two
arguments and both of them are
references
now this would be of Lifetime a and this
would be of Lifetime B again both of
these references must outlive this
function
and we are just returning X which is
annotated with a lifetime a meaning the
return type will return
meaning the return type will be a
reference to an i32 with a lifetime of a
right this would be the type that is
annotated to the X argument here
if we would here have y and we return y
then we would do it like that right
because we are returning a reference
with a lifetime annotation of B
foreign
so as you can see we have here
two variables
holding i32 types and then we are
passing to all of the above functions T
reference to these two
variables right because all of these
functions over here expect a reference
to an i32 type
now
in this case this program will compile
as you can see this is compiling because
we have here declared X and Y in the
main scope meaning they are valid until
the end of the scope over here right so
t x and y references we pass to the
functions outlive all the functions
which is a requirement right
the best references must outlive the
function
so we don't have to deal with dangling
references
and so let's see an exercise to
understand it even more make it work by
adding proper lifetime annotation
so over here we have the function
longest that takes two arguments of type
string slice
now we then test the length of these
string slices
and if x is
and if x
is longer than y then we return X
otherwise we return y
so
if we go over here in the main function
and let's do some variables
as you can see we have two string
literals long and longer
now we would pass that to this function
over here
now
it could be possible in this case
the return type is known at compile time
but sometimes this is decided at runtime
and when we are passing these arguments
to the function over here let's do that
actually
[Applause]
and notice we don't have to pass here a
reference because string literals are
already references all right now if we
would compile that this would actually
fail right missing lifetime specifier
so what we want to achieve here
is first of all we want to add a
lifetime parameter like that
and then we want to define the lifetimes
of these references
now in this case the function over here
could either return X or Y right
depending on which argument has the
longer string
right so sometimes it might be X that is
returned and sometimes it might be y so
we can't be sure if we annotate here a
and B like that
we don't know which one will get
returned is it a or b it depends on the
arguments right
so what we can Define here is that
X and Y these two arguments have the
same lifetime meaning
these two references share the same
lifetime they must be declared in the
same scope and both of them of course
must outlive the function longest
so in this case this is what we are
providing right we are declaring X and Y
over here in the main scope so when we
call the longest function with these two
references over here it means that these
two references still live on even after
this function call all right because
again the reference of X and Y will
leave until the main scope ends
now because we have here defined that
both of these references have the same
lifetime
it is clear that the returned
string slice must have the same lifetime
either X or Y right
let's see
and as you can see this is compiling in
this case longest will return y because
it is longer than this than the X string
all right
a must live longer than the function
here reference to string Foo would
create a string followed by a reference
then the data is dropped upon exiting
the scope leaving a reference to invalid
data to be returned
fix the arrow in three ways as you can
see we have the function invalid output
we Define here a lifetime parameter a
and declare that The Returned reference
should be of this lifetime
now the problem here is we are
creating a new string and returning a
reference to it right we are returning a
reference to a string the problem is
this string was declared inside the
function now when
the function returns to the caller it
means the string over here will get out
of scope right because it is declared
inside the function
so again if we call for example
if we call this function
then we would get back
a reference to a string right the
problem is
that
the reference points to something that
isn't valid anymore this string declared
here got out of scope so X points to
something that is not valid anymore
so returning a reference to something
declared inside the function is a really
bad idea now what we can do over here to
fix that and this is probably the
easiest fix
we just return the string itself right
so then ownership will be transferred
and X will be the owner
all right let's print out X
as you can see this is working because
we are here
declaring a string
and then return it meaning the ownership
of the string will then be returned over
here right so X will become the owner of
the returns string from the invalid
function
the second way to fix that would be
returning a string literal
right
and a string literal actually has always
a static lifetime we will come back to
that but that actually means that this
reference is of static lifetime meaning
it is valid throughout the entire
program
all right because remember a string
literal is hard coded into the binary so
it lifts as long as the program lives
so then over here we will get back a
string slice right
let's see
and as you can see this is also
compiling
the Third Way would be
over here
create a string
and then we can pass this string to the
invalid output so
in this case we want here to take
a reference to a string right we can
also write it like that because remember
a reference to a string
will be automatically inferred to a
string size right
so
[Applause]
so we are then passing a reference to
this string right and what we want to
return here is s
meaning we return here a string slice
and we can annotate a lifetime parameter
and then we will print out X let's see
and this is also working because as you
can see we have defined here a string
meaning s over here is the owner of this
train then we are passing a reference of
s to this function right
we annotate here a lifetime a meaning
the reference over here passed to the
argument s must outlive this function
which it does right we have declared s
here so even after this function call S
still lives on right
and then all we do is we again return as
the past reference right so
it will actually have the same lifetime
as the past argument
all right meaning we have here then a
returned string slice
all right
Point refs takes two references to i32
which have different lifetimes A and B
these two lifetimes must live at least
as long as the function print refs so as
you can see we are here in the print
refs function declaring two lifetime
parameters one for argument X and one
for argument y again we are dealing with
references meaning
we care about the lifetimes if these
would be owned types like so
then we don't deal with references right
[Applause]
and then we just print out X and Y to
provided arguments
make it work if function which takes no
arguments but has a lifetime parameter a
so over here
we can see that we annotate a lifetime
parameter a and we have here
and i32 integer now error X does not
live long enough
so we assign to Y over here in reference
to X
the problem again is that when we
annotate this lifetime parameter it says
the lifetime a must outlive this
function
which it doesn't right because
the reference over here
because the value we are referencing to
is declared inside the function meaning
it will then be dropped at the end of
the scope
attempting to use the lifetime a as an
explicit type annotation inside the
function will fail because the lifetime
of reference X is shorter than a a short
lifetime cannot be coerced into a longer
one
so let's see in main we are here
destructuring a tuple into the variables
4 and 9 right so 4 will hold 4 and 9
will hold 9. borrows of both variables
are passed into the function
so we are then calling the print refs
function with references to 4 and 9
right
this function over here
any input which is borrowed must outlive
the borrower in other words the lifetime
of 4 and 9 must be longer than D then
that of print refs
so again when we annotate these
lifetimes on a function both of the
lifetimes must outlive
the function or both of the
references passed here must outlive the
lifetime of this function which they do
right so 4 and 9 are declared in main
scope meaning they outlive this function
over here
so this should actually work
so failed borrow contains no references
to force a to be longer than the
lifetime of the function but a is longer
because the lifetime is never
constrained it defaults to static
so
so as you can see we have here declared
the lifetime a which states that the
reference holding the lifetime of a must
outlive the function this is not the
case right because we are declaring the
value inside the function itself
now when we remove that
actually this over here will then
work all right let's see
let's see structs make it work by adding
proper lifetime annotation a type of
road which houses a reference to an i32
the reference to i-32 must outlive
borrowed
so as you can see we have here a custom
type a tuple struct holding a reference
to i32
now in this case we have to annotate the
lifetime and we do it like that
and then we pass it to the reference
like so and that means this reference
here must outlive this struct or the
instance we create from it right
similarly both references here must
outlive this structure
again we are here annotating the
lifetime and we say that both of them
should have the same lifetime which
makes it easier right
and enum which is either an i32 or a
reference to one
so as you can see again
we can annotate a lifetime basically
like a generic type parameter
and over here as you can see this
variant holds a type of i32 so the enum
will be the owner of this type we don't
care about any lifetime annotation we
only care about lifetime annotations
when dealing with a reference
like that
now let's see we have here i32 and i32
and then we are instantiating the
borrowed struct with a reference X right
so as you can see this would be the
borrowed struct and it holds a reference
2x which is i32 right
now as you can see we Define here that
reference
of Lifetime a must outlive
this struct or the instance of destruct
right so X over here must outlive this
instance which
which it does right because it again it
is declared in main scope meaning X and
Y we live until this point here
so they outlived The Borrowed struct
and over here as you can see we pass
here references to the X and Y field of
the named borrowed
a struct
so this would then be an instance now
again
X and Y in this case first of all they
are declared in the same scope so they
can have the same Lifetime right
they both live in the same scope and
both of these variables will end at the
same time
so
this will actually compile right
everything over here is safe
so as you can see we instantiate clear
the either enum
and one time with the variant ref
holding a reference to X
now again as you can see we have here a
lifetime parameter a which states it
must outlive the instance of the enum
which it does right X is valid all the
time
and the second variant doesn't hold a
reference we just pass it to single
we just pass it
T variable
now because this implements copy it's an
i32 it means that even then y will still
live on so either want to take ownership
it will take ownership of the copied
value
let's see if this is actually compiling
and this is compiling
make it work so over here we have
destruct no copy type and and over here
we have struct example and as you can
see we annotate here the lifetimes A and
B meaning over here the A and B field
could hold references that have
different lifetimes but they can also be
the same all right
now let's see in main a tight to FN main
stack frame
so as you can see we have here an i32
and over here we have declared a
variable which should be of type example
but we haven't initialized it with
values all right we haven't instantiated
the example struct now notice here we
have another scope
lifetime B tied to new stack frame so
then we have here an instance of the no
Copy Type struct
and as you can see fix me
so then we are instantiating example
with the fields over here passing it
concrete values as you can see we are
passing it a reference to Bar a this and
a reference to Bar B so the problem over
here is that VAR B will go out of scope
at this point right
meaning
the example struct we have instantiated
over here will hold the B field which
points to something that is not valid
anymore as you can see we are here
printing out example now if we would
print it out in this scope
then this would actually compile
and of course this must be your 32
because it is a u32 field here as you
can see this is compiling fine
now even though
we are here in a new scope right we have
declared Bar B here in the inner scope
but even then both of these references
are valid right
because we are here then using example
in the same scope and we have noted that
here that you that the lifetime of a and
b are different right so the lifetime of
bar a
is actually longer than the lifetime of
Bar B
right because for a lives until the end
of the main function while Bar B leaves
only until this point
but again
this is safe and this is compiling
because the VAR B we have created here
and passed a reference
to the
example struct is valid
if we leave this over here then this
wouldn't compile right because vorby
gets out of scope
and
we over here say that both A and B must
outlive example
all right so example is used here but
not all references are still valid which
would lead to a compiled error
but what we can do also is just removing
this scope here
meaning everything is now declared in
main scope so this would also compile
right because all the references to
these variables are valid
let's see here we have again struck no
copy type and the example struct we have
seen before and as you can see denoting
that the lifetimes of these references
might differ but they can be the same
it's no problem so let's see here fixed
function signature we have here the fix
me function which takes us an argument a
reference to an example instance and it
will then return
the B field from the provided argument
from the example struct right it will
return this field over here meaning a
reference to no copy type because that
is what B is holding
now over here we are instantiating no
Copy Type
and we are instantiating the example
struct
so we pass for the field a here a
reference to one
and for B we pass a reference to no Copy
Type
right
[Applause]
and then we pass a reference
this example instance over here to the
fix me function now let's first annotate
the lifetime parameter
again we do a
and over here we say
that the past reference to the example
instance must outlive this function
right which it actually does because
here we are instantiating the example
struct and passing it to a reference
and passing it as a reference to this
function meaning example over here will
live longer than the function right
and we can then Define that no Copy Type
must also outlive
this fix me function all right which it
does because again it's secured the main
meaning the end of scope will be at this
point
so both the instance of example and the
no copy type both outlive this fix me
function
and as you can see we can pass this same
lifetime parameter because they are
declared in the same scope meaning they
have the same lifetime
methods are annotated similarly to
functions so we have here destruct owner
holding an i32 type
so annotate lifetimes as in a standalone
function as you can see we have here the
implementation block for owner and we
Implement some methods for this custom
type
and this is how we would annotate
lifetime parameters again same thing
again same thing like in functions
make it work by adding proper lifetime
annotations
you have a struct important excerpt
and the port field holding a string
slice now again string slice is a
reference meaning we have here to
annotate the lifetime parameter
so that means the reference that the
port field of destruct is holding
outlives the entire struct
right
and over here we have
a method implemented for the important
excerpt struct so as you can see we are
using a lifetime parameter here but we
have to actually first declare it
like that
and that's basically it it should
compile
so when distract over here
declares a lifetime parameter we have to
declare it in the implementation block
again but we are here not using it
meaning we can do it like that right we
don't care about this lifetime parameter
here
and this lifetime parameter is declared
only on the on the method right
this is compiling but there is an easier
way actually we don't have to use any
lifetime here right
because we can Define here that
the string slice is static
meaning it will live throughout the
entire program
all right
illusion some lifetime patterns are so
common that the borrowed Checker will
allow you to Omit them to Safe typing
and to improve readability this is known
as illusion
illusion exists in Rust only because
these patterns are common
for a more comprehensive understanding
of a lesion please see lifetime illusion
in the official book
so I have prepared some slides
let's see there are three rules of
Lifetime illusion the first rule states
compiler assigns a lifetime parameter to
each parameter that's a reference
second if there is exactly one input
lifetime parameter that lifetime is
assigned to all output lifetime
parameters
third rule if there are multiple
lifetime parameters but one of them is a
reference to self or immutable reference
to self the lifetime of self is assigned
to all output lifetime parameters
so let's see an example
and
before we see the example as you can see
lifetime illusion makes writing rust
much more easy until this point we
didn't worry and care about lifetimes
and that's most of the time the compiler
just inferred it so we didn't have to
worry
now let's see here we have the function
first word taking a reference okay and
returning a reference
so the compiler applies the first rule
each parameter gets its own lifetime
so the compiler behind the scenes will
annotate here a lifetime for this
function and we'll annotate it for all
the references right
so the second rule applies because there
is exactly one input lifetime
again we have only one argument that is
a reference
so this gets assigned to the output
lifetime meaning the output reference
here must then be
the same reference right we are taking a
reference so it must be the same when we
are when we are returning a reference
so in this case the compiler could infer
the lifetime and we don't have to
specify them manually
so what the compiler will do he will
just annotate the same lifetime as for
the input argument right
so this is all inferred you can write it
like that and it will compile you don't
have to worry about lifetimes
so let's see this example we have the
function longest that takes two
references as arguments okay and it
returns one reference
first rule each parameter gets its own
lifetime so the compiler will come and
annotate
A and B each reference gets its own
lifetime all right so here the second
rule doesn't apply because there is more
than one input lifetime also the third
rule doesn't apply because this function
is not a method we have now to manually
annotate the lifetime parameters
so as you can see over here the compiler
cannot infer
The Returned reference here is it of
Lifetime a or is it of Lifetime B right
so it depends if you return X then you
would annotate a lifetime of a if you
return B then you would return then you
would annotate a lifetime of B and again
both lifet times A and B must outlive
this function
let's see an example in a method so as
you can see we have a method taking a
reference to self meaning taking the
instance as a reference and doesn't take
ownership
so here the third rule applies which
states that if there is a reference to
self then all references will have the
same lifetime as self
right so we can have here any number of
arguments all of them will take the
exact same lifetime as the lifetime of
self because this is inferred and it
makes sense right because
all of the provided arguments to a
method must actually outlive
the structure or the enum
instance
all right so all of the arguments here
take
implicitly the same lifetime as self
all right
so let's see remove all the lifetimes
that can be elided as you can see over
here we have only one input argument
and the second thing is we don't even
return anything so we don't even have to
care about
uh the lifetime because we don't worry
that it might go out of scope right but
in this case we only have one argument
meaning the compiler is able to infer
that
over here again we have only one
argument
but
as you can see the difference is we are
returning
a reference right
so
because there is only one argument here
the compiler can infer that the
reference over here must be the
reference that will be returned so we
don't have to annotate the lifetimes so
let's see over here we have the longest
function and
the first rule says that the compiler
will annotate a lifetime for each
reference meaning it will create a and b
because we have here two references
right two arguments
and
it will annotate for the first argument
a and for the second argument lifetime
of B
now over here this
the compiler cannot infer which lifetime
will get returned meaning as you can see
we are returning X so the lifetime over
here would be a right the lifetime of
the argument X
but notice both of the references must
outlive the function
right
here we have a struct owner that holds
an i32 type
annotate lifetimes as in a standalone
function
so as you can see we have here
methods implemented on the owner struct
now again when we have a mutable
reference or an immutable reference to
self then we never have to worry about
lifetime annotations because this will
get inferred by the compiler
all right all references pass to these
methods will get the same lifetime as
self
or SD reference to self
now over here we have to annotate the
lifetime because this is a struct and we
want to ensure that the reference the
name field is holding is actually living
longer than the instance of a struct
person okay and over here the same thing
let's see if this is compiling
and this is compiling what we could do
also here
we could remove that and doing it like
this all right this should actually also
work
okay we have here to specify that this
string is static in this case we have to
explicitly state it and as you can see
this is compiling so you don't have to
declare here a lifetime parameter you
can put here this static Lifetime and
static lifetimes will be our next topic
let's take a look at static lifetimes so
aesthetic lifetime refers to a lifetime
that lasts for the entire duration of
the program's execution
any reference or borrowed value with a
static lifetime can be safely used
throughout the program
and aesthetic lifetime can be coerced to
a shorter lifetime if needed
so we have seen string literals and they
are usually annotated using an ampersand
and stir but implicitly it would have a
static lifetime
so string literals have a static
lifetime because they are hard coded
into the executable meaning they are
valid throughout the entire duration of
the program's execution
let's see
static is a reserved lifetime name you
might have encountered it several times
so a reference with static lifetime is
for example a string literal and this
would be the full type annotation
static as part of a trade bound
so as you can see we are here defining a
generic type parameter and we say that
the argument provided should be of type
T now in the Vera Clause over here we
see that t must be of static lifetime
though they are all static but subtly
different
as a reference lifetime Ampersand static
indicates the data pointed to by the
reference lives as long as the running
program but it can still be close to a
shorter lifetime
there are several ways to make a
variable with static lifetime two of
them are stored in the read-only memory
of the binary
fill in the blank in two ways
so as you can see we are calling here
neat static within argument of V so
let's declare that here
and as you can see the argument must be
of type static string or string literal
all right
and then we are here checking is the
argument equal hello
so let's initialize it here
so the first way is just initializing it
like that without any type annotation
because this is simply inferred by the
compiler so any string literal is hard
coded into the binary means it lives as
long as the program's execution Because
the actual data of the string literal is
living in the binary the second way is
just annotating the full type annotation
like that
and this static lifetime annotation here
can also be omitted so we can annotate
it like this
as you can see the compiler is able to
infer the lifetime
another way to make static lifetime is
using box leak now this is an unsafe
method and I won't cover that because
it's a more advanced topic
but I have solved it and will put it on
my GitHub if you want to solve it for
yourself
static only indicates that the data can
live forever not the reference the
letter one the letter one will be
constrained by its scope
so let's see make a string literal and
print it so over here we have a string
literal meaning it's a string slice of
static lifetime
then we print it out
when static string goes out of scope the
reference can no longer be used but the
data remains in the binary so
at the end of this scope over here
this variable will go out of scope
meaning it's dropped
and that means we can't then use static
string anymore because the variable has
been dropped now even though the
variable now even though the variable
has been dropped the data over here is
actually still living on right
so this is living in the binary a string
literal is hard coded into the binary
meaning it is of static lifetime meaning
it is valid throughout the entire Pro
programs lifetime
but of course a variable is bound to its
scope
so to make that work we can
take that and copy it over here meaning
the variable static string is valid
until main ends as you can see
static can be close to a shorter
lifetime
so over here make a constants with
static lifetime so this over here is the
static keyword meaning we are here
creating a constant now constants by
conventions are always uppercase right
and by the way the difference between
conist
[Applause]
the difference between this and this now
both of them live for the entire
lifetime of the program both are of
static lifetime but the difference is
that static will always remain at the
same memory location while a const
constant will get inlined so when we use
for example num const here then it will
get inlined meaning the compiler will
basically copy that into the code in the
function so the memory location could
change but static always stays at the
same memory location
so returns a reference to num there is
static lifetime is coerced to that of
the input argument
so as you can see over here we have a
function corostatic and we have defined
a lifetime parameter a
we Define here that the input reference
should be of this lifetime a right
meaning the reference we take as an
argument to this function must outlive
the function itself
now we over here actually return
this constant right basically a
reference to this constant
and we can in this case course
the static lifetime of this num constant
to a shorter lifetime
it's no problem right
so a is shorter than static right
aesthetic lifetime is
larger than this a lifetime here meaning
aesthetic meaning a reference with a
static lifetime lives longer than a
because a only defines that it must
outlive this function right but we can
hear chorus it to a shorter lifetime so
it matches with the lifetime annotated
on the function
make an integer to use for coreostatic
so over here we make an integer
and then we pass a reference of this
integer and called the chorus static
function
meaning we here returned a reference to
an i32 right basically a reference to
the number 18.
and then we will just print out the
result of this function call right
now
as you can see we have crossed num here
to a shorter lifetime
but this doesn't change the actual
lifetime of this static constant right
so even after this scope over here
we can still access num because again
it's of static lifetime it lives as long
as the program is running
so even though we have here corrected to
a shorter lifetime it doesn't matter it
remains static right
let's see as a trade bound it means the
type does not contain any non-static
references
for example the receiver can hold on to
the type for as long as they want and it
will never become invalid until they
drop it
it's important to understand this means
that any owned data always passes a
static lifetime bound but the reference
to that owned data generally does not
so
so let's look at function printed as you
can see we Define here a generic type
parameter meaning the input meaning the
input argument here must be of type T
now this over here is a trade bound
meaning we say the type T must implement
the debug trade and
T cannot contain any reference that is
not of static lifetimes so all
references T is containing must be of
static lifetime
right
and over here we do basically the exact
same thing but using the impul keyword
right this and this is actually quite
the same
and then over here as you can see
22 takes a reference to T right
and again T must implement the debug
trade and it cannot contain any
non-static
references all right
so
I is owned and contains no references
thus it's static
[Applause]
as you can see we are here initializing
I with a value of 5 meaning I is the
owner of 5. now when we pass the owner
to a function then it would actually
comply with this function signature
because owned types are also considered
static okay
now this would actually work
because again
i32 implements debug and it is
considered static because we are passing
an owned type right
oops reference to I only has the
lifetime defined by the scope of main so
it's not static
right so the so a reference to I has a
lifetime that is defined by this main
scope
so it's not static anymore right
so this would actually
output and error right
and this would be the same thing again
print it and print it one would actually
be very similar right
now this here actually works because we
are here passing a reference to I again
right so we pass a reference to I
and again the reference to I would have
a
lifetime of this main function now the
difference is here that
in the argument we defined that
the argument should be a reference to T
meaning
if we
think away it is ampersands
I would be T right
so a reference to T would be a reference
to I
hope this makes sense
so
that means again when we pass I directly
it would be it would Implement debug and
it would be of static Lifetime right so
this over here would work
now to fix this over here we can
do it two ways we can create here the
constant I
and again constants have a static
lifetime as you can see this is
compiling
and the second thing is we can use this
static keyword meaning I is static
so this would pass because
the argument we are passing
or the references we are passing are all
of static Lifetime and they implement
the debug trade right
i32 implements debug and we have ensured
that all of them are of static lifetime
now the last one here again deals with
box leak I won't cover this but again
the solution is in my GitHub if you want
to solve it you can do that and then
compare with my Solutions
alright see you in the next one
so let's see closures a closure is an
anonymous function that is able to
capture the values from the scope in
which it is defined and if you are
coming from python then you might know
Lambda functions and in JavaScript they
are called Arrow functions
and they can be defined inline for
example as a function parameter they
don't require type annotations and they
can take ownership of a value by using
the move keyword
so all functions and closures
implement the F and trades and that is
the trait that defines the signature for
closures and functions
it describes the types the number of
arguments and the return type there are
three different traits FN ones the
closure can be called only once because
it takes ownership of the captured
values
FM mute it might mutate a captured value
it can be called more than once and FN
it doesn't take any ownership of
captured values it doesn't mutate
anything and it might not even capture
anything from its environment
so let's take a look over here we have
here initialize the variable x with a
value of 1. now over here we would have
a closure and closures are defined like
that first of all we have these symbols
over here and between them we Define the
name of the argument
and as you can see over here we just add
the argument with the value of x so as
you can see the closure here is able to
capture the value of x something a
function can't do right
and
we then assign this closure to a
variable meaning we then can call this
closure
and calling it like in normal function
so in this case as you can see we call
the closure using the variable name
closure and then providing it an
argument right
so actually disclosure call should
evaluate to 3 because we provide 2 here
meaning weld will be 2 and adding X to
it one so two plus one will be 3.
so disclosure captures the value of x
and modifies it the compiler will
capture variables in the least
restrictive manner possible
in this case immutable reference of X is
taken rather than taking ownership
because it's less restrictive
let's see closures can capture the
enclosing environments for example we
can capture the X variable that's the
example we have seen
from the syntax we can see that closures
are very convenient for on the Fly usage
unlike functions both the input and
return types of a closure can be
inferred by the compiler
so we have here a normal function as you
can see it takes an argument of type i32
and it will just add 1 to T and it will
just add 1 to the provided argument and
returns it meaning the return type will
be i32
now closures are Anonymous here we are
binding them to references
these nameless functions are assigned to
appropriately named variables
so as you can see we can here create a
closure
and this and this over here are exactly
the same so type annotations enclosures
are not required okay
and then again we assign the closure to
a variable in order so we can call it
all right over here we have a variable I
with a value of 1.
and then we are just calling the
function and these two closures with
this value over here
and a closure taking no arguments which
returns an i32 the return type is in
third
so this would be a very primitive
closure just with running one when being
called so when we call one here we will
just get back one
let's execute that
you can see when we call this function
and these two closures it will just add
one to the provided argument
and over here we are just returning one
capturing closures can capture variables
by borrowing or moving but they prefer
to capture by borrowing and only go
lower when required
so they can capture the values either by
reference by mutable reference or by
value meaning the closure will then only
type it captures okay
so let's see exercise one make it work
with least amount of changes so over
here we are initializing a variable
color with a string
so as you can see over here we have a
closure and we assign it to print so we
can then call it now this closure here
doesn't expect any arguments but it uses
the move keyword meaning the captured
values will be moved inside this closure
right
so that means the closure here will
become the owner of the captured value
this is not always the case so for
example over here a immutable reference
is sufficient because we are just
reading basically this data here we
don't mutate anything and we don't need
ownership to print something out
but as you can see printing two time
over here will cause an error right
so what we can do is we can remove the
move keyword
and color can be borrowed immutably
again because the closure only holds an
immutable reference to color
right that means when we don't move the
captured value we can then
take a reference to color again
so this foothold a reference to a string
as you can see we print here out two
times color green because we are calling
this closure two times
and this will take an immutable
reference of this captured value
all right and then we can take another
reference of this
string
so let's see exercise 2 make it work
don't use reborrow and count reborrowed
don't modify assert EQ
so we have over here an i32
by the way this is mutable and we have
here a closure taking no arguments
then as you can see it captures this
variable here all right and it mutates
it meaning count will then hold one
and then we just print out count
over here we are calling disclosure
and then we are taking a reference to
count meaning a reference
to an i32 right
and then we are again calling
this ink closure
the closure no longer needs to borrow
mutable borrow account therefore it is
possible to re-borrow without an error
so what is happening over here we have
seen that the compiler will take the
least restrictive approach so in this
case it will take an
so in this case the count variable here
will be captured as a mutable reference
right
and
that would be a problem because as you
can see we are calling Inc and over here
we call it again after you're defining
an immutable reference to count
so maybe you remember that you can
either have one mutable reference or any
number of immutable references but not
both at the same time
so this would be a problem
so we can call here the move keyword
meaning
disclosure here takes ownership of this
value now again because i32 implements
the copy trade it means
it will actually get a copy of count
so count is still accessible even after
this
closure call right the closure will just
take a copy of the value
and that means we can then take an
immutable reference again to count and
call the closure right
and over here the closure no longer
needs to borrow a mutual reference to
count therefore it is possible to
re-borrow without an error
so as you can see we are here taking a
mutable reference to count again because
we don't use this immutable borrow over
here again after this point right so
this is allowed
let's see
and as you can see this is compiling and
here you can see that count
has been modified
so let's see exercise 3 make it work in
two ways none of them is to remove take
movable away from the code
so as you can see we have here
initialized a variable with a heap
allocated i32 integer right
then over here we have a closure and we
capture here this movable variable
now
we have seen that actually the compiler
will use the least restrictive approach
so in this case because we have only a
print line it will take this variable
here as immutable reference we just need
to print it out
now over here we are calling the take
function as you can see the take
function takes an argument of any type
but it takes ownership meaning when we
call the take function
with an argument the argument will then
lose its ownership so take function will
become the owner of movable in this case
right and that means we can't call
disclosure two times
because in this case again
the compiler will try to use the least
restrictive approach but in this case
it's necessary that this closure over
here will Implement F and once so it
only can be called one time because
again over here move a bell when we call
this take function it will take movable
and take ownership of it because it's
necessary for the compiler to do that to
comply with this function signature but
what we can do is we say we want a
reference right
so again the compiler will then
implement the F and trade for this for
disclosure meaning
it can be called two times now we will
see a lot of more example of these FN
trades so don't worry
it just means now because we just need
over here immutable references the
compiler will actually capture
this
variable here as an immutable reference
right so nothing gets moved inside this
closure and movable will remain the
owner of the data
for comparison the following code has no
error
foreign
so as you can see we have again a heap
allocated integer and we have here a
closure now as you can see we use the
move keyword here
and in this case disclosure will capture
the movable variable only as an
immutable reference because we here only
print out the variable we don't need an
we don't need a mutual reference and we
don't need to take ownership so we can
call this closure two times without any
problem
type in third the following foreclosures
has no difference in input and return
types
so this is actually a function not a
closure but as you can see all of them
are exactly the same so we can skip the
type annotations and we can even skip
the curly braces if it is declared on
the same line
so this over here is exactly the same as
writing it like that
so over here we have an example closure
taking one argument and just returning
that argument so then
V over here
call the example closure with a string
meaning
over here this would be the argument
provided and it returns a string
now when you define a closure
and call it with a concrete value the
compiler will then infer the types of
the arguments and the return type so in
this case the compiler will annotate the
types like that
right we take an argument of type string
and return the string
and that means
that we then can't call the closure
again with another type
this would cause an error okay what we
have to do is to convert that to a
string
let's do it like that so we get back a
string here
and this is compiling
so let's see FN F and mute FN once when
taking a closure as an input parameter
the closures complete type must be
annotated using one of the following
trades
FN the closure uses the captured value
by reference F and mute the closure uses
the captured value by mutable reference
F and once the closure uses the captured
value by value basically taking
ownership
alright so make it work by changing the
trade Bound in two ways
so when a function accepts a closure as
an argument we have to actually
Define what will be the type of the
arguments to the closure and the return
type of the closure right
and we
over here can see that a closure
implements one of these
three trades all right
now over here in the fn1's function we
Define that the fund argument must be of
type f
and here we Define the trade bound so F
must be a type that implements F and
ones
taking as argument U size and returning
a Boolean value
all right
and
inside this function over here we are
just calling the provided func closure
and providing its arguments
so as you can see we have here a vector
[Applause]
and we call the FN ones function with an
argument of a closure as you can see we
can't pass a closure as a function
argument
now in this case disclosure will
implement the fn1 straight right
basically meaning it will take ownership
of the captured values and it can be
only called once
so it takes as argument
a a type of view size right
so
and this is necessary here because we
are comparing the provided argument 3
and 4 with the return value of the Len
method right this land method is defined
on vectors and it will return EU size so
that over here has to be of hue size we
have to Define that
and all this does is we can provide
disclosure an argument and it will check
is for example 3 over here is it the
same as the length of this vector
now the problem here is that we have to
change the trade bound because at the
moment we are calling the funk closure
passed as argument to this function two
times while it implements FN once
meaning it can only be called once now
what we can do over here is we take FN
right basically just taking an immutable
reference of a captured value now the
captured value in this closure here
would be X right this vector
acoustic because the closure captures it
from the environment it is defined in
and this should actually work let's see
as you can see when we pass this closure
to this function and we Define here the
closure must implement the FN trade
taking a u sizes argument and returning
a bull
then we are calling the closure right
Funk here
holds a closure so we are calling it
with three in this case this would
evaluate to true because the length of
vac is three elements right so x dot
length will return three meaning it's
equal to the provided argument and four
of course would return false
so we are here initializing a string
and over here we are defining a closure
it takes an argument and it then
modifies the string over here basically
pushing the string that was provided in
the argument
then we are calling the exact function
providing it this closure all right
then let's see
all this function does it takes a
closure as an argument
and then it will call the closure
and it will pass it a string literal
right
meaning
that
to this string as
this string literal will be pushed right
so after calling this closure
s should then hold
hello
all right
and then we just print out s
now what would be the appropriate trade
Bound for this closure
think about it we have FN FN mute and FN
once so what would be the least
restrictive approach
it would be FN mute right
because we are mutating here this string
the captured value
but we don't need to take ownership in
order to be able to mutate it right now
we have to provide the argument this
would be of type string slice right we
are passing here at this string literal
which is string slice
and then we have to provide a return
type
so actually
this won't return anything right so we
don't here have to provide
a return type so let's see if this works
and as you can see we have here a
lifetime parameter
and this is just ensuring that
the past string literal here
is actually outliving
this function exact right which is the
case because string literals remember
are static lifetime
they live the entire duration of the
program and as you can see when we print
out s it has successfully been modified
so it's sufficient to use here F and
mute but if we want we can even take
ownership
but then we have the Restriction that we
can only call this closure one time
right
so if we try that
as you can see this is working two
which trade does the compiler prefer to
use FN the closer uses the captured
value by reference
FM mute the closure uses the captured
value by mutable reference
fn1 stick closure uses the captured
value by value
on a variable by variable basis the
compiler will capture variables in the
least restrictive manner possible
for instance consider a parameter
annotated as fn1s to specify that the
equation May capture
T by reference by mutable reference or
taking ownership but the compiler will
ultimately choose based on how the
captured values
based on how the captured variables are
used in the closure
which trait to use is determined by what
the closure does with captured value
this is because if a move is possible
then any of borrows should also be
possible note that the reverse is not
true if the parameter is annotated as FN
then capturing variables by Mutual
reference or by T is not allowed
let's see number seven fill in the blank
a function which takes a closure as an
argument and calls it f denotes that f
is a generic type parameter so as you
can see we have here the function apply
and it takes as an argument a closure
and all it does it will then call
disclosure right and we have here to
define the trade Bound for the provided
closure
a function which takes a closure and
returns an i32
so over here we have applied to three
again taking a closure and we have 10 to
Define here the trade bound
the closure takes in i32 and returns an
i32
and again this function over here will
just call the closure and the difference
is it will then return The Returned
value from the closure so as you can see
over here it just calls the closure but
it doesn't return anything because
here this is a statement it's ending
with semicolon here we omit the
semicolon meaning the return value of
the closure will be the return value the
function returns
all right
so over here we have a string knittering
in non-copy type to own creates owned
data from borrowed one
so as you can see we take a string
literal and call the two owned method
now the UN now the two ohms method will
convert a string slice to a string
capture two variables creating by
reference and Farwell by value so over
here we have a closure
then greetings by reference requires FN
so
as you can see this closure captures the
greeting variable now all it does it
will print it out meaning
to take a an immutable reference would
be sufficient so the compiler will
implement the FN trade for disclosure
because it is sufficient to only take an
immutable reference to the captured
variable all right
mutation forces farewell to be captured
by mutable reference now requires FN
mute
so as you can see we are taking Farwell
and we are modifying it
now this requires far well over here to
to capture as immutable reference again
you can see that the compiler tries
always to use the list restrictive
approach
so then the compiler will instead
implement the FN mute trade for
disclosure all right
because again we capture here a variable
which needs to be mutated then manually
calling drop forces for well to be
captured by value now requires FN once
so this mem drop here allows that we
manually dropped a value from memory
right but this actually requires that we
take farewell as a value right so the
closure should take ownership of this
variable
meaning the compiler will now implement
the fn1 straight for this closure
right
so as you can see step by step
here an immutable reference was
sufficient so it just implements the FN
trade here a string got mutated so it
takes the captured values as f
as IMM mutable reference meaning F and
mute is implemented and here when a
function needs to take ownership then of
course the captured value must be
captured
as owned type meaning fn1s is
implemented
so that means if this closure implements
the fn1 straight it can only be called
once because you have inside values
that capture
the environment values by taking
ownership
Quality Function which applies to
closure
so we call the apply function here
providing it an argument diary
disclosure here right
we are calling apply and providing diary
now let's see this would be this
function and as we've seen
because Farwell here gets captured by
by value meaning the closure takes
ownership we have to Define here that it
will be a closure that implements the FN
once
trait right
now as you can see the closure doesn't
take any argument and it doesn't return
anything
so we would annotate it like that
so again this just defines that the
generic type f
must implement the FN once trade
and over here double satisfies apply to
three straight bound so here we have a
closure taking one argument
and
it Returns the result of this operation
right so we call the apply to three
function providing it as argument
disclosure
and as you can see over here apply to 3
is a closure
generic type f and V here
Define that the type f must implement
the FN trade
and as you can see it takes as an
argument an i32 and the return value and
the return type will be i32
so let's see I take disclosure here
and disclosure was passed as an argument
to this function and all this function
does is it will call the closure with an
argument of 3. now X here will be
replaced by three
and the return will be 2 times 3 which
would be 6 right
so
disclosure then returns an i32 namely 6
and as you can see because we omit here
this semicolon it means that the return
value of this closure will be the return
value of this function
so when we call this function over here
the return value over here will be 6
as you can see this is all compiling
move closures May still Implement FN or
FN mute even though they capture
variables by move
this is because the trades implemented
by closure type are determined by what
the closure does with the captured value
not how it captures them the move
keyword only specifies the letter
so the move keyword only specifies how
the captured values are captured
while the FN trades determine what the
closure does with the captured values
so as you can see we have here a string
and we have here a closure
with the move keyword meaning
values will get moved inside disclosure
now because over here as you can see as
in this case
doesn't need to be taken as value so the
closure doesn't need to take ownership
of the data because it will just print
it out right so an immutable reference
would be sufficient
and that's exactly what this says so
over here as you can see we are calling
the exec function with this closure
and when we see over here the exact
function takes us an argument a closure
that implements the FN ones
trade all right so it will in fact take
ownership of the captured value
and then in the function itself it will
just call the closure and Returns the
return type of the closure
now over here as you can see again we
have a string and we have a closure even
though we have the move keyword as you
can see we Define here that the provided
closure to exec only has to implement TF
and trade so the string s here will get
moved so basically this closure here
takes ownership
but we can still Define disclosure over
here to just Implement FN
because again
even though we are taking ownership we
are just printing out right
the difference between move and the
event rates is
the event rates
Define what the closure does with the
captured values and move defines how it
captures them so it would capture here
by taking ownership
but the FN trait only defines what are
we doing with the captured value in this
case you're just printing it out meaning
an immutable reference would be
sufficient so we can even here pass FN
and it still would work
fill in a blank so over here we have a
string
and this would be a closure that takes
an argument and returns a string
now what we do over here is pushing to
this string the provided argument right
and then what we do is we will return s
meaning the string right
so when we call over here this function
and provided the closure
then we have to implement the FN once
rate
and it will take as an argument
a string literally let's annotate that
with the lifetime parameter a
and
it will return a string right
so this would be
so this would be the trade bound we are
defining here
now why did I Implement here FN once or
why did I Define that F over here the
type of the argument must implement the
fn1 straight because as you can see we
are capturing s
and modify it now over here it would be
sufficient to use an FN mute right
now
again it would be sufficient to just use
a mutable reference to S but again we
are here returning as right we are
returning this captured variable
meaning we must be the owner to return
something
so we have to Define that F should
implement the fn1 straight
right because we are here returning s
meaning
the closure must be the owner in order
to return it
let's see
and this is compiling
input functions since closure can be
used as arguments you might wonder can
we use functions as arguments too and
indeed we can
so as you can see we have here the call
me function
Implement call me to make it work
and over here we have a normal function
just printing out something and in main
here we have a closure right also just
printing out something
then we call the call me function here
two times one time with a closure and
one time with a function
and
that means let's see
first of all we Define we want here A
type f which is generic okay so we have
to Define here a generic type parameter
and then of course we have to define a
trade bound right
so
in this case over here we are not
mutating anything and we don't need to
take ownership
and in fact over here we don't even
capture any variables right
it will just print out something
and it doesn't capture anything so in
this case FN
so in this case the F and rate is
sufficient right and by the way they
don't take any argument and they don't
return anything
so let's see
and this will be the output so we call
call me providing it to closure the
closure implements CFN trade and then
call me we'll just call the provided
function and closure
right
meaning when they are called they will
just print out this over here
course closure first because closure has
been called first
let's see exercise 10 closure as return
types returning a closure is much harder
than you may have thought of now it's
actually not that hard but you will see
fill in the blank using two approaches
and fix the error
so as you can see we have here the
create FN function and we have to Define
here the return type so let's first see
we have over here a variable that is
declared inside the function meaning num
will only live as long as this function
lives right
and then over here we are returning a
closure notice we omit here semicolon
meaning
this whole closure will actually be
returned by the function
and when we go into main as you can see
we call the create FN function
then this function should return a
closure meaning F and plane will hold a
closure basically F and claim will look
something like that
right
holding a closure meaning we then can
call the FN plane closure with a
integer all right
because we have to Define here that X
should be of type i32 because we here
capture num which is of type i32
remember when we perform an operation
both values must be of the same type
now let's see
we call the create FN function
then we initialize the num variable
and then we have here the closure that
will get returned meaning num here will
capture this variable
and
when we then call the closure over here
that will get returned by create FN
then we provided a value of 1 meaning X
will be 1 and num will be 5.
right
meaning the value the output should be
16.
when calling
let's write it here after calling the
closure itself the output should be 6.
now let's see
first of all we have to think about how
is this num variable captured
now again the compiler will use the list
restrictive approach so it will just
take a reference
problem here is
that we actually return this closure
right so num actually must outlive
this function otherwise when we return
the closure and num
gets out of scope then over here we hold
a closure that refers to something that
got out of scope so let's use the move
keyword here meaning num gets moved into
the closure so the closure will become
the owner of this
variable all right
now again here we can use static
dispatch or dynamic dispatch now I will
go first with static dispatch
so in this case we want to return a type
that implements the FN trait right
because over here we have the closure
that we want to return
so let's Implement that
disclosure should implement the FN trait
and
again over here FN is sufficient
because
even though we have captured the num by
ownership the actual closure
only performs an operation so it doesn't
modify num
and remember move defines how we capture
the closure and the FN trades Define
what
the closure will do with the captured
value alright so FN here is sufficient
and disclosure takes as an argument in
i32
right because the argument and the num
variable must match because we are
performing an operation on them
and the return type should also be i32
all right
the result of this operation
so let's see
and this is compiling now let's actually
see the output
as you can see the output will be 6.
now this is using static dispatch now we
can also use Dynamic dispatch remember
when you when dealing with trade bounds
like this
we then have to basically box this
over here
and we put this over here into a box
right
this would then be a trade object we are
using Dynamic dispatch here
so let's see
and this is also working so we have
implemented the return type in two
approaches
fill in the blank and fix the error
so as you can see we have the function
Factory taking one argument of type i32
over here we have a variable of type i32
and if x the provided argument is bigger
than 1 then this will be returned
and else if it is smaller than one
disclosure will be returned so using
here the static dispatch approach
doesn't work okay we cannot do something
like that
because over here
we don't know exactly which closure gets
returned and as you've noticed they are
identical right but in fact disclosure
is different than this because
these have been both declared and they
are located in different memory
locations all right
so even though they are exactly the same
the compiler can't know at compile time
which of these closures will get
returned because they live at different
memory locations
now what we can do over here is using
the dynamic dispatch approach
so for that again we are boxing these
closures
and we Define here that the return type
will be a box
that holds a trait object namely a trade
object that implements the FN trait
taking as argument and i32 this x here
and returning an i32
right let's see
right and we have to provide here the
main function because otherwise the
program won't compiled
and this is compiling alright see you in
the next topic
so iterators will be the last topic we
will cover together so let's Dive In
iterator allows to perform a task on a
sequence of items in turn
iterators are lazy meaning they have no
effect until methods are called that
consume the iterator to use it up
all iterators implement the iterator
trade which provides the next method
which gets called automatically when
traversing over some data
and some methods consume the iterator
While others produce a new iterator from
the provided iterator let's see the
iterator pattern allows us to perform
some tasks on a sequence of items in
turn an iterator is responsible for the
logic of iterating over each item and
determining when the sequence has
finished
so
over here we have a vector and then we
are iterating over the elements in this
vector
and as you can see the variable X will
hold in each iteration one element of
the vector
so when we print that out
as you can see in each iteration it will
just print out X which means X in the
first iteration is 1 then 2 and then 3.
in the code buff you may consider for as
a simple Loop but actually it is
iterating over an iterator by default
the for Loop will apply the into ether
to the collection and change it into an
iterator as a result the following code
is equivalent to the previous one
so this is happening implicitly
that V over here this vector or really
any collection
will be called with this into either
method meaning this collection will be
converted to an iterator right
and then we Traverse over each item
so let's see exercise one refactoring
the following code using iterators so we
have here an array holding 10
Elements which are all zero
something like that okay 10 times
then we have here a for loop iterating
from 0 to array length where the actual
length is excluded meaning from 0 to 9
right 10 times
and then we just index into this array
and print out the
and print out the element living at the
specific index
so when we execute that as you can see
we print out 10 times 0.
now again we don't have to use this
syntax we can just pass here
the array itself
and it will do exactly the same
and we have seen that the compiler
implicitly will put that into an
iterator
like that
and as you can see this would be the
exactly same thing
one of the easiest ways to create an
iterator is to use the range notation
so over here we are initializing an
empty vector right then we want to
iterate here over a range and in each
iteration we are just pushing n to the
vector
now in the end the length of this Vector
should contain 100 elements right so
what we can do over here is going from 0
to 100 meaning 100 is excluded going
from 0 to 99 meaning the vector will
then hold
elements from 0 to 99.
like that right 100 elements
and this will compile
next Method All iterators Implement a
trait named iterator that is defined in
the standard Library
as you can see this is the iterator
trade that is defined in the standard
Library it has an Associated type item
which basically refers to the type
we are iterating over for example a
vector of u8
then the item type will be u8 right and
as you can see each type that implements
the iterator trade will need to will
implement the next method taking a
mutable reference to the instance and
returning an option containing
the type of the associated type defined
here
and we can call the next method on
iterators directly
so over here we have a vector
and
we can then put that into an iterator
right
so this will then actually hold an
iterator right and not a vector anymore
so we put this collection into an
iterator meaning we then can use the
next method that is implemented for the
iterator type and that is actually
exactly what is happening when you are
doing a for Loop for example in the back
the rascompiler will just call next all
the time until it reaches a point where
there is a non-return because remember
this next method will return an option
type
so
when we put that into an iterator and
call next we will get a sum
and the first element right
then sum and two
and
as you can see
we don't have any more elements so it
will return Norm right this is the
option type and we have covered that
and when we put a collection into an
iterator it should be mutable right so
the next method takes a mutable
reference we have seen so we have to
make it mutable
all right
into iter eater and iter mute in the
previous section we have mentioned that
4 will apply the into ether to the
collection and change it into a iterator
however this is not the only way to
convert collections into iterators into
either eater and intermute all of them
can convert a collection into an
iterator but in different ways so into
ether consumes The Collection once the
collection has been consumed it is no
longer available for reuse because its
ownership has been moved within the loop
ether dispers each element of the
collection through each iteration thus
leaving the collection untouched and
available for reuse after the loop
and it remute this mutably borrows each
element of the collection allowing for
the collection to be modified in place
so as you can see we have here a vector
then we Loop over this Vector here right
and
all we do here is actually printing out
each of the elements
now we have seen that implicitly the
compiler will call here into iter
meaning the iterator will become the
owner of this data right so we can't
reuse
these are after we have put it into this
iterator
but there is not a solution we
can just use either here because it's
sufficient that we have a mutable
because it's sufficient here that we
have an immutable reference right we
just want to print it out we don't need
to mutate anything or anything else we
only need read only data right so let's
see
and as you can see
we then iterate over each element
printing it
this over here and then we can reuse the
collection over here so ownership hasn't
been transferred into this iterator
five fill in the blank so over here we
have a vector
with string literals okay
and then over here we are iterating over
the elements in this vector
now as you can see
we are here matching the element
and if it is immutable reference to the
string literal fairies then we will
actually modify
the elements that we are iterating at
this exact moment to this over here
if it is anything else then it will be
replaced by hello right
so in the first iteration
name will hold a string literal this
over here then we match this and in this
case this arm will match meaning we
assign string literal hello to this
element right so instead of Pop we would
then have hello in the first index
right
so as you can see we are mutating
meaning we can here use either mute
right we want to take mutable references
from this vector but as you can see over
here we are again using these names
Vector meaning we can't take ownership
so let's see
and this is compiling and as you can see
the first two elements got replaced by
hello and the last one ferries has been
matched here right name holds a mutable
reference to the string slice Ferries
and that's why this will get returned
meaning it will be assigned to this
element
let's see exercise 6 fill in the blank
as you can see we have here a vector
now over here we want to put this Vector
into an iterator right now before we do
that as you can see this is the vector
in the beginning and this is how it
should look like in the end so we want
to mutate the first element
so in this case we take it as mutable
references calling The Ether mute method
right so we take from here mutable
references of the elements in this
vector
then over here we can call the next
method
which will then give us back an option
type of the first element right so we
pet our match here some with the inner
value and then what we can do because we
get here
a new to the reference meaning we can
dereference it and assign it a new value
like that
so we get no output let's actually see
the elements
as you can see we changed the first
element we have mutated it using ether
mute right getting bad getting back
immutable reference to the elements
creating our own iterator we can not
only create iterators from collections
type but also can create iterators by
implementing the iterator trade on our
own types
so as you can see we have here a custom
type counter which has one field and we
Implement here the associated function
new
basically just creating an instance
and then over here we implement the
iterator trade for counter right
so first of all we have to give the
associated type a concrete type in this
case u32 right basically the type this
field is holding
then we implement the next method as you
can see next takes a mutable reference
to the instance and it returns
an option
that holds a type of the associated item
here
right it would be u32 in this case
so if self.count is less than 5
then we increment the count field here
and we return
the
actual count
otherwise we return none so if self to
account is bigger than 5 then it returns
none so as you can see we are then
creating a new instance of this counter
type
using the new Associated function
and then as you can see when we call the
next method on it right because we can
do that because we have implemented the
iterator trade for our custom type
so when we do that we just get back
T value of count as you can see
when calling next
then over here it checks is the self to
count field less than five
in this case it is right we didn't
increment it so far so it should hold
zero
and in that case it will increment it by
one right the count field over here gets
incremented by one
and then it returns it
and of course packing it into a sum
because we return here an option type
so that means we get one in the next
iteration we get 2 3 4 5 and then as you
can see the count field holds a value of
5 meaning this won't get
meaning this would evaluate to false and
this will get executed right so we will
get back a non
and over here we have Fibonacci so the
Fibonacci sequence
starts at zero then one then zero plus
one is one then one plus one is two then
one plus two is three
two plus three is five five plus three
is eight and so on right
and as you can see we have here distract
Fibonacci that has a current field and a
next field
so as you can see current for example
would hold zero and next would hold one
and as you can see we are implementing
the iterator for Fibonacci
so we Define here the return type to be
u32 right or basically the type of the
items we are iterating over so these
both of these fields hold u32
and
over here we have a function Fibonacci
which just returns an instance of the
Fibonacci struct with current holding 0
and next holding one
so notice something here when we call
next we actually want to return someone
and not some zero so this is important
but let's now implement the next method
so we have seen that it will return
option type holding self item
write the type that is defined in the
associated type item
and then over here I will create a new
variable forward
and this would then be self dot current
plus cells dot next
right because
so forward in this example would be zero
plus one right this would equal one
so we can then
to go one step forward we want to go
like this and then like this right
we can assign to self current
self next
meaning
in the next iteration the current field
will hold one right
and self.next
will hold forward
right self to current plus self dot next
meaning in the next iteration next we'll
hold one so we will be at this point
right
and then all we need to do is we wrap it
in sum because again we return an option
and we return the current
a field over here
let's see
methods that consume the iterator
the iterator trade has a number of
methods with default implementations
provided by the standard Library
consuming adapters some of these methods
called the method next we use up the
iterator so they are called consuming
adapters
so over here we have a vector
and we put that into an iter notice we
take here the iter method meaning it
will just take immutable references to
the elements
and then we call on this iterator this
sum method the sum method will take the
ownership of the iterator and iterates
through the items by repeatedly calling
next method
right so all this sum method does it
will just add together all the elements
in the vector notice sum will take
ownership of this iterator meaning we
can't use V1 eater again right so in
this case the total will be six
now I can't edit here let's see it in
the playground
so we have here a vector
and then we put it into an iterator and
then we call the sum method on the
iterator
meaning this should then hold
i32 and the value should be 6 right just
adding all of these together
now that means we can't use V1 either
again here this is not possible because
it is some method will take ownership of
the
V1 eater
variable
let's see
as you can see this is compiling
let's actually print out the result
as you can see we would have six
collect other than converting a
collection into an iterator we can also
collect the result values into a
collection collect will consume the
iterator
so over here we have
an array
which holds two tuples right
and each Tuple has as
and each Tuple has a string literal and
an i32 right
then we take this names array here put
it into an iterator notice here into
either meaning we take ownership of
these elements
and then we collect meaning we collect
it into another collection which has to
be annotated here
meaning we will then create a hash map
with string literals as keys
and i32 values right then we print it
out here and over here we have a vector
of i32 types
and we call The Ether method over here
meaning we just take references
to this vector and then over here we
call collect
meaning it will get collected
into an iterator right because we want
here V2
meaning
and then we annotate here that we want a
vector of i32 because as you can see V2
should hold a vector with these elements
let's see
and actually over here we would have
references of i32s right because again
ether here takes references of these
elements meaning they would not equate
we want a vector of I 32 elements
meaning we can call the input ether
and that means
ownership of these elements will be
transferred to V2 and this would be the
output of the print line over here we
are printing here out the hash map we
have converted
iterator adapters methods allowing you
to change one iterator into another
iterator are known as iterator adapters
you can chain multiple iterator adapters
to perform complex actions in a readable
way but because all iterators are lazy
you have to call one of the consuming
adapters to get results from calls to
iterator adapters so over here fill in
the blanks we have a vector
and we iterate over the elements just
taking immutable references alright then
over here you can see we want to modify
the elements inside this Vector to look
something like that basically just
incrementing each element
now we can use here map
to do that
right
Now map will create
another iterator it will take ownership
of this iterator here
and it will then
create another iterator
right but with the
modified elements and then we can call
here collect
to actually put it into a collection
meaning this Vector over here
let's see
all right this is compiling I guess this
would be i32
so we have taken it from this vector
so this is compiling
let's actually output
[Applause]
as you can see we have modified the
elements
but of course
V1 is still accessible
and that is because we have called here
the eater method meaning we just take
immutable references of the elements in
this vector
meaning the ownership will remain at V1
so we have now reached the end of this
course and if you have made it this far
then your dedication to this language is
really impressive and this is only the
beginning of your journey I hope this
course was helpful
don't forget to split the word about
free software and I'm out